That's so dumb!
I know, I hate the 10 minute delay.
I hate it so much.
Yeah, by the way, everything I say from now on is gonna show up on the stream.
If one of the 10 minutes are up.
I mean, I've already been live anyway, so you're showing.
Okay, cool.
Anyway.
That's crazy, you should talk to all those people, it's nuts.
I know, it's fucking insane.
I'm so glad none of us are live, you know?
When I said all those things about those people.
You should have asked for all that, it was fucked up.
Oh my god, I know.
If it goes live, everything I just said actually went out to the public.
It'll be so over for you.
We're going to court, buddy.
Yeah, it'll be so over, especially for you.
Oh, wait, wait.
I don't talk shit, man.
I can't handle confrontation.
I can't talk shit.
Yeah, you don't talk shit.
Yeah, I told him, definitely.
Okay, last week was different.
Yeah, yeah.
So, all you have to do is...
You already lied now, then.
You already lied now.
What else are you lying about, Wig?
What else are you lying about?
Listen, man.
They were jumping on my friends, bro.
I don't fuck with that.
They were fucking with my dogs.
I like that.
You just don't like that they're especially fucking with you?
Yeah, I also hate that just as much.
Don't worry, we'll be...
It was all in love.
You know, those guys know I love them.
Those guys know I love them.
Yeah, love.
If that's the love that you're giving to, like, those people...
Oh my god, the things Wig says off stream is so...
Hello?
The craziest part is you're gonna say all this and still get a fucking level 10 hype train.
By the way, for those of you in Wig's chat...
Have you guys heard of Twitch Prime?
Yeah, use it on Doki Bird.
Go to your search bar and type out Doki Bird on Twitch.
And then click on that channel and then use that Twitch Prime on your favorite streamer.
I.e.
me.
Oh no, yeah, Doki.
Doki.
Not me.
Totally not me.
Wig, why are you going off script?
We planned this.
We planned this from the start.
Wow, my bad.
My bad.
I'm going off script because I'm trying to win today.
Everything we did yesterday I'm trying to do the opposite.
Everything last week I'm trying to do the opposite of today.
You're the IGL.
We just listened to you.
What's that say about you?
You're literally the IGL.
Wait, those zones last week were hard though.
They were.
They were slightly difficult.
It's because, like, it's not run by tempo so he can't control the circles for us.
Where is this guy?
We have seven minutes left.
I'm a bit worried.
Now I'm definitely worried.
I mean, now I feel like he was hyping it up in the chat so much because he's just not awake.
He's just like...
Oh my god.
He's compensating.
Was he in your chat earlier?
Oh no, he was in the fucking Discord though saying, I'm awake, let's go, time to party.
Oh my god, yeah.
Do you think he took a nap?
No, stop it.
Don't say that.
Oh no, wait, wait, wait.
Do you have any, do you have any, like, numbers of, like, any...
I don't have his number.
You don't have Tempo's number?
No, I have no Tempo's number, I have no Hao's number, I have no one's number.
Do you have any of the TSM, do you have none of the TSM members?
No, I don't at all.
Okay.
I think we might have a problem.
We might have a huge issue.
Did you DM?
Oh, you did, okay, you did.
We might, we might have a problem.
Yeah, it's a serious problem.
Oh my god, my stream's still not live yet?
Your stream is still not live?
It's been 10 minutes.
I know.
I'm not live.
Oh my god, this was Tempo's idea too, and he's not awake.
This guy's a fucking idiot, man.
If he's not awake, I will actually lose my mind on him.
Me too.
Because he's the one that's so excited about it every time.
Yeah, he's the one that's like, yeah, it's Casper.
He's the one that's gassing up every week.
If he fell back to sleep, I'm never doing this thing again.
There's no shot.
There's no fucking way.
I can't believe he, I think he actually is asleep.
Why would he not be online?
No, I refuse to believe it.
We can't get a sub because we didn't even sign up anyone to substitute.
No, he has to be awake.
Holy shit.
I'm not playing this as a duo.
Why not?
Wait, it'll be so fun.
How far do you think we can get?
I think we can get past first round.
At least we can get past first round, you know?
Did he like wake up, like wait five minutes, see if he answers?
Just like, ah, I didn't say anything.
And just fall back asleep?
Holy fuck, dude.
We're code red right now.
Don't you literally reply?
I was like, let's go.
Oh my god.
There's a legend itself.
He's awake.
We're in real life.
Oh my god.
Where were you?
We were freaking out.
We were so nervous about you, man.
I missed this group chat.
I know, but we thought you fell asleep.
Yes, but you never appeared.
Oh.
Yeah.
Where did you go?
We're all, we're like four minutes.
Uh oh.
Wait.
I was warming up my charge rifle earlier.
We're good.
Oh yeah?
But were you?
You didn't answer a question.
I've been sleeping for like 30 minutes, though.
What?
Where were you?
I was like, I don't know.
I was cleaning.
Oh my god.
I'm a good guy, man.
Jesus Christ.
You know what you should have been doing?
Warming up, bro.
What the fuck's going on?
Yeah, you should have been warming up.
I was warming up, bro.
Okay, good, good.
I'm warmed up now too.
I'm actually warmed up.
I'm not warmed up.
Oh, what's warmed up?
Oh, yo.
Someone here's going crazy.
Doki, why don't you tell them what you got yesterday?
I got a new mask, guys.
It's so cute.
It's like blue and yellow.
Oh wait, with your new PC and everything?
No, no.
This was a different mask.
It's like a custom painted G Pro wireless.
Oh, I see.
It's super light too.
Have you ever used a G Pro wireless before?
Yeah, yeah.
My other one's a G Pro wireless.
But this one's too.
This one is number two.
Jesus Christ.
It's like my other one's G Pro is super light.
This one's G Pro is super light too.
So apparently it's lighter.
Yeah, they're pretty much the exact same thing.
No, no.
They're like three grams lighter.
Is that a hashtag ad or what?
No.
Sponsor me G Pro wireless.
Do you have connections to G Pro wireless?
Maybe.
To Logitech?
Yeah.
I was actually on, funny enough, I was on a Logitech box.
Oh, yeah.
I was on a Logitech box.
Oh my God.
Can you tell them to sponsor you?
I'm actually sponsored by Turtle Beach now.
Oh shit.
Can you tell them to sponsor me too?
Yeah, I'm down to get you.
Get all the sponsors.
All I'm saying is, all I'm saying is Turtle Beach today did tweet they're releasing new products.
And I might, I may or may not know what the products are.
That's all I'm saying.
Hey.
And they might be very, very good.
That's all I'm saying.
I do it for, I'll do it for less than he does.
That's crazy.
I'll do it for $10 less than he does.
And I'll do it better.
I'll do it for less money and I'll do it better.
And I'll make sure I'll do better.
That is insane.
Turtle Beach goes to your chat.
It gives you fucks up.
By the way, Turtle Beach, my Twitch is Dokie.
My business email is DokieCanReadAtGmail.com.
Hit me up.
Hit her up guys.
Hit her up.
Hit me up.
Hit the girl up.
Tell me you have the code and we're now?
Nah, it's not out yet.
Is that out?
Okay.
It still says a minute 20.
Nice.
I didn't warm up that whole time.
Where am I?
Where's my game?
Get on your PC bro.
What are you doing on your phone?
What?
Get on your PC bro.
Wait, that's your PC?
Are you on your PC right now?
Yeah.
What's wrong with your fucking mic?
Wait, what's wrong with my mic?
It's on your webcam, it's on your webcam.
I thought he was on his phone!
That's definitely not a microphone.
I thought he was still on his fucking phone.
Okay, what do I know?
What the fuck, what do I know?
You sound kind of the same, I think.
Yeah, you do sound the same.
What the fuck did you do?
I don't know.
My thing is on the fortune cookie.
I think?
Have you tried plugging and unplugging your phone?
No, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I think I know what it is.
I changed my mic to... er... wait...
No, yeah, this is all set to default.
Oh my god!
Okay, there you go.
Now it's better.
It's better now.
Yeah, you sound so much better.
It's so much better now.
I was changing the audio on my fucking stream, and I was like, is this better?
It's the wrong thing.
Whoops.
Whoops, I fell down.
I'm warming... guys, I'm warming up, guys, with my new mouse.
Guys, I'm doing it.
She's doing it, guys.
She's doing it.
I'm so fucking locked in now, for real.
Here?
I'm live now!
Ten minutes later!
Hey, let's go!
Live!
Ten minutes later, they're gonna hear this.
Yeah.
Oh, right.
Uh... live now?
Wait.
Right now.
I swear, lockdown is like...
Oh my gosh, I can hear myself.
Hear yourself through what, me?
I hear my... no, no, no, through my own stream.
Oh, I'm still alive!
I was crouching and I'm still alive.
What?
Everything is fine.
I'm locked in now.
We're so locked in, we're so locked in.
You guys can't hear anything, like background noise from me, right?
Nope.
No, you're good.
Nope, we're so good.
Wait, what?
We're so locked, we're so locked.
Yeah, we're so locked right now.
Very locked.
When is TSM playing right now?
Oh yeah.
For what?
Oh, are we TSM?
I was like, good!
We should actually do TSM after this, it'll be funny.
Wait, what do you mean?
We should just be TSM every time.
TSM CC.
Make them a fake name, like, we're TSM White.
Holy shit!
Wait, that's such a good idea!
People are like, bro, they actually saw the TSM, we just died.
Yeah, we should change, we should make a clans- wait, are you guys on clans right now?
Are you guys on any clans?
Clans?
I mean, how do you join a clan?
The fucking groups, what are they called?
Clubs?
Didn't they get rid of clubs?
Should we do a TSM club?
Yeah, yeah, we should do a TSM club!
Wait, no they didn't!
Why would they get rid of the best thing ever?
They actually got rid of clubs.
The best thing ever?
That shit sucks!
That shit was so useless.
But what the fuck, it's not useless to me!
It's overall just useless in general.
It's not useless to me, my opinions matter.
Did they actually?
They might have actually.
Yeah.
Oh my god, okay, guys, guys, we had to name change, remember?
Oh my god, we did not do that, no I can't do that now.
My shit's gonna get so yoinked so fast.
Wait, oh.
But don't you have Steam?
Yeah.
Then just change it on Steam.
You can't do shit on Steam.
I don't play on Steam, though.
What the fuck is your...
They got rid of the thing.
That's why I do so bad all the time.
Shit!
That's my number one issue, huh?
What do you mean you don't...
I play on an EA app.
You mean...
I'm an EA stan.
What the fuck does that mean?
It doesn't matter, we're still playing an EA game.
I'm an EA con-diosaur.
God, actually this feels better for a controller on this, I'm not even kidding.
I don't know why.
Oh my god, I can't believe it.
You were like, we're gonna name change...
That's a placebo.
...and everything.
No, it's not a placebo, bro, trust me.
You guys should play Road today and just try it, watch.
Yeah, we are.
Oh my god.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12.
No!
There's 13 teams?
There's 13 teams.
Oh, thank god.
Okay guys, if we don't get past this, who are we?
That's even better.
Oh, wait, that gives us... what if we... okay, first game, we run at teams.
We fight.
There's no way we'd lose, right?
Yeah, yeah, we just run at... we just run at teams.
Oh, yeah?
Oh, okay.
The only name I recognize here is Shops.
Who's Shops?
So we just run at... oh wait, Shops and Flake.
Are they in the same team?
No.
I don't know who that is.
They're on two different teams.
Oh.
They play a lot of... they play a lot of...
Like CC?
I wanna say they played like CC shit when Pro League was still going on.
Gotcha.
Is that bad?
Good?
Bad, right?
That means we have two teams that are good teams.
No, that means...
Two teams that are pretty solid.
That means we have two teams that we can bait into all the other teams to just kill them.
You're so smart, buddy.
Alright, so are we... okay, first game... okay, how about first game we don't run at teams just to gauge how it's gonna be like.
Yeah.
We figure out the skill level.
Yup, yup.
We can decide if we're gonna be little rats or if we're gonna be, you know, a gamer.
I mean, listen, I'm down.
I mean, listen, okay, so what do we wanna play then, first game?
Well, I'm on Bloodhound right now.
I don't even know what we're on.
Okay, you can play Blood.
We're on World's Edge.
Oh, we're on...
Oh, World's Edge, nice.
So, can we play Fuse first game?
Or do you wanna play Fuse first game?
Let's go Caustic.
This streak I'm...
Let's go.
I just wanna know right now that this streak is...
This streak I'm drinking is absolutely horrible.
Beacons.
Guys, I'm so locked in now.
I feel like you're lying to me.
Guys, no, I'm so locked in.
I'm like doing my...
Why, why?
I'm doing my scans.
I'm shooting my gun.
And like, I just one-clipped somebody.
It's already better than last week.
Yeah, that's already better.
You didn't do any of those things last week.
Yeah, I didn't do any of those things.
I barely shot my gun.
To be fair, I went a lot of close range.
I did a lot of close range guns.
Uh-huh.
I assume we'd be fighting more instead of, you know...
You think we're gonna fight more?
I don't know.
I just, I don't know.
I was told that round one would be so easy.
And this, I thought that I would be fighting more, you know?
Well, that's the problem here though.
That's the problem is that it is easy, just not really for us, you know?
Yeah, apparently.
It is the easiest round, but there is no easy round for us guys.
We're facing adversity every step of the way.
Like every step for you.
It's an uphill battle every round for us.
No matter what.
That's like a little unfortunate.
Not gonna lie, that's a little sad.
I love that though.
Doki, get in!
Wait, we have the code?
Oh yeah, code's up, code's up, Doki, code's up, Doki.
He didn't say anything!
It's okay, it's okay, we're locked.
It's alright.
Alright, alright, okay.
Give me a sec.
I won.
Alright, now I'm ready.
I literally just won my control game.
Good for you.
Okay.
Nice.
That means we're gonna win the day.
Yeah, yeah.
That's true, remember if we win our control game, it means we win.
Guys, we have to win at least one game today.
Yeah.
Okay.
Like at least, even if we go out second round again, can we at least win one game today?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, um...
Think about how exciting that is.
Best round to win will be this first game.
I can't promise anything.
Throw everyone off.
I gotta work here.
Oh my god, guys!
Guys, I have news.
Yeah?
Guys, wait.
Did Tempo leave?
Already?
Tempo, are you here?
Oh no, okay, wait.
I need Tempo to be here before I say it.
Guys, it's like really big news.
Yeah?
Yeah, it's huge news.
I feel like you're just lying so hard.
I hear you smiling behind.
Why would I wait for Tempo if it's not big news?
This guy has 100k channel points on my channel.
A hug.
Oh my god, what is he gonna do with 100k?
It's so fun every time I get a new channel.
I'm like, I'm gonna come in these lobbies.
Everyone's just like, yo, what's up, dude?
I'm like, dude, let's go.
That's the only thrill I get out of this.
Man, if only somebody remembered to do something, dude.
Wait, wait, wait.
Are we fucked, man?
Where are we landing, guys?
I don't know.
You're the IGL.
I just listen to what the IGL says.
Yeah, I don't know what the IGL says.
I'm an indecisive IGL.
I'm an uncompleted IGL.
Okay, that's like, that's not, that's the worst kind of IGL.
I don't know what the IGL says.
That's why I stopped being an IGL.
I'm like, yo, I think this is right, guys.
All right.
Is anyone, Lavas, I mean, there's gonna be answers.
There's gonna be answers.
There's no way we, okay.
Oh my god.
Okay, here's my big news.
Guys, here's my big news.
I'm on the level four hype train right now.
On Twitch.
You mother.
You're not even streaming.
You're on the level four hype train.
I'm on the level four hype train.
That's the most used shit I heard in my life.
Oh my god, it's level 5 now!
It's level 5!
Hey guys, you know I'm live!
I'm live.
You can literally give me subs and you get a reaction.
You can literally give me subs and I'll give you a reaction.
I'll give you a reaction on YouTube.
That's crazy.
I like to put types in my chat.
Follow for follow.
You got no mods, sucker.
Yes, we do!
Mod!
I have a mod.
Your channel's not live.
You got no mods on.
I thought you did multicast.
No, I don't do multicast.
I don't want to split the viewership.
And also have two chats to worry about.
Yeah, that's true.
Did you get one split your viewership though?
Huh?
I heard a lot of people on YouTube stay on YouTube.
That's fair.
And also like Fucking tempo.
Mods, fandoms, chat, advertising.
Also, I just feel like it's just too much to work to handle two chats at the same time.
I'd rather handle just one chat.
That's loud.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
Thank you guys!
Thank you for all the gifted subs on Twitch!
Oh my god, you guys shouldn't have.
Wait, wait, wait.
Do you guys know where we're going?
No.
No, where are we going?
I don't know.
Do we not claim anything?
No, we didn't claim a single thing.
No, I was waiting for Tempo to claim something.
Oh.
I just trust you, bro.
I just trust you.
Alright.
Is there any place you want to go?
Like, Syphon?
I just typed Syphon, so I said fuck it.
Wait.
I don't know if anyone's there.
Wait, what's your hype train record?
I have no idea, actually.
Okay, here's how you can find it.
You go...
How do you check it?
Okay, you... okay, let me...
No, because you're gonna make it a gold of B-Bot!
You little shit.
I should just type that.
Can we break our record?
Can we break Wig's record?
Oh, she's using you.
She's not using you to get that train up.
She's using you to get that train up.
Alright, how did it look?
Oh, she took up a hype train record.
Okay, how to know your hype train is activated.
How do you know your hype train record?
I don't think there's a... I don't think there's anything that tells you.
How...
How to figure out...
Your hype train record?
Yo, yo, yo, we're live.
Oh my god, we're in game.
We're in game now.
We're in game.
Oh shit, okay.
Sorry, this one... this thing was more important.
I got my bot in Doki's channel Are you playing Fuse or Caustic?
Yeah, I'm playing Blood.
I practiced Blood yesterday.
Don't worry.
I'm locked in guys.
I'm going to play a Valk for the Rotate Sin.
I believe in us.
I believe in us too.
What's the worst that could happen?
Nothing.
Backup plan.
If someone goes Syphon, we either go Tree or Launch Site.
They both have the thingy too.
If someone just decides to come Syphon.
I feel like someone is going to be both.
I'm trusting you with the flight too.
I'm trusting both of you because I just tabbed out.
I just tabbed out.
Why does it look like there are two teams right beside us?
I don't know.
Oh shit!
Go left!
Is this just like Evan tempo?
That's exactly what Evan taught me.
There's no one here.
Jesus Christ, what a start.
Guys, I don't know.
I have two destructor rounds.
You guys keep it in the middle.
We have both beacons.
This is perfect, guys.
At first I thought like maybe we're going to do this.
Now I don't know after that.
No, I mean...
I'm more locked in today than I was last week.
I'll tell you how much.
What the fuck?
What the fuck happened last week?
What the fuck, man?
What the fuck?
If you were locked in the first week...
If we were in last week, we would have won.
Yeah, if you were locked in, we would have to do this again.
No, I was locked in just now.
I was locked.
We would have to do this again if you were locked in last week.
Oh my God.
We're a team here, guys.
We were going to compete about our win.
Yeah, but you weren't thinking about the team when you weren't locked in.
I was like this coach right now.
I was knocking on your guys' house.
I was knocking.
Check fucking mate, bitch.
Yeah, that's my fault.
That's on me.
That's my bad.
There's a havoc here.
If anyone wants in.
I'm actually kind of solid right now.
I'm both.
Oh, yo.
We got a staggy.
Yeah, we can go fast too if we need as well.
All right.
I'm at 6x.
Does anyone want the 6x?
No, I'm good.
Where's the thing?
The beacon?
No, the...
I dropped a charge rifle with the...
Okay.
Are you okay?
Evil cash.
He's talking about the evil cash.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm going to go scan the...
The brain just turned off.
I'm just going to scan the people.
Templar, I paid the charge rifle.
Do you have one already?
No.
Okay.
It's in this building.
It's clearly the first floor.
I'm not using it.
I'm going to get the evil cash.
If I die for it, just run away.
All right.
That's fine.
We cannot craft you, but that's fine.
I have two destructor rounds.
Let's get this together.
Does anyone have an alternator?
No.
Nope.
No, sir.
I'm going to do the thing.
Where do we go?
We're going to go straight to stacks for sure.
It's going to be a stacks end game.
Okay.
We're coming over to you.
Yeah.
We'll just go from like...
We'll just go over here.
Just go towards this balloon.
All right.
We should be good to go.
I'm beside you a wig.
Why am I too low?
I can't really hear.
Have you ever considered turning up the volume?
Raising it?
Yeah.
Actually, I was just thinking that right now.
I was just saying like if that's a problem, you could...
There's no way.
For me, it's a very easy solution.
There's only one team at stacks right now.
Yeah.
I mean, that's so crazy though.
Why?
I mean, I guess because we could take this fight if we wanted to.
Yeah, I'm not against it.
Let's see.
Then we die 13th, which is first.
Yeah.
Yeah, one point already, guys.
Where do we go?
What do you mean already?
Well, you're going first?
Yeah, you guys...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Don't worry, guys.
We're going here, right?
Yeah.
Don't worry.
The bloodhound will go first, scat, and then die.
Yeah.
I can't scan when I'm in the air.
What do you mean?
What kind of flying was that?
I was scared.
I didn't want to have cover.
I was so scared.
Oh god, I'm very bad at this.
Ready?
3, 2, 1.
Nice slide.
Are we grabbing this thingy?
No.
Just come here.
And then we'll grab it if we're able to.
Look, people.
They're going mod, which I don't agree with.
I'd rather just play from here.
Oh yeah, we can scan the people beacon and I can scan the beacon beacon.
I don't know if it's safe to scan.
Is it safe to scan?
Yo, someone else landed.
Other building.
Oh, they're in the other one.
We're good.
We just play from here, I think.
I don't know if it's gonna pull back side, but I'd rather be up here for the Valkyrie.
Who's gonna look at this team over there?
Uh...
I'll look over there.
I'm just gonna look everywhere to be honest.
Alright.
I have a longbow.
Let's get some shotguns.
I hope they don't shoot me in the back.
You guys need bats?
That would be so awkward.
Oh.
I do.
I have zero.
I just do.
Yeah, take that other one.
Let's tell them what needs all of them.
No, no, no.
I don't have...
If you guys find more shield cells, let me know.
I only have like five.
Oh, I got you.
I can give you some for sure.
I have five.
Oh, they're gonna fucking take your shit.
I dropped four down here.
Uh...
This blow ball doesn't grab them.
I don't think it will.
Oh!
If they grab it, we run at them.
Yeah, I agree.
Okay, that sounds like a terrible idea.
That's a great idea.
I'm down.
Fuck those guys.
If they kick my loot, bro, we get after it.
Exactly.
I hate motherfuckers who steal loot.
I'm taking a hundred shots of a longbow here.
I steal loot.
Do you hate me?
Yeah.
Wow.
No hesitation.
Yeah.
Very, very much so.
Wait, wait, wait.
Try and grab the Evo.
No one's gonna kill you right now.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Try, try, try.
I bet you no one's gonna kill you.
Alright, if I die, let me know.
I bet you.
I bet you like...
One gifted sub.
I bet you you're okay.
Okay.
Well, I'm already here.
I didn't really hesitate.
A whole one gifted sub that no one's gonna kill you.
What if I get landed on?
It's like, and then if you live, you gotta give me one sub.
How does that work?
Cause it's a bet, you know?
I won the bet.
I'm gonna deny that.
I won the bet, though.
Someone kill me.
Oh, we're vibing.
We're so good, guys.
Look at our lock.
We're so locked in.
Yeah, we got our zone plan, man.
Yeah.
There's actually the highlight of my week, sadly, every time.
The challenger second?
Yo, what are you gonna do after this weekend?
What the... did you watch the fucking finals of the last CC and this is the highlight?
I know.
And the whole time I was like, damn, we could've been us, guys.
We could've been the... that could've been us.
It is gonna be us.
I just killed one.
Oh my charge rifle!
Oh my gosh!
Yo, I don't have a charge rifle yet.
I pinged the charge rifle for you.
What happened?
There's one downstairs.
Oh, there's one downstairs?
I think third floor or second floor.
I'm not sure which one.
I'm in.
Let's go revenge.
That fucking smoked.
Whoa.
I'm trying to... slap me.
I was nuts.
Oh my gosh.
I can't stand up there anymore.
Where's that from?
Okay, front side?
Yeah, this side.
Here, I'll stand in the back.
There.
That's where they are.
It was not on third floor.
They broke your barrel, Semu, by the way.
Over here.
I'll break their face.
Whoa!
In game, bro.
You don't wanna get twitched.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Not that.
Bro, because I would definitely report you.
Oh, I found it.
Get your subs from my train.
Yo, does someone need that?
What?
The heavy mag?
No, I already have a purple.
What are you shooting from?
Bro, keep scaring me.
This guy is just so annoying.
I need to find a better scope now.
I found my charge rifle.
We're fine.
Good luck with that.
Yeah, good luck with that.
Bro, I don't think... guys, my eyes aren't working yet.
I would just keep scanning.
Oh, no.
Not this again.
I feel like my eyes... I see the frames, but my eyes...
Yeah, yeah.
They're a little half right now.
It's so bad for us.
They're not fully open yet.
What, how am I literally not having eyes yet?
It's not good for me.
I thought you had a scan.
That's why I scanned some...
Yeah, so she can see bright orange things.
Oh, God.
We're so buff.
I have no sniper.
I have a bunch here.
Oh.
I'm gonna go.
That'll be 16.
You got more out of her.
Oh, my God.
Guys, I dropped that and another bat.
Nice.
That's me.
Tom, Tom.
Found some loot.
Whoa.
Where are they shooting us from?
Oh, my God.
I knocked this shit all in.
Don't.
Oh, my God.
Get fucking shit on.
Anyway, how much meds did you waste for that knock?
Not that many, actually.
Only one Phoenix so far.
Oh, nice.
That's good.
I'm gonna get purple.
You think I can scan this?
Yeah.
I'm gonna do it.
You knocked him.
He's gonna be...
They're so scared.
Yeah, they're scared now.
They think I'm shooting ice and I got my purple guys.
Oh, nice.
Okay.
There is...
One, two...
Two teams.
That doesn't have...
These teams are slowly rotating in.
Yeah, we're good right now.
We're vibing.
We just play here.
Whoa.
You missed every shot.
Is he on the roof?
Yeah.
Oh, that was really bad.
I was looking at the map.
Yeah, that was pretty bad.
Yeah.
He missed every shot.
He still missed.
Wow.
If that team over there is higher ranked than us, then there's a problem.
There's a problem.
In this system of Apex Legends, there's a problem.
There's a big issue actually.
Oh my God.
We're at level 10.
We're gonna break Wig's record.
I'm so proud of you guys.
Thanks guys so much, guys.
Yeah, thank you guys.
Thank you guys.
Don't worry.
Wig is not taking any cut of this.
Yeah.
No.
I should.
Where's my IGL pay at?
Which is crazy.
Where's your IGL pay?
If we can't get it, we're gonna lose.
We get passed round two.
That's where the pay is.
Is that in our contract, if we get passed round two?
Yeah.
I'm not going to fucking get paid.
Okay.
Yeah, you'd get paid.
Wow.
I'm not getting paid anytime soon, guys.
I'm going to be looking for a job real quick.
This is your job now.
You can't break this contract or you'll have to pay me a million dollars.
What are you doing?
Aren't they throwing it?
No, I'm just throwing it.
Oh, hey there's a Watson team underneath us.
Team 10 eliminated.
That's not us guys.
That's not us!
Not us!
Can I scan the people's... I can only scan it once, right?
Even if it's a new ring?
No, I think per round, can't you?
Per ring, right?
I'm not sure.
I actually don't remember.
It's bad that I don't know that.
Yeah, that's pretty bad.
Yeah, I can't do it.
Only once.
You have many...
How many fucking games...
What the fuck?
I'm dead, I think.
I'm running back.
No, there's nobody near you.
Where did I just get shot from then?
Where the fuck did you get shot?
I thought that sounded on me.
Okay, clearly Wig's ears aren't working.
That's why?
You're scanning East?
Wig's ears are not working.
No, wait, wait.
Is someone in that building?
They have to be.
Yeah, they are.
Down there.
Okay, okay.
I'm gonna scan you for a second.
They were definitely in there before.
Tempo, what the fuck are you jumping on there?
Tempo, what the fuck are you doing?
They're to our left.
I'm trying to 4-8-X.
Oh my god, that 4-8 though.
There's a team right here running.
Don't worry, you can't catch me.
There's a team over behind this rock, by the way.
I got something to Southwest.
There's a team in this building Southwest.
I got 4-8 now.
Everyone's dead.
Nice.
Oh, I just dropped off from so far away.
Can you res, T-Rex?
What the hell?
Run away, Wig.
Res now, res now.
Don't worry.
Nobody is gonna show up.
Anyone have a Phoenix kit?
X1 or no?
No.
I only have shield cells.
They just literally all three shot me.
I just got repeater charge rifle.
Where are they shooting from?
Like all the way from the dome.
The team that he knocked at, they're very mad about now.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They're really mad.
I don't have... I just have like 3 shield cells, but I do have 2 bats, so...
Yeah, I'm fine.
Oh, there's team Portland right now.
Oh, I'm gonna be there.
They're in the RV.
I see that.
Oh my god, it's your favorite spot.
Yeah, that spot sucks on me.
What do you mean?
We got like 2 second bases from that.
That should have happened though, if we're being honest.
Over here, by the way.
I'm running away.
I'm trying to shoot them right now.
I'm hitting.
I cracked him.
I cracked 2.
I cracked 3.
You're such a fucking liar.
I still fuck with you after you're a liar.
One shot, one shot.
They're one shot.
Got one.
Wait, over here.
Where?
Over here?
I helped.
Can I actually get the knock?
Full kill?
No.
No, I don't think so either.
No, they have room behind the thing.
That sucks.
Barely though.
That blows.
Good knock though.
Yeah, good knock.
I helped him, by the way.
Yeah, you did.
Yeah, for sure.
They're dying up there, 4Tempo.
You're actually a beast for that.
They're getting ran at now.
You're a beast.
Oh my god.
Oh yeah, they're getting sent out.
Oh no, I missed.
I am so much more warmed up this week than I was last week because I'm actually hitting shots right now, which is crazy.
Wait, what does that mean?
Last week?
Last week I did harm.
I did harm.
Guys, we're top 10.
We practically qualified.
We gotta keep wall jumping.
This sounds really good for us, by the way.
We're chilling.
Chilling?
Okay, nice.
Yeah.
1, 2, 3, 4.
What's in the pack?
Oh, wingman.
I need to keep scanning these packs.
You guys gotta remind me if I forget.
This team of big monies is coming too.
There's no teams like next to us anymore.
Yeah, we're good right now.
I think they're only on the southwest side.
Yeah, I think they went this way.
Southwest side?
Ashtp?
Where did they...
Oh, I see it.
Now it's knocked on?
Why does it take it so long?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I see headshot.
I see headshot on him.
Oh my god.
I gotta reload.
I can't shoot him yet.
I'm waiting for him to move.
He's not gonna move.
Yep, I'm watching.
Hit him 25 again?
I'm just gonna keep watching him.
Me too.
Alright, I'm gonna look at the other directions.
We'll watch him and then just make sure you can never clock.
Yeah, that's what I'm literally doing right now.
I'm not letting him clock out.
This sucks.
I think there's a team underneath us.
There's people underneath us now.
Yeah, there's like here.
They're directly underneath us too.
Oh, is that on us?
We're fine right now.
We're fine.
You have enough barrels down?
Right, Demo?
You're good?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm still watching that corner.
I am too.
There's a...
There's a team fighting over here.
He's still there, bro.
He's still there.
He's getting shot.
Nice job.
Someone else?
That was me.
I have over 96 headshots.
Oh my god.
Okay.
I heard that thing and then I turned around and it was just you.
Oh, good.
You're good.
He's a Wraith.
Why isn't he queuing up?
The one I just cracked was a Wraith, wasn't it?
Well, I mean if he's not queuing up, then I'm not gonna be able to kill him.
I don't think it's a Wraith anymore.
Why is he queuing up?
Oh, he went up.
He went up.
It wasn't a Wraith.
There's a team.
Yeah, it was.
Oh, then why the fuck didn't he not queue?
I don't know.
What a fucking idiot.
Yeah, what an idiot.
I'm not really sure as to why he would not queue.
Why would he pick Wraith?
Yeah.
They're just shooting.
Wait.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
On me.
Shit done.
What the fucking audio was that?
Oh my god.
What the...
Bruh.
There's no way.
You guys are good.
I'm down below.
Play it.
I have to get down.
Are you fucking kidding me?
If you all want to drop first floor, you can.
Throw the caustic barrel.
Oh, they got the caustic.
You guys can come first floor if you want.
It's up to you.
Are they on first floor?
No.
They're not.
They're never going to drop down and hit dead stick and fight you though.
Nice.
Probably.
Tempo jumped down already.
Doki.
No.
I'm going to stay here for a bit.
No audio, bro.
Again.
No.
This is why I did it.
Yo, honey's kids.
I'm going to stay here for a bit.
This is why I didn't jump down.
No, it doesn't matter though.
We were dead.
You guys are going to get sent on the dogmas.
Yeah.
You're so fucked.
Doki, live.
Oh, no.
Where is that audio?
Are you fucking kidding me?
Oh.
They're evacing on you.
For sure.
No.
They're evacing.
Oh.
No.
They're sending you.
Well, if you just drop down to first floor, you can grab both our banners and rez us now.
There's no way.
Play it.
I'm going to go to the path, by the way.
I was sick.
Doki, you can rez us.
Trust me.
There's no fucking way.
I'm not rezing you guys.
Play your life.
Don't listen to that guy, man.
Plug us in.
Where?
Plug you where?
Wait.
Okay.
You're going to stand this white side.
You got this, bro.
You got this.
We don't plug you in.
Please.
Enlighten me.
Nowhere.
This guy's an idiot.
There's a horse guy.
In the zone.
I think you craft the battery here.
Imagine.
I don't know, man.
I already have a bat.
I can't believe they just three men took a zip line.
I'm so sad.
I mean they lived.
Is it really a throw?
Oh no, it wasn't a bad play.
It was a good play.
I didn't know what floor they were on underneath us.
I thought they were first floor on us.
I know they were right underneath us.
Whoa, whoa, there you go.
Whoa, whoa, I got the thing.
Wait, wait, we got seven points.
Is seven three points?
Seven points for sure.
Oh yeah, yeah.
I'm gonna use the bathroom.
Go for it, you're good.
Go do your thing.
I mean there's no way we just don't qualify, so we're fine.
I mean, I think we probably still need a few kills here or there.
Oh yeah, we'll be fine.
I'm not worried about it, bro.
We're no way we get top seven every game.
Should we get three other games to make up for it?
That is insane though, bro.
I cannot believe that...
They actually just three minutes in and I was blind.
There was no audio at the last second.
That was crazy.
Wait, was the zipline going?
No, I told Doki to scan underneath us.
I don't think she did.
I told her to scan underneath.
Wait, wasn't that zipline the other way?
No, no, no.
From the roof to the roof or something?
No, it was the zipline on the floor underneath us.
I asked Doki if she could scan underneath us.
I don't think she did.
I thought they were on the first floor, not the run underneath us.
If I knew they were underneath us right now, I would have told you to put barrels on the ziplines.
Well, there was one barrel in...
No, yeah, yeah, yeah, totally.
It just sucks.
Three men took it.
Unfortunate.
The team's alive here.
I don't know.
I mean, it's a pretty easy zone to live.
It sucks.
That blows, man.
Three fucking men sent us in.
And a bunch of shitheads.
We can get revenge next game.
Oh, yeah.
Alright, I'm gonna use the washing tool.
I'll be right back.
Oh, man.
Wow.
Yo, yo, yo.
Ay.
That could have been us.
Hell no.
This could have been us.
Not a chance.
Are they winning this?
No, they're losing this.
1v3.
Oh, my God.
That could have been us right there.
We could have been that team with second place.
I can't believe that I didn't hear any of those.
I had no idea they're on the floor underneath us, bro.
I cannot believe that they just three men took a zip on me.
That is so unfortunate.
Crazy Party's almost alive, too.
Yeah, you almost survived.
Wait a minute.
We could have helped you there, too.
Yeah, it sucks.
It was just so fast.
You know what's fucked up?
What?
What's up?
I've been timed out for one hour.
Where?
In my chat.
I wonder where you...
In my chat?
No, in my chat.
Because he kept advertising his own channel on my fucking...
Yes.
...on my chat.
Good for you.
I look over and I'm like, what the fuck?
All right, what place are we at?
We're gonna be in like, what, ninth place now?
That's mean.
All right, we gotta make a new lobby, right?
Yeah, there's video code.
Yeah, yeah.
Most likely.
Yeah, it's snowing.
All right.
Oh, wow.
Fuck me, man.
What?
What's wrong?
I can't believe that's got three men sitting there.
Oh, shit.
It's all right.
It's because someone didn't change their name.
Well, I should find the Lombo charge level.
That's a clear indication of who they're at.
We're in seventh.
All I'm saying is, is somebody changed their name.
Yeah.
I don't know.
Six people's first place.
My God.
Maybe I should have made a just nice rigged thief.
No.
Seven place.
We do have a good team.
We just need to have good, consistent games.
It would be so sad if this is the fucking week we get knocked out first round and we get the easiest.
Oh, would they imagine?
Jesus.
First round would be really bad.
We're really bad.
Technically, this is like better...
Technically, this is supposed to be easier for us.
No, no.
The first round is harder for us.
Round two is going to be the easiest.
Round three will be the most difficult.
Yeah, yeah.
Round three will be easier.
Round three will be the most.
Round two will be normal.
I meant like for this round one should be easier than last week's round one.
So it would be very fucking awkward if you know.
We did not make it through?
Yeah.
That would be so awkward.
We are in.
So awkward.
We're in seven?
Alright, we're fine.
We're so good.
Guys, literally we have to actually be the worst to not qualify.
No offense, we're bad but we're not the worst.
What if 11, 12, and 13 are watching your stream right now?
That would be so mean.
We got a lot of work on.
Somebody of them.
11th, 12th, and 13th place are watching your stream and they just feel sad because you called them the worst in the game.
Damn.
That's pretty fucked up.
I thought you were nice.
I thought you were a nice person.
Yeah.
What happened?
You've changed bro.
You fucking changed.
He started competing and then he changed.
Yeah, you used to be a nice guy.
What do you mean?
Bro, code's up.
Code's up?
Nice.
Where is it?
Discord?
Oh, okay.
I see it.
Oh, you were not ghosting us.
You were just not here.
We said good things about you.
We didn't respond back.
We said good things about you and then you didn't respond back.
And then we got sad.
I got a monster guys.
I can't believe it.
I stole it from NoCo.
I'm getting bullied just like I was last year.
What are we talking about?
You changed man.
There's no difference.
We were saying the nicest things ever about you.
And then you just disappeared on us.
I'm an unconfident IGL.
Indecisive IGL.
There's just so much nice things.
Why are you so harsh on yourself bro?
We're talking...
Bro dude.
Why are you so mean to yourself?
The first step is acknowledging that you matter.
After berating me for like nine hours?
Dude, why are you so tough on yourself?
Yeah, man.
What the fuck?
Where's your self esteem?
Where are you at bro?
What's going on?
How's your confidence up?
You little shithead.
Too bad you don't have a chat to the fact checkers.
Not now.
In ten minutes I will.
In ten minutes?
Yeah, in ten minutes.
But you don't even know where that's supposed to be about.
Wig and Tempo so serious.
Doki shoots in the air.
Cracked four.
What?
She missed like 75 shots and she's like, Cracked three?
Oh my god.
I watched the team she was shooting.
I was hitting them and she hit zero shots.
I watched it all happen in front of me dude.
No, no, no.
It was cracked.
You know that.
You don't have the POV on my screen.
Yeah, I'll get it in ten minutes.
Ten minutes.
I'm pretty sure jokes on you.
There's no rewind on my stream.
You gotta wait until the VOD's over.
Delete spot.
You can't see anything.
I hit them all.
What do you mean?
I hit all of them.
You guys just don't understand.
My chat's just spamming audio.
Cause I just got fucking rocked in the game.
I actually shit myself.
I couldn't even know if I was scared.
I actually couldn't even know if I was scared.
I did not know there was a zip there.
To be honest bro, I knew the zip was there.
But I just had no idea there was a floor underneath us.
That's my bad.
You're the bloodhound.
I didn't scan there.
I didn't know.
I didn't have my scan.
Bro we should have those tag names.
You see those people with the AES9?
Where?
Oh my god.
For the third game, let's all change our name to TSM.
That's so funny.
People on the competitive Apex.
They'll be like, Rick got signed to TSM.
Wait, did you see the post about us a couple weeks ago?
When we first announced it.
They were like, this team is going to do awful.
People thought we were playing these serious.
I was like, dude there's no way people think we're serious.
Dude, what the fuck?
They were like, who's going to IGL?
I understand how this team thinks they're going to do well.
Why are they participating if they're not going to win?
They're going to throw it.
I remember I saw someone tweeted something like, these people are making fun of the competitive integrity of TSM.
Yeah, we are.
Yes we are.
They're not going to take it seriously.
Why are they joining the CC?
Yeah.
That just proves that if we do better than you, then what the fuck?
What are you doing?
Yeah, what the fuck are you doing?
That's what I'm saying.
The last time I touched Apex...
Okay, that's...
I played Apex yesterday.
The last time I touched Apex competitive was the last Apex.
You played Apex yesterday?
Yeah.
Why are you so bad today?
I bought a new mouse!
Why are you so shit today?
What the fuck, man?
I'm literally on a new mouse.
Like, what the fuck do you want from me?
Oh, fuck, dude.
To be fair, I...
Three grams difference.
Is that actually a big difference in mice?
Yeah.
Oh, actually...
I don't know.
I think I'm doing pretty alright.
I'm doing pretty okay with the three grams of...
No, you did great.
They both feel exactly...
I mean, yeah, three grams really throw off my gameplay for sure.
No, no, throw mine off.
She's right.
No, did you guys not see the four people I cracked?
No, no, I actually didn't see those people.
I really gotta watch her VOD back.
Look at my POV.
I cracked like four to five people.
And then, like, nobody cared.
I'm so...
Oh, wow.
I'm so sorry.
No, not you making me feel bad about a crack that didn't happen.
I did all that work and no one cared.
Yeah, no one appreciates me.
Alright, wait.
Who's going middle?
I'm going left.
I got middle.
I need the thing.
Oh, we got hot drop.
Wow.
Give me a golden charge rifle.
Okay, that's asking a lot.
I hope we find that for you, buddy.
I can only imagine how big your smile would be picking that thing up.
That's enough to make me want to give you one.
Big golden stick.
Alright.
Whoa.
You called it a big golden stick.
Uh...
Here's a 3x if anyone needs it.
I'll actually take that.
Where's the sound nail?
Let's see.
If anyone finds a vault and not use it, let me know.
There was a vault in my room somewhere.
Oh, I almost got run over by the...
Guys, I drank some coffee now.
I'm so locked in.
My eyes are a little bit more open now.
I got a blue helmet here for anybody.
Oh, I was muted.
Anyone need a gold heavy mag?
Yeah.
Me, me, me, me, me.
Backpack.
Oh my god, there's another...
Is someone taking that gold energy mag?
Me.
Me, me, me, me, me.
Me, me, me, me, me, me, me.
There's a purple...
Oh, a light mag.
Alright, where's the evil caches?
I'll get the evil caches next to me.
Yeah, you're good.
And then I'll scan the people scanner.
There's a purple helmet.
That'd be great.
No, I haven't found a single charge rifle.
I haven't seen one either, buddy.
Sorry.
I know it's tough for you out here, bud.
I know.
What are you gonna do with your life when you don't have your charge rifle?
I have all the stuff for a charge rifle.
I just don't have the charge rifle.
I don't have the charge rifle.
Wait, I found it.
I found it.
I'm rich.
I'm trying to find him.
He found it.
Okay, that's gonna be a skyhook zone for sure, obviously.
I think it's gonna pull probably towards the back of skyhook.
Around that area.
We had zero kills last game?
Yeah, 7th place though.
We had zero kills?
Oh, kill smells.
Oh my god, I cracked all those people just for zero kills.
Just to get nothing out of it.
Now how would people know I actually cracked them if you guys didn't?
Yeah, I think that actually might be our fault.
I got a golden ball here.
I'm gonna scan people.
Golden balls?
Oh, I got a gold knockdown.
Holy shit.
We had to rotate.
Yeah, we should definitely leave.
I have the gold mag for you too, Doki, by the way.
For what?
Oh, the heavy.
Okay.
Oh, I almost fucking landed on the lava.
I'm gonna drop it over here and we're just gonna rotate it.
We could technically have a free rotate if we just go fast.
No, we could definitely get this out of here.
We gotta grab that one, and then we gotta grab that one, and then we gotta grab that one.
I think we're gonna skip that and we're gonna go through Fragment and get that one instead.
And then go through whatever it is.
Alright, I'm here.
Fuck that balloon.
I'm here.
Alright, we're gonna go through Fragment and then we're gonna go to Grandmaster Blue Vins.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's the goal.
We should be able to hit this rotate pretty clean.
I don't think it was gonna be able to...
Wheeeee!
I'm waiting for the coffee to set in.
You're good.
Wheeeee!
Okay, we're gonna go to that Evo Cache and Fragment, alright?
Alright, alright, alright.
That's the goal here.
We'll all run together.
We're fine.
There's gonna be no one in there.
And then we're gonna go to Blue Vins over here.
And get this one and hit people's heads and then Valkyrie into the zone.
Oh my god, you're so smart, Wig.
This is why you're our IGL.
God, he has a plan.
Wait, do you have your gold heavy mag?
I do.
You want it?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Actually, did you drop it up here and pay it last for you?
No, it's fine.
I got it.
Nice, there you go.
Yay!
See, my IGL cares.
I do.
I care so much about you guys.
Don't believe any of those people that said you don't care.
Don't believe all the people in my chat saying that you're horrible, man.
They were wrong about you.
They were so right.
They're so wrong about you now I know.
Yeah, you just get me.
Never believed in those haters.
Oh, never.
Alright, let's keep walking up.
We're gonna go to that blue bay to get that EvoCast again.
Wee.
Let's do it.
I'm also gonna get rid of this.
I don't know if I want to one or two.
I'm dropping it.
No, I don't need it.
I need one.
No, we're good.
Two times?
Oh, I'll get the two times actually.
Sure.
No, we're not.
Oh.
Yeah.
They should rotate out of it like a way.
They shouldn't find us here.
Yeah, because they're like, oh, I'm scared.
Woo, people.
I don't know what they're thinking.
Nah.
What else would we be thinking of?
Well, they might not think it's us, so they might actually be scared.
Yeah, they'll be like, oh, I'm scared.
Alright, let's keep this rotating.
You guys ready?
Keep on moving?
Yeah, I'm ready.
I'm here.
Alright, we're gonna get this EvoCast.
Then we're gonna go people scan like they did.
Then rotate into sky.
Oh, and then I can charge rifle everyone.
Yeah, when we get in sky.
Yeah, we hit a Valko at the end there too.
Oh yeah, we get right here.
Oh yeah, that sounds juicy right there.
Oh yeah.
I love juicy.
Whoa.
This is like a Christian friendly stream.
Oh yeah.
They're not riding us, right?
No.
Oh, you scanned already?
Not the building?
No, we didn't need to go there.
There's no way.
Oh god, oh god, they might be in here.
They left 60 seconds ago.
Okay, nice.
See you guys.
I walked through the whole living and Ducky's like, yeah, we can scan that real quick.
We're fine.
What are you so worried about?
You're so paranoid.
What the fuck are you two teams doing?
The team already top sky.
We pushed them off top sky.
They might not be in there.
Come over to me.
They might not be in the top area.
They might be on the bottom.
If they're not in the top, do we just play one of these buildings?
Or if they are in the top, yeah.
They are.
They're Dacia, Rampire.
We're just gonna go four story here.
Which one?
This one?
Yeah, four story here.
Okay, I'll scan.
We should be fine.
I don't think it was in here.
Yeah, there's nobody.
I don't need to scan then.
Yeah, we can all just rotate out if we need to.
If the zone goes towards that diner side more over here, we're gonna make a rotation to the next diner on the right and then just keep walking through, okay?
Oh my.
Okay, I didn't hear what you said, Wig.
What did you...
Okay, so basically, if the zone keeps pointing to the right over here, which I'm not sure it's gonna, we're gonna just rotate down through these diners and just go through the first floor.
I'm paying attention.
Sorry, I couldn't multitask because Tempo was getting shot.
No, it's okay.
It's scary.
Yeah, yeah.
I was worried because he was on the roof.
Yeah.
And I was getting deja vu.
He scares me the most when he's getting shot, we're being honest.
Yeah, honestly.
When he's getting shot, he most likely might die.
Don't worry, I'm not on a...
I'm in a room.
I'm not on a roof, so we're good.
You're really...
I think your arch nemesis is a roof.
What the fuck?
What are you shot at here?
Oh, he's like...
I wanna fucking get rid of...
Is that a fucking Watson thing?
Good barrels down below, Tempo.
Okay.
Oh my god, he's being proactive.
Look at you, bud.
That's actually good barrels too.
Let's fucking go, man.
Actually good barrels down.
What a fucking compliment slap.
Whoa!
Tell me what up.
Who was it, dude?
Little shithead?
Oh no.
There's some people on the roof.
They are on the rampart.
They touched, and it was not fun.
Oh my god, bro.
Their setup is crazy scary.
They're diabolical over there.
I can only shoot this team now.
The other team has a bloody rampart.
Yeah, I'm scared of that team.
Not gonna lie.
We can't even do anything against them.
I'm scared.
I don't even want to fucking peek that shit.
Does someone want my charge rifle after?
Oh, no.
I already got purple.
Can I get that Kraber?
That's really far.
That's really close to this team.
I know, but fuck me.
Do it.
If I die, then we are so fucked.
Okay, yeah, don't do it.
No, no.
You can get the beacon, but you can't.
I was just chalked.
Shoot, fuck off, charge rifle guy.
I'm just gonna hang out here.
Wee.
I have my purple up now, too.
Which is good.
How did you get your purple?
I scanned a package and then I got shot.
Oh.
I need like 50 shots.
I don't know who to shoot at because it's just that team and then the team, the rampart team.
There's like no one else for me to shoot at.
I'm gonna chug another.
I'm gonna chug this coffee.
I said that kid 106 might knock this kid.
Nah, he's not peeking me, bitch.
Little bitch.
Nooo.
Okay.
Let's try and get this one shot in for that 50.
Come on, somebody peek.
Somebody open that door.
Just think about me for a sec, team.
Alright, let's see where this sound's going.
Alright, well.
I think I kinda wanna move right, but I don't know.
I think we just stay here for right now.
Yep.
Oh my god.
I'm literally fucked.
I'm alive.
I'm five away.
Is there any way to get under these guys on the roof?
Like in the middle?
I don't think so, right?
Under these?
Oh, in the middle.
Yeah.
Without dying?
I don't know if we could right now.
We maybe could, honestly.
It just depends.
We have no smokes, which sucks.
Yeah, we only have the scans.
Yeah.
And there's nobody.
There's no one on there?
They left?
What?
Which one?
The middle.
You scanned the middle.
You didn't get anything.
No, they're there.
I just didn't remember.
I did not hit.
My range wasn't...
They just low-balled us in the middle.
Woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah.
It's okay.
I'm gonna use my bat.
I wasn't paying attention, but it's okay.
I'm paying attention now.
You're doing great.
Thank you.
See, positive reaffirmation improves the player.
Yeah.
Oh, you're so right.
You should do that to me more often.
Well, like, it only works for certain players.
Oh, so I'm not one of those?
I do better game before I have a sub through, actually.
You're so right.
I'm a better player.
I'm my role model.
It works for certain players is crazy.
If it works for...
I don't know if it works for TSM, who's the number one team.
I don't know.
You're so right.
Oh my god, stop looking at me through the rampart wall, you freak.
I need five damage.
I'm gonna scan the top of this.
Yeah, see, they're still there.
Yeah, they are.
They're playing really weird.
I want to get this care pack in front of us.
What is it?
It's a fucking...
Oh, I don't need to shoot anymore.
Nice, I got you.
I got you.
I kinda wanna...
Wait, how did you get purple?
It's like he scanned another packet.
I'm gonna try to get this one.
Let's see if I can do it.
Oh.
It's gonna be really risky, actually.
Can you guys shoot this building?
Yeah, we're shooting.
We're looking at them.
I'm looking at them, but I don't see any of them.
Yeah, they're not looking at us.
I think they're here.
I think they're on this fence right now.
Someone just opened this door.
No, they're not.
They're still over there.
Why don't you guys look over here too and shoot this team if you guys can.
Okay, I'll go shoot.
I'm shooting left.
I'll do that.
We need to get underneath these guys, by the way.
It's okay.
I closed this door.
We're good.
Okay, where do we have to go?
We need to get underneath them right now on the second floor.
Okay, okay, okay.
Can you scan right now?
Which right?
Come to me.
Come to me down below.
Yeah.
Okay, come to me on the first floor.
Alright, keep moving right side.
Come here.
Alright, you're gonna scan the next building over to the green room.
Over here.
Okay, can we do it?
Yeah, yeah, scan.
We're good.
Okay, we're gonna go that.
We're gonna take it right now.
Okay.
Come to the first floor on the bottom right side.
We're gonna keep scanning our way and just keep walking in.
We're good.
Just moving.
I have a creeper, by the way.
Nice.
Alright, we're gonna wait for your next scan and then we're gonna move forward a little bit more.
Alright, seven seconds.
Yeah, you're good.
Let's see if there's any extra loot.
Oh, there's seven seconds.
I heard a zip on the right side for sure.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, scan.
Want me to scan this building now?
Yeah, scan to the right right now.
Scan both those buildings if you can.
Okay, so there's split holding right now.
There's split holding.
So we could easily get in there if we need to.
I'm ready.
They're flying.
They're taking the first floor.
They're about to fight.
Okay, okay, I'm looking, looking, looking.
Yeah, yeah.
Wait, I blocked our first floor.
I know, I got it.
We're good.
They're like smoking now.
Yeah, they fight this before.
I don't know.
There's another team taking a zip on the high ground here.
Which is really good.
Yo, dude just walked here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
He just walked outside.
I see them.
Yeah, they're across.
They're across the way.
13 blue.
He's coming across.
He's coming across now.
I can't look right now.
Knock, knock, knock.
I'm gonna try and thirst freeze.
Yeah, you're good.
Go for it.
You should be fine.
Where is the knock?
We're good.
Nice.
You gotta kill guys.
Oh my god.
You gotta kill him.
Let's go.
Yeah, I just wanna see if they're still fighting.
Alright, there's no one in the diner, bro.
I kinda wanna get...
Can you guys come to me real quick, actually?
Come here.
Come to the bottom floor.
Come on.
We're gonna make a crazy play.
Yeah, come here right now.
Outside.
We're gonna make a crazy play.
It doesn't matter anymore.
Yeah, true.
Are we just playing on the roof of that?
Is that what we're doing?
Stay with me.
Just in case.
Come here.
We're gonna take this outside.
What did I miss?
You're not.
Just play slow.
I didn't miss, guys.
Shoot this team up.
Come to me.
Come here.
Yeah, we're good.
We're good.
This team's not gonna be in for that long.
They're out next round.
Just play on me.
Let's see where this round's going.
Wait, I don't know where I'm getting shot from.
You're getting shot from the top, Teppo.
Just come to me.
This is safe.
Yeah, we're good.
We're good.
Ooh, I'm so...
There's a team underneath us.
They don't know we're underneath.
They don't?
I thought they do.
No, they do.
They're looking at me.
They're looking at me right here.
Oh, that's fine.
See?
They definitely know.
His cheats are triggering through the wall.
Yeah.
The cheats are triggering.
Bad him!
We're streamers.
We know what we're talking about.
Air grenades.
Play slow.
Play low.
We're good.
Air frags.
Where do we go here?
We're gonna jump down and just fight for the second floor here.
Okay.
We're gonna just jump down.
We're gonna ulti this.
Ulti the staircase to have a late game, okay?
Whatcha gonna do?
This one I'm peeing right now in front of me.
The only one that we have in the zone.
The next one.
We're gonna ulti that late game.
We're gonna play for it.
We should be fine.
Oh, they're portaling out that team.
I'm trying to shoot the team on our left.
Yeah, the team on our left shouldn't be a problem.
Just when they rotate in.
I don't know what they're doing.
They're still there.
They ported out.
They're gone now.
This team needs to fucking get fucked though.
I'm so pissed at these guys.
Wait what?
What's the charge in our retos?
We should go down to third party this if we can't wait.
Wait a little bit, wait, there's a trade.
We're gonna jump down.
Oh, come here.
Come here.
He's okay.
Oh, he did not.
It's okay.
Come here, Donkey.
Come to me.
Come here.
We have to fight for this.
Okay.
Fuck.
If you have an evac, just get on the height if you have an evac.
Oh, I do have an evac.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Just come to the front side.
Just come up to the second floor.
Don't overthink it.
Just play slow.
We're good.
Wait, wait.
Did they finish?
They finished.
I got a kill.
Suck my dick!
Nice.
Come here, come here.
Oh, shit!
Come here.
Okay.
Just put barrels down here and start shooting them.
They're gonna start shooting us on the bottom side.
We're good.
They locked their costume.
They locked their costume?
Nice.
We're good, Debbie.
I killed their costume.
There's no one here, right?
No one here.
They're on the side.
They're right here now.
I can scan in two seconds.
I got a kill.
We're good.
Oh my god.
We have two kills now.
We have three kills.
I have one too.
I would say we need to wipe these guys.
They need to walk out first floor before we need to jump off.
Wait.
Right here.
In the open.
No!
That's my... Oh, you fucking...
Fuck.
I'm gonna kill.
I'm trying to get the thirst for you.
Nice.
We're good.
Oh yeah.
Let's go, guys.
Good shit, dude.
Alright.
This team needs to jump out to us and let's...
There's a team right here.
I'm pinging them.
Okay.
They're leaving.
I'm just scanning.
They're just scanning it.
We're good.
We're getting this.
We're going.
Take space.
Come with me.
Oh, that's a wall.
Oh, you have your ulti, right?
You have your ulti?
Yeah.
No, no.
I don't.
I'll tell you what we do.
Two teams fighting here.
Yes, I do.
We're going to ult these kids off.
We're going to ult these kids off right now.
I'm with nade.
I'm nading.
Yeah.
Go with our grenades.
One team here.
Yeah.
But just play with my staircase.
We're good.
Play near me.
Tempo, jump down.
Come right down to me.
Because you're going to die when you jump off.
I'm safe here.
Oh, wait.
No, I'm not.
Yeah.
I'm safe here.
I'm safe here for now.
Yeah.
Back up with me.
Got to get some barrels down.
Tempo.
And try to ulti forward if we need to late game.
They're right here.
Yeah.
I have another nade.
I'm going to scan them, nading.
Yeah.
Tempo, throw your ulti on these kids again.
Throw it.
Oh, they're not there.
I know.
But you need to throw it.
We saw them on the one side.
The right side.
Over here.
Somewhere.
These kids have no angles on the right side.
You need to just pressure them.
You need to throw this ulti right here.
In this corner.
Oh.
Come on.
That's fine.
I hit the wall.
Oh my god.
No.
There's no fucking way.
You just hit the wall.
Revival.
They're so happy.
Okay.
We're good.
There's no shot.
They're so happy.
That guy's a rat.
That's a rat.
That is a rat.
That's right.
Keep them barrels forward, Tempo.
Keep them barrels forward.
We're good.
There's a rat right here.
We want to rush that.
They're crossing us.
Oh.
I didn't realize that was you.
They're crossing us.
Oh my god.
Tempo, you had fun.
We just needed to...
I didn't see the wall.
I didn't see the wall and I hit it by mistake.
Tempo, you had a good job.
Oopsies.
We were just waiting for Tempo to do his thing.
Okay, wait.
Wait, wait.
That's real life, dude.
Wait, wait, wait.
It didn't hit the wall.
It hit Wig's gigantic head.
Are you going to play for ITL?
Yo, Wig.
Your head was in the way.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Me!
Oh my god, dude.
That was so bad if we had that ulti.
Bro.
My heart hurts.
Great game guys!
We got third!
We got so many kills!
We're good.
We qualify for the next round 100%.
Good job!
Wait, wait.
Good job, Tempo!
Stay alive and take that evac tower.
Good job.
I was so nervous when you called.
Good call on the evac.
Wait, how did you get up there, Doggy?
It was a Horizon Q.
I just took the Q.
Where the fuck did a Horizon Q come from?
I don't know.
It just showed up.
I was like, yay!
I was like, okay, Doggy's with me.
At least we can wrap around and do something.
And then I was like, oh, someone came in to kill me.
And I was like, where did you go?
I can't believe that Q.
Change name, change name!
We gotta...
We gotta unite!
It's not gonna let me.
I'm on EA apps.
It's gonna be so long.
Okay guys.
We're in sixth now.
We're gonna get sixth.
After all that, we only got sixth?
Wait, wait, wait.
We're in seventh, eighth, ninth, and tenth points-wise.
We are 14.
And then the next four are 12, 8, 7, 5.
Okay, we're good.
We're so good.
But!
The teams right above us are only at 15 and 19.
See?
We're vibing.
But how did we only leave up one place?
We can end this in second place.
That's crazy.
Okay, please don't...
After what happened last game...
Wait, what am I?
I'm not even gonna watch this.
I think I could still play Kostic on this.
You could, yeah.
You might want to be honest.
Fuck it.
Let's see.
We're gonna be...
Where do we wanna go?
Lightning rod.
I'm down actually.
Am I doing the same?
Am I playing Bloodhound still?
Yeah, I mean if you want to.
Are you more comfortable on Bangalore here?
Because Bangalore is pretty good.
I can do either.
I can do Bang, yeah.
Alright, yeah, I'll just play Blood.
We'll see how it goes first game.
Yeah, yeah, we'll see how it goes.
We're experimenting now.
It's a code.
Oh, code's out.
Alright, code's out.
Yeah, oh no, we know.
We're both in here.
Oh, guys, did you guys know?
We should've told you.
Hey guys, the code's out by the way, everybody.
We totally want you in the game with us.
Don't worry.
We would not be the same without you.
On the globe?
No way.
That's a code that keeps everybody together.
No way the spotlight on my Twitch dashboard is the new level 10 hype train emote.
There's no way they're doing that to me right now.
Wait, really?
Are you showing the hype train emote they got from Bangalore?
I literally said spotlight.
New hype train emote.
It's level 10.
I ended up level 10.
Oh my god.
You fucking reminded me.
Why not?
Yes, why not?
We just wanted you to be sure that you helped contribute to the game.
I'm gonna help you to success.
Not your success, but like other people's successes, you know?
Exactly.
And that's all that matters.
That's so nice of you.
I'm actually a good guy.
Yeah, you're such a good guy.
See?
Thank you.
I appreciate that.
See?
He already has everything he ever wanted.
So he gives his successes to others.
Wow.
That's a good way to look at it to be honest.
Yeah.
So Turtle Beach.
I'm cheaper.
Wait, what?
Hello?
I don't know that nice.
I came back and all I heard was, Turtle Beach, I'm cheaper.
That's all you need to know.
I'm fucking weak.
What was that?
Can we talk about what that Kost was doing?
The first Kost we killed that was trying to cross in the open with nothing.
That was so sad.
I felt bad killing that guy.
I don't.
I can't lie.
I did a little bit.
One more point for me.
That's all that matters.
Oh shit.
You're sponsored by Gillette Labs?
I am sponsored by Gillette.
Yeah, the best a man can get.
Yeah, Gillette.
You know when we were at Twitch Rivals?
Hey guys.
Yeah.
They were for... what?
For our balls dude.
Yeah.
It was like their own manscaping thing.
It's a pubic shaver.
Oh.
Damn.
I did not use that shit.
You didn't...
That's not a good sponsor thing to do.
You're not using your own products?
Oh no.
You gotta trim the jungle down a bit.
Gillette, did you hear that?
Wig doesn't even use your product.
I'm getting shamed for not shaving my balls out.
That is insane.
If you believe in the product...
What doesn't sponsor me to shave my balls dude?
It's implied.
It's a facial sponsorship.
You don't know that.
What does it say in your contract?
Hair is everywhere.
How do you know that Tempo?
How do you know he has hair?
How do you know I got hair everywhere Tempo?
How do you know that Tempo?
He has something in the...
I'll see you at LAN.
After our volleyball game, it's me and Tempo in the showers.
After hours.
He's definitely looking.
Gotta give that homie a...
Gotta give that homie a glance over.
You know?
Tempo, that's lowkey the only L.
If I don't move the Texas Brawlers, we can't do our own volleyball league bro.
It's like lowkey the biggest L.
Wait, wait, wait.
So you're not?
No.
100%.
I'm actually probably buying a place in LA.
You're gonna move to LA?
I live in LA.
Wait, aren't you in LA?
Yeah, I'm trying to buy a place here.
That's so expensive.
I put an offer down already actually on a place.
Holy shit.
That's so expensive.
How much was it?
Tempo is now looking for a new roommate.
How much did you put down?
How much do you have in your bank account?
How much is your mortgage?
What's your social security number?
What's your mortgage?
What's your pet name?
What's the coordinates for it?
What the coordinate ordinance are so like everybody can like look it up.
Why did you say it like coordinate ordinance?
Coordinate ordinance?
The co-ordinate ordinance?
We got the co-ordinate ordinance guys.
Oh god.
Alright, we're going lightning rod.
If there's anyone there, I don't really know what to say.
We deviate to Zeus.
Yeah, probably actually.
Probably.
I think we're good.
Yeah?
Yeah.
Alright, we'll see what happens.
You know you're jump master right?
No, I had no idea.
Sorry guys.
There might be a team there actually now because I jumped late.
There might be a team there, yeah.
There's no way you called it.
There's no way they would contest it.
Those two teams are fighting at Zeus today.
Where's the beacon?
They're contesting.
There's like 13 teams.
I don't know why you would.
Unless you really don't like a team.
I'm just gonna go here.
There's no beacon at lightning rod.
I'll land back side.
Just in case that team decides to come this way.
After realizing they're being contested.
I feel like they would realize they're being contested like very early on.
The fact that they still committed to it is actually crazy though.
Low key.
I think they saw that too.
Oh god I have the buster sword on this character.
I look ridiculous.
The bonk sword.
I wrote in chat during the whole Karsa thing that guys don't worry you're gonna watch tempo carry.
And then people thought that was the moment where he got that one kill.
And they're like this is it.
This is where tempo carries.
Little do they know.
What do you mean?
Wig was in my way.
Wig's drinking.
I'm finally gonna throw that ulti.
Oh my god.
It's off my fat head.
Bucks it up and then blames it on you.
I think he's really said 7000 times to fucking throw it.
It's like my timmy incident.
Alright well this box is straight.
What a stupid prowler.
Did you send the box off the mountain?
Yes that is so dumb.
Why does that exist?
Nice.
Wait what do I do here?
This.
I need a bunch of blue backpacks over here if anyone needs.
Like tons.
I have white.
I'm heading over.
I'm running carbine.
Carbine.
Fowler.
Oh.
I'll burble barber here if I want to.
Oh wait actually there's a devotion here.
I'm about to take this.
Alright.
Getting to that backpack.
It's up top.
You know where it is?
Right here?
Yeah.
I'm heading over now.
I got a havoc.
Wait did someone loot here?
I think Doki did right?
Wait what?
No.
Wait which way?
I did not loot that.
I looted this.
Well someone looted that so I'm running away.
Yeah definitely don't play near that.
Don't.
I'm coming back guys don't worry.
We need to figure out where we're getting a fucking evo.
An evo and then also people scan.
I already grabbed us one evo.
Oh nice okay.
I'm gonna go get that fucking thing.
Yeah you're good.
The cell bin?
Yeah that thing.
That thing?
We're so fucking choked.
What do you mean?
I called it correctly.
Oh I got the wrong thingy.
Oh wait what's your thingy?
No.
What does that mean?
You got the wrong upgrade.
Was it the tactical cooldown or the ultimate tactical?
Yeah it was tactical.
I got the eater.
How did you?
Okay.
Let's go we're gonna take this cannon.
I'm ready.
Oh wait there's a band.
I'm checking it out.
There's someone there.
I think we go back maybe and go towards top command.
And go into command and maybe hit the beacon scan.
But we need to hit a fucking beacon.
Actually fuck that let's go back to our base.
Let's go towards Zeus.
Oh yeah yeah yeah yeah.
Go back towards Zeus and go from there.
I feel like we were supposed to take the car.
I should ask Raven what we're supposed to do here.
Oh we probably should have.
It's okay it's not a big deal.
Just walk it.
They just left Zeus so we should be fine.
They did?
Yeah they did.
So we should be fine on the rotation then.
Alright we'll hit the circle scan.
And then we'll come back down and see where we have to go from there.
We can just go to wall 2 if we need to.
Yeah that that and then boom.
I'm gonna craft one battery as well.
Cause I have only one.
I'll craft one up.
I have three bats.
Tempo go hit that circle scan whenever you can.
Yep.
You're gonna get the evo right?
Actually I'll head over to the evo.
I'll get the evo you're good.
Really?
You're the bloodhound.
Should we really let the bloodhound get the evo?
I'll get scanned if they're getting ratted on this building or some shit.
Yeah that's a good idea.
That would be pretty funny though.
That would be pretty fucking hilarious.
If you died that way I would laugh.
Where are those fucks?
Oh it's over here.
Wait do you not know where the ring comes from?
Nope.
This is unbelievable to me.
Should we take the redeploy?
Oh.
Guys wait for me I'm coming back.
We'll wait for you.
I have not found a charge rifle yet.
I know what a shame.
Alright we see that zone.
We're at the checkpoint for sure.
Checkpoint slash north pad.
We're just gonna run down and...
We should take the balloon.
Alright.
IGL.
Take the balloon and I'll go get the evo cache while you guys just land wall.
Okay.
Land inside wall, play slow, just land together in the building and I'll walk in afterwards.
And then if Tempo and I die then you can survive and live for us.
I got you guys.
And we all know how good you are at ratting.
Oh wait we don't have a people thing.
We don't have a people thing.
We do have a bloodhound but we don't have a bloodhound.
We don't have it right now though sadly.
Wait rank top 1 has 60 points?
I can't see if I can see people.
That did not register for me.
Wait who has 60 points?
Rank 1.
Number 1.
In our lobby.
They have 60 points.
Let's stay the fuck away from those guys guys.
Yeah what the fuck.
I'm good I'm happy.
Jesus christ.
Are we going here?
We're waiting for...
You got scanned?
From inside the ball thingy?
Oh I see them.
They are across the way.
You can hear me?
Yeah you are good.
I'm coming to you right now.
I'm gonna get on the roof and shoot for you.
You okay?
I'm alive.
They should want to fight this guys.
It's a mad maggie team which is annoying.
Help me.
Tempo!
Can you get the res?
They are here.
I don't know if I can grab this.
I'm on first floor.
Stairs stairs stairs.
I'm backing to you.
Yeah I'm trying to run down.
I don't know if you can try.
I'm gonna run as close as I can to you.
So you can come grab my banner later.
Tempo!
I bet you are trolling.
You are actually trolling.
Tempo what happened?
I got blasted from their roof.
What the fuck.
I can't.
God damn it.
We are fine.
I'm fine.
You can rat in this corner.
And then you can loop around.
And come get our banner.
Easy.
I'm not ratting for anything.
No no no.
The far north side.
I'm dead as fuck.
You can get our banner from the north side.
No way.
After what he did.
Do not listen to anything Tempo says.
I'm dead here regardless I think.
To be honest.
These kids are fucking terrible.
Bro what are you playing with?
Those kids are fucking horrible.
You could have nearly crossed by them.
I mean they are staring at me.
That's gonna be a problem.
I think over here.
Wait the team that killed us is gonna go that way.
So they can shoot each other.
And then...
You know what I'm saying?
If you think I'm getting a banner in this situation.
I just want you to let you know.
There's no way.
This is the wig show now.
Get the beep beep.
This is the wig show.
I mean if you could send me that would be pretty funny.
It would be pretty funny.
Oh they have a fucking rampart wall just for you by the way.
No you don't.
Okay I was gonna say.
We're fine we're fine.
We're good.
What's the issue?
They don't see you yet.
No.
I'm trying to figure out where I can just route to you.
I have to go far far right I think.
Just find a hole.
For your goal.
A hole for your goal?
That sounds crazy.
What it's true.
Get in that hole.
I'm just gonna go over here to the left.
And get in this hole.
Do you have meds for this?
Okay that's good.
I'm fine.
I just don't want this team to see me.
They'll just kill me in two seconds.
That would be so fucked though.
Oh my god scan that.
No.
Oh yo you can get loot here.
That would be so funny though.
And I'm gonna shit my pretty ass right here.
Alright.
Okay we all know who's fault this is right?
Yeah yeah yeah.
Snaky's fault.
Why?
Actually yeah he was protecting you.
Yeah I was protecting.
I was inside the building when he died.
Like who is he protecting at that point?
I was protecting from the roof and then I ran inside.
I was literally inside when he was dead.
My chat's saying to show my apartment on Zillow.
Laughter.
Dude, that's one of the funniest things you ever said.
Coordi-dordi-dance.
Shit, Tom, how did you do that?
I'm surprised you want to live in LA.
It's so fucking expensive.
Yeah, it is, but like...
I don't know, I feel like... I was talking to everybody in my family.
I definitely want to live here forever.
I'm trying to be like three years in here and then out.
Like three more years.
Just like, feel good for business.
And then I'll probably just dip out and probably just buy a house in like San Diego or like Texas or something like that.
Yeah, oh, so like you're just going for a career.
It's you and me in LA.
And then when it's finally...
When it's finally time to retire...
You can like...
In three years?
In three years.
You know when I fall off?
No, I didn't say that!
No, no, no.
I didn't say that!
I said...
When it's time to retire in three years, you're moving?
That... it's your choice to leave content creation.
No, no, no.
Oh my God, please don't do that!
For the sake of all our viewers, don't do that.
Oh my God.
You don't like it?
Not a fan.
Not a fan at all.
We're fine.
I can't believe I'm still in here today.
Was it expensive?
Are you getting a mansion or an apartment?
No, I'm buying an apartment.
A mansion?
I don't know.
It's LA.
I don't know what the fuck type of money you think I'm making.
But like...
A mansion in LA is like 90 million here.
Yeah, I'll call content creators and spend all their money on mansions.
And then...
Well, that's funny because they do that with renting and they spend like $20,000 a month renting like a bunch of fucking idiots.
It's so funny.
Yeah, like us.
Like us.
I'm trying to be smart with my money.
I'm trying to make it interesting.
I live for free, so you know.
You live for free?
Oh, well...
Good for you.
Not for long.
Yeah, I was gonna say...
I was gonna say...
You're gonna live for free.
Yeah, you won't planeta left me and left for LA.
I do watch them.
Who is that backup plan?
I actually came on here now.
Yeah.
Who is it?
What was it?
Who ditched you like that?
Who would do that to a homey?
Yeah, exactly.
We were about to live together, make food together, sleep together.
Oh!
Yes.
Especially that last one.
Come on.
In the same bed?a I thought that's what the homies do I started to...
Yeah.
Are you still in there?
Oh, you are.
He heard us yapping.
They're in front of me.
They see your big ass gun poking through the wall.
Yeah, yeah.
They have your stream up ten minutes later.
This is...
I mean, lowkey they would have the stream stopped me if they wanted to.
I've been here for easily ten minutes.
Yeah, I was gonna say this is where you were hanging out for ten minutes.
This could be an easy top five for the boy though.
Don't say that!
You're gonna jinx it!
You're gonna die right here, right now.
You can get second place.
We're gonna die right...
Do you have any nades?
You can get first.
I have zero grenades.
Okay, you can't get first.
You can get second.
Okay, I like that idea.
I'm down for second place.
If you had nades, you could get first.
You think so?
Yeah.
You just arc stick one while they're resing and then you just spitfire them to death and then we win.
But we have no arcs.
I have a Havoc.
Oh, that's a Havoc.
Do you remember what we said about not listening to the...
tempo's cause?
I didn't know that that's a Havoc.
That looks like a big ass gun with a spitfire, like a handle thingy.
It's like it has electricity on it.
The brown wooden handle thingy.
I don't think you should like do it now.
I think you should wait before you start.
They see a gun poking.
I think I'm right over here.
I think I'm in.
Oh no.
Oh, oh, oh.
What was that?
What?
Oh!
They didn't see you.
Stick to the wall.
Stick to it.
If you don't see them, they don't see you.
Exactly.
That's true.
Wait, wait, wait.
We saw them though.
So if you don't move, they don't see you.
Yeah, yeah.
Don't move and like...
They're coming to the stream right now.
No, they're not.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
He got his boys, bro.
He got his boys.
I hear the water.
I know, I know.
Yo, they were stream sniping.
Oh, they definitely are gonna kill you.
Wait!
Oh, run!
Okay, now they shoot each other.
You're good.
No, I don't think they're gonna be shooting each other.
Yeah, they shoot each other here.
No.
I told you not to jinx this!
I told you guys!
I just know that they kill like five times, bro.
I just know that they kill like 30 times.
What the fuck?
Yeah, that's crazy.
I actually just know that they kill like four times.
Yeah.
What the fuck?
I mean, top six is fine.
I think we're on EU servers.
I blame the servers.
We're literally in East Coast.
I have 95 ping.
We're in East Coast.
Yeah.
I'm fine too, bro.
I don't know what you guys are talking about.
Guys, we need a reset here.
We need...
What's top six?
How many points is that?
Three?
Three, right?
I think?
Yeah.
Alright, it's not bad.
I mean, 17 is not gonna be awful for us.
We're definitely qualified for sure.
Yeah, we're definitely qualified.
There's no way one team's gonna fucking kick like...
I do like making the end games, guys.
Yeah, you know, I do too.
That seemed really fun.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, but what about you, bro?
Do you like doing that?
Yeah, Teppo.
Do you like that?
Don't worry, guys.
I got it.
I blame Doki.
How do you blame me?
No, I'm down.
I'm so down for that.
I blame her too, actually.
It's two against one.
We can't lose.
You lose.
I made it.
Wait, what happened?
Our pact is over now.
He's gonna play aggressive.
Oh, what are they looking at?
They're in duo.
Why are they playing so aggressive for a duo?
Wait, they're a duo?
Yeah.
I'm gonna be honest, bro.
If I didn't know right, I think I could've killed him.
Yeah, but then his duo is gonna kill you.
No, he would've made it out.
I would've got a bad off, to be honest.
That was crazy how bad that lag was.
All good.
They're gonna get sent on here.
You know what I should've done?
I should've not rez tempo and just ran to you.
Honestly, yeah.
I was thinking about taking that fight, but I know that Zeus station team would've been stacked on loot.
Yeah, I should've left tempo and just ran to the loot.
That's Zeus' team?
That was the Zeus station team, yeah.
I don't know why they didn't rotate it farther.
Oh, what a Valk ulti here.
Oh my god.
I can't believe he didn't get blasted.
And the Valk didn't get hit once.
That's crazy that he lived that.
Oh my god.
This team is actually so lucky.
Where was our luck here?
If we did that, you would've died so fast.
I would've died instantaneously.
Yeah, yeah.
I would've died in .1 seconds.
Three teams.
Okay, we're at the point where tempo dies.
Even my chat was like, No!
Tempo!
Wait, let me open this up.
This guy is tempo.
Don't worry, you can plug us in.
I was two minutes ago, tempo!
I'm looking at Greek's face and he's just like, huh?
My chat's literally saying, Tempo just like me for real.
See, I give the viewers the experience that they would've had had they played Challengers again, okay?
People are like, tempo's on the roof again.
I'm giving the viewers what they want.
Did you guys see what I did in that game?
I was not on a roof, okay?
I was on the second floor.
Wait, was I on the roof?
You literally said you were on the roof and then you dropped down from the roof.
And you died.
Oh, I think, no wait.
Was there a forklift on the roof?
People said you were on the roof.
My chat was like, tempo versus roof.
Tempo, you need to stop going on the roof!
Well, I can't charge rifle if I'm not on the roof.
Well, we gotta find other ways.
We gotta find other ways.
We gotta figure out another way, tempo!
You can't keep going on the roof!
It just means death!
The roof is a problem for you, buddy.
Yeah, you're bad from roofs for real now.
Oh yeah.
Damn.
We never even got a chance to see if Bangalore is okay.
Come on...
Okay, we're still in sixth.
We're good.
We're ten points ahead of eleven.
So, you know.
I mean...
I don't know.
No, no, no.
How much for ten points?
Ten points ahead of eleven?
What?
How much for what?
Oh, he muted himself.
Oh, shit.
I muted myself.
What did you just say?
My bad.
You just said how much for what and then you didn't even...
Oh, how many points are we away from tenth right now?
Do you know?
Oh, nine.
Oh, we're good.
We're good.
We actually need the most unlucky situation to happen to us to lose.
Codes up!
Let's go.
I gotta pee so bad now.
I gotta pee.
Go pee!
I gotta urinate so bad.
Yo.
The fuck, man?
What the fuck, man?
It's okay.
I switched the fuse.
We're good.
Alright, this is it.
Wait, are we... we're in Stormpoint.
Yeah, yeah.
Wait, what were you before?
Caustic.
He's moving too slow.
I'm in drag.
This is it.
Now that you're on fuse, everything's gonna change, right?
Now we're back.
No more roofs.
No more roofs for me.
I'm a smaller roof character.
No more roofs, Tempo.
You stay on the second or first floor.
Or sometimes maybe the third floor.
But never on the roof.
Never on a roof.
This is it.
This time we're gonna get like...
We're gonna get second place.
Because you're not gonna be on the roof.
No, we're gonna get first place.
Wait, does first place have like...
Oh, first place almost... is at like 80...
Is at 80 points.
Jesus.
Bro, we're not gonna...
We're not even first.
There's no point.
Wait, wait, wait.
We can still get...
We can still get... top...
We can get top three.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Jesus Christ, the distribution is actually crazy.
The distribution between the top...
the top ten.
Wait, where did Wig go?
He has to join us.
He has to pee.
No, he's in the lobby.
He's just not moved yet.
Look, it's Wig's time to pee.
It's his turn to pee.
We've always seen...
Yeah, wait a minute.
I get a little chance to pee here too.
No, I didn't judge.
I was defending you.
Oh, yeah?
Yeah.
Chop, chop.
Yeah, I fucking defended you.
I was like, we all had a chance to pee.
But you...
Wait, wait, wait.
Did we die next round last time?
What?
What do you mean next round?
No, we made it past round two.
We lost round three, didn't we?
I don't remember.
I think we lost round three.
What?
For sure.
We lost round three last week.
No, we lost round two.
What do you mean?
Did we really?
Okay, okay, okay.
So we gotta make it past.
We gotta make it past today then.
Yes, we have to.
Yes, don't you remember round two?
We fucking... you guys actually...
I don't remember anything.
My brain...
You guys had trauma and like fucking forgot about that.
Oh, our brain has no memory.
I mean, I think I was just hitting straight copium and then we made it to round three.
I was like...
We died like twice in a row.
Like before top ten.
We can totally get top three.
We can totally drop three.
And then we got like left... we got like fucking dropped out of round two.
Yeah, we got fucked up, huh?
We got fucked so hard.
We cannot beat those guys 3v3.
110 minute delay.
We could barely beat that guy like 1v3.
Yeah, no, I actually think we lose 1v3 to those guys.
To who?
The boys.
Fuck no, we win 1v3.
Tempo, every time you say...
Remember our rat jam plan?
Yes, we...
Remember our surprise and then confusion is super effective?
Oh, I remember that.
Did we confuse them?
We did not.
We fucking got knocked out.
When we run into them again this time, we'll do that.
We'll use confusion.
We'll kill one, use confusion, kill two, and then 3v1 the last guy.
Okay, Tempo.
Tempo, I think you're like on some hardcore copium shit every time.
I don't know how you do this, but every time, every time, anything comes out of your mouth is some hardcore cope right there.
You know when you're a delulu?
Yeah, yeah.
Last week, Tempo was like, we're gonna make it to the finals, guys.
We're gonna do it.
We needed one week of practice.
That was our last week.
Now we're in the finals.
I can't believe you thought my Havoc was a Spitfire.
Okay, look.
That guy...
I'm looking at your stream right now.
That gun is like a big gun, and you know the little knobby thingy?
The Spitfire has a knobby thingy.
The brown wooden knob thing on your thingy.
It's literally electricity fucking charging up in his face.
Yo, that could be a Spitfire skin.
That's energy.
Spitfire has a blue-like skin that has the thingamajig.
Spitfire doesn't have the electricity charging out of the gun.
Yo, that giant knobby thingy threw me off, okay?
Look at that knobby thingy.
The Spitfire has a knob.
And that thing just has a big-ass knob.
Why does Havoc have that?
Because it's a skin.
It's a skin.
Exactly.
Yeah, but you're mad cute, bro.
I love you.
That's why...
He doesn't do well with cops on his...
I can't move.
That guy was lost in hell.
Uh-oh.
He said he's broken.
He's like, wait, what?
Oh my gosh, thank you so much.
Yo, he's like super flustered right now.
Like, oh my god.
He's a fan.
He's just like, oh my god, did you say that?
Did you just compliment me?
Don't forget, no Valk.
So we need to get those evac towers.
I thought you were on Fuse.
Why are you on Caustic again?
We need to...
I rigged it so that we get a map thingy.
Ah, okay.
I did not rig it enough.
We didn't get a map thingy.
Do we want to fight some of the punks for this car right here?
Oh, we're not making this.
Wait, wait, you gave me jump...
Don't worry, guys.
No, no, no, please, for the love of god.
We're gonna go to this cannon.
You do not make this jump.
Don't worry.
Go do it.
Just do it.
I will give you literally $10 at the next van.
I will buy you food if you can make this jump.
Okay, how far do I have to make it?
All the way to Lightning Rod.
What about Thunder Watch?
Nope, Lightning Rod.
Alright, let me go get Evan.
One sec.
Let me go get Evan.
Wait, you're off to a good start right now.
Wait a minute.
Evan's controlling the mouse right now.
He's muted.
Wait a minute.
This is too good.
I have to buy you food?
This is crazy.
I did not expect this out of you, kid.
I'm gonna be honest.
Wait, Tim is not talking.
He's not talking.
You guys have to split off.
I gotta go loot Thunder Watch while you guys go Lightning Rod.
Okay, Tempo.
Oh, that's right.
Master jump master.
I get free food now.
Yeah, you do.
I'll buy you one meal of land.
Deal.
Okay, clearly we know what's Tempo's motivation now.
Okay, Tempo.
Tempo, if we make it to top five in this game and you stay out of the roofs, we will buy you two lunches.
Wait, what if...
There's someone else in the room that makes a lot of money.
I don't know.
You're doing.
That is crazy.
I'm down though.
Two lunches to make top five, please.
Yeah, yeah.
What if we make top five and I stay on the roof?
No, no, no, no, no.
You have to not be on the roof for this.
I'm gonna be honest, bro.
I'm gonna be honest.
If someone finds a digi...
Yeah, yeah, I got you.
Are you running a motion?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There's another redeploy here.
There's a lot of redeploys this time.
Yeah, just take them if we need.
Honestly, if we don't have them.
I'll probably take that one.
I need a backpack.
There's another...
Sorry, alt-excel here.
Okay.
I need a backpack too.
Four!
I have no fucking backpack!
Blue.
Oh, I have a backpack now.
My backpack.
It fell off the map again, dude!
What is the point of these drops?
Genuinely!
They just fly off the map!
Why me, god?
Why me?
You said that the last time the compound on the left was looted?
Yeah, last time.
Yeah, I don't know who's looting that.
Let's get by survey beacon right here.
Yeah, just pay attention and make sure they don't get sent to us.
Make sure they don't jump on us, yeah.
Yeah, I don't think they will.
I'm gonna go loot this and see what happens to me over here.
One sec.
Yeah.
It's not like you're on an immobile character.
No, you saw my movement last game.
I kind of got that.
Yeah, I saw your movement.
Yeah.
You got shot there for no reason though, but...
I'm gonna get the car too, I think, for this.
Is there any beacons we can hit?
Is the car still there?
Yeah, it is.
Oh.
I don't think last game anyone looted this properly, because there's no...
Oh, sorry.
I forgot.
I smoked accidentally.
The pills were 100% open when I checked there last time.
Yeah, I don't know what the fuck they're doing there.
Grab that evil cash and the car and yadda yadda yadda.
Yeah, 100%.
We'll go to zoo station again and hit the beacon again.
Should be a little easier with the try down here.
I looted stuff.
I'm a bit low on the resource department.
There's a blue backpack here, but if you can still come back and get it.
I might go back and get it.
I'm not sure.
We'll see.
Where are we going, Wig?
We're gonna go get the stride in for us and then we're gonna go towards zoo station to hit the beacon.
Alright.
I'm heading over to...
Alright, sounds good.
I'll come pick you up.
We're vibing.
Just trying to find other loot.
My loot's not really fantastic either, if I'm being honest.
Yeah, I'm wanting hemlock and... well, I'm gonna see if I can find a 30-30 later.
I definitely don't need this much sniper ammo, but I wanna keep it.
Wait, does someone want...
I already have it.
Alright, I'm not bringing a mobi.
I'm gonna take a redeploy.
I think we don't need it yet.
I feel like if we die, everyone's dead.
I agree.
Alright, let's take this stride and let's head over.
I don't know why...
Wait, why are we still...
Why?
Because we didn't find the evil cache.
Wait, wait.
I found one.
Oh, nope.
Oh wait, yeah, we only have one.
That's it.
I didn't get a chance to find a bin to open and assault bin.
Don't get out of the car yet, because I don't know if they're gonna still be here or not.
Oh wait, there was an assault bin right here.
Do you wanna get it?
Yeah, let's get it.
We can grab blue.
Why not?
Yeah, I swear if you drove it...
Hahaha!
I don't know.
I don't know why would you jump out on the bridge, Tempo.
Did he jump out?
That was so dangerous.
That was scary.
Well, if my car shoots you up, so you can't really die anyway.
Yeah, but he jumped off in the edge of the...
We were at the edge.
Wait, wait, oh my god, there's a...
What?
Golden sniper.
Oh, I'm sorry, I didn't get it, buddy.
Yeah, it's all you.
Yeah.
Not golden sniper, but the golden sniper... threat.
Nope.
Scope.
Sniper threat!
Yeah, and then it said sniper threat.
Oh yeah, true, sniper threat.
I don't think I've ever heard anyone call it that, though.
Was there a re up here?
Nope.
Oh no wait, I have a re.
It's almost like prediction.
Tempo's gonna forget and go to the roof.
Hahaha!
Hey, if there are no roofs for me to go on, then I can't go on a roof.
We're in the car.
I'm coming, I'm coming.
Beep beep.
Alrighty.
I feel like we're so gonna get shot.
Nah, there's no way.
If they're still here, they're playing the game entirely wrong.
Okay.
Cause like, we're playing the game semi wrong right now, and we're pretty early.
Alright, Tempo, go hit this shit.
Wait, why did all... why should all of us be here?
I mean, I just picked Tempo back up, we just go.
I thought you guys were gonna go craft a bat.
Yeah, I thought, I'm gonna go hit that... I'm gonna hit that beacon... uh, not assault bin.
Assault, yeah.
Yeah, say beacon.
I'm gonna cut off the battery right now.
Uh...
I'm heading over.
Yeah, you're good.
Do your thing.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
I have one on myself.
Did you die here?
Ooh.
That's pretty fire, actually.
I'm gonna use my mid-pitch.
Oh, look at the zone here, too.
That's gonna pull to the Braum or shot slash cheetah, I think.
We're gonna go into... we're gonna go get that Evo near wall, and then we're gonna go into command and hit the beacon again.
All right.
Making another bat.
There you go, dude.
Yo, my Uber is just disappearing on me.
All right, here, I'm ready.
Let's go.
Wee!
All right, we're gonna go into command.
We're gonna go in the command cell.
Actually... yeah, yeah, yeah, what's that?
Command, hit beacon.
What the... what the fuck was that?
Um, um, um, wait, you're driving is a little...
Is our driver, uh, drunk?
Yeah, we have a... uh, we have a driver that might not know what he's doing.
Doing?
At all?
Wait, I thought we were gonna... I thought we were gonna scan the people beacon here.
No, no, no.
Let's move forward.
Okay.
Let's go hit the... let's go hit the fucking scan inside.
I'm gonna grab some syringes from these guys.
Yeah, do your thing.
You're good.
We're gonna hit the scan down below.
The... the... the circle scan.
Then we're gonna go to waterfall and hit the people scan.
Okay.
We're gonna wait for Dougie, right?
Yeah, you're good.
I'm here.
Don't worry.
Don't worry about me.
You better... you better... you better...
All right, if I die, I die.
Yeah, don't worry.
I believe in you.
We're good.
We're... we're chillin', guys.
I have so... that's why I'm behind you guys.
So if you guys die, I can just leave.
Run away?
Yeah.
Just not be dead with us.
Like, let's keep up with that.
Yeah.
I heard something.
Like a boom.
Yeah, we're fine.
I think that's just the ambience.
I think... I think we're okay.
Yeah.
Oh, get the ring scan.
Get the ring scan.
Yes, sir.
Get that shit.
We're good to go.
Let's see what goes on.
And we're gonna go towards...
Let's see.
First...
Ooh, that's a really good knowledge for us to have.
Okay.
We're gonna go get...
We're gonna go out this...
Let's go to this left side over here.
Okay.
We're gonna go get the people scan, then we're gonna go.
We're gonna go right to zone.
Right behind you?
Yeah, we're good.
All right.
We're playing this right, guys.
This is the way we should play it in the actual game, too.
Oh my god.
I can't believe we're actually doing it.
We're learning from our mistakes.
Yeah, we're slowly but surely learning.
Yeah.
It's like if we actually did Scribbs, we might have...
No, actually, though.
We could have... guys, I don't know.
We could have actually done something with our lives, guys.
I feel like if we actually sort of practiced for this, we could have, you know, made it pretty far.
We could have went pro.
Yeah.
Hey, we're past first round, guys.
It's all that matters.
Yeah, yeah.
We're past first round.
We didn't do worse than we did last week, which is right.
Should I grab the thing?
I'm gonna have to scan.
Why?
What thing?
You have a cash?
Yeah, go for it.
Yeah, 100%.
Well, I mean, if we place below top five...
Oh, okay.
I know where to go.
Let's keep... let's go into zone when you guys are ready.
No one knows.
No one knows right now.
Yeah.
Cut to me.
Yeah, we have three Rita ploys, too, by the way.
That's fine.
Just come to me.
We're gonna beat them.
We should at least.
We'll see.
We have three Rita ploys.
Just follow me.
Yeah, yeah.
We're gonna go right into the house inside Jurassic.
Just keep on moving.
Keep on moving.
All I'm gonna say is that if we place below top five, we actually did worse than last week.
I agree.
I fully agree.
With 13 teams instead of 15.
Wait, we're better in harder lobbies.
It just shows how good we are.
All right.
Let's go move it up.
I'm gonna walk up and we're gonna try to get into this building left side, okay?
Okay.
The building's pretty shit, but we can definitely play it if we need to.
We're scanning.
All right.
We're good.
Take the building.
Okay.
There's only certain angles we can play in here though.
So we just gotta play smart.
Note to self.
Don't roof.
Don't go on roof.
No, no.
This is like somewhere where you can get absolutely annihilated if you're positioned badly.
What if I take that Evo cache?
Sure.
Go for it.
I'm gonna do it.
You're gonna do it.
How much do you wanna bet?
You're gonna.
It's free.
How much do you wanna bet?
I can get it.
Why are we betting money?
We're on the same team.
We're on the same team, guys.
I like a little excitement in it.
A little gamble?
Oh, yo.
I'm ready to get rich.
Yeah.
Shoot these guys off.
I'm gonna try to at least.
Oh my god.
They're red.
Our safe space is the staircase by the way.
Okay.
They're on the bottom.
That team is red by the way.
That's fine.
What the fuck?
Why are they red?
They're so scared of you right now.
Let's go.
He's red.
I'm gonna eat this 4-10 charge rifle.
Domnaesh.
You're welcome by the way.
That was my opening.
Oh, I have to reload.
That sucks.
There's a sniper ammo right here if you need it.
They might be like, oh.
They might be like, yo, that's a charge level and a fucking Lomba.
That's definitely minus tempo in team.
We're gonna fight this much.
That's so far right.
Yo, stop moving.
I would fight them immediately.
For round two, are we all changing our full names?
I'm down if you want to.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, okay, okay.
I got a name.
I got a name already.
What are you gonna name yourself?
Don't worry.
It'll be a secret.
We can't say it out loud.
Oh, true, true, true.
Cause what's the point of saying?
Well, no, it's gonna be on screen anyway.
They're gonna know in 10 minutes.
I mean, they'll know after the first game, you know?
True.
They won't know until after the first game.
One, two, three, four.
One more here.
We're in such a good spot right now, by the way.
Are we?
I can't tell.
Where is everyone?
There's a team behind us.
They're gonna be all on the outside of Jurassic.
There's not many spots to play in Jurassic Park.
Push for this.
I'm looking.
I'm looking for us right now.
Watch it, Kraber.
Kraber on the front side.
Oh, that's not good.
Oh, you wanna play Kraber versus Charge Rifle Kraber?
No, we don't.
You don't wanna do that.
We do not.
Oh, you wanna...
Who will win?
A Charge Rifle or a Kraber?
A Charge Rifle is a Kraber.
Respectfully to Tempo, Charge Rifle would not beat that, even if she's the best Charge Rifle player in the world.
You're kind of fucking...
Where is that?
Yeah, you wanna go toe-to-toe with me?
It's like, God damn right I do.
What's fucking...
You guys got a Charge Rifle.
Wait, why you guys are up... why you guys are down here?
I'll make a mistake, maybe.
It's like, play there.
You're gonna get a steak?
No, I'm gonna make a mistake.
He's gonna make a mistake.
He's gonna do something wrong.
Potentially.
What is he doing?
Is that a person or...?
They're fighting over in Pile of Lines.
I'm trying to see if I get picked, but I don't think they're fighting anymore.
They wiped.
I'm coming back to you.
There's a drop here, though.
Okay.
We're so healthy.
What's in the drop?
Come on.
I don't know.
I can't see.
We don't have a scan for Scamisher.
I'm gonna put my Lumba down now and try to get it.
Okay.
Oh, you're gonna get it?
Oh, you wanna go do it?
Yeah.
Do you believe in me?
Okay.
With your belief, I can do this.
Wait, did you...
Okay.
Let me know when it's dropping and then I'll go all in.
I'm gonna throw...
I'm gonna throw my Hemlock.
Actually, I'll throw my...
That team just ran into that building?
That's fine.
Yeah.
They're running right side.
Is it down?
There's a full team up here?
It is not down yet.
No.
I saw it.
You're gigantic football.
Okay.
There's a team behind us as well, guys.
Team behind us on our north east, right where that fence was.
Should I go for it now?
Yeah.
You should.
Smoke it, though.
Make sure you smoke it and drop your gun first.
I did.
Okay.
Nice.
You did it.
I did it.
It's a bow check.
Can't see that.
Okay.
That's pretty ass.
I'm gonna lie.
I'm looking for you.
I'm gonna shoot for you.
You're good.
I got you.
You're vibing.
What's your...
Okay.
I'm gonna grab it.
Now we're gonna listen to me.
Ready?
We're gonna listen to me real quick.
Okay.
Northeast team behind us.
You guys see where northeast is on the map?
Tempo?
Yeah.
Tempo, you need to listen to me or two?
Tempo, you need to listen to me.
Okay.
Northeast is going to push us.
So we need more barrels on our first floor.
This team is going to fight us.
I have...
100%.
They have no choice but to.
All of this if anyone wants it.
No choice.
I got a kill.
Tempo!
Okay.
Now, Tempo, focus on the northeast side.
Come here.
Get this barrel out of here.
That's northeast.
Top left.
No.
Here.
Look at your compass.
No.
These are our compass.
Northeast and southeast.
This is the two teams that are going to fight us.
Okay.
Northeast as well.
These are the two squads.
Let's get some barrels down so they play our first floor.
If they play our first floor, we just hold inside stairs and you cost a goldy first.
You cost a goldy.
Okay?
All right.
You want me to...
Don't hit me in the head.
I threw stuff on first floor.
Nice.
Good job.
We're good.
We're just going to watch that southeast side.
I'm going to keep scanning it for us.
You see that team I'm scanning?
They're dropping down.
I'm going to ult.
I'm going to ult this side.
Yeah.
Ult the first floor.
Get ulti.
No, no.
I can't.
I can't open my door.
Watch out.
I did.
Nice.
Get ulti.
It's fine.
I need med kit.
They're dying.
I'm medding.
You're good.
I'm med kit.
I'm med kitting.
We're fine.
We're good.
We got another team on the left side.
We're good, we're good.
They're sliding away.
We're chilling.
Good job.
Loot up later.
Don't loot right now.
Just play slow.
Nice job.
Yeah.
We're doing great.
I'm watching.
I'm watching the stair door thing.
Yep.
We're still in.
Good job.
They're scanning us again.
Yeah.
We're good.
I'm watching.
I have digi.
Yeah, yep.
Nice.
Good job.
Ult us.
I don't think that'll work.
No, it's really bad.
I'm looking at them from here.
I'm still looking with digi.
I'm with you too.
I cracked one.
Nice shot, Stokie.
Good shit, yeah.
I need like energy though soon.
I'm here.
I'm gonna dump you somewhere here.
Step here.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Maybe don't.
Come to stairs.
You're good.
Okay, okay.
You're good?
Yeah.
Got it.
I'm still looking stairs.
Yeah, you're vibing.
You're good.
We should be good.
I'm gonna look out with my...
Oh!
That's mine.
That's my smoke.
It's her smoke.
That's her smoke.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're good.
You can even play first if you need.
We're vibing.
There's a lot of batteries down here.
Yeah, I got a lot of bats.
Okay.
Tempo, how long is your ulti?
Do you know?
I'm at 40%.
Okay.
I'm using my charge rifle though.
You're good.
Do your thing.
We're vibing.
Oh my god.
There's so much energy.
I have like alt-accel if people need it.
These guys...
There's two down over here.
Here, here.
Tempo alt-accel.
Yeah, Tempo.
Definitely take one if you need.
Take it.
We gotta kill these guys.
These guys are alright when they walk in.
I'm trying to kill these guys.
There's two down over there.
What?
Left side here?
I mean, I can... I'm needed.
Yeah, I'm just scanning one sec.
They are there.
Oh, they're so far.
I'm going down.
I'm going down to first floor.
That's my bad, boys.
I just fast-finger.
Oh, it's okay.
It's unfortunate.
Do you need this alt-accel, Tempo?
Because I'm going to use it.
We're not going to need to.
No, you should take it, Doki, if you don't have it.
Okay.
I'm going to use it then.
I'm going to use it.
I'm at 43%.
Alright.
We're going to try to swing this right side, okay?
Okay.
You don't have alt-tempo or no?
No, no alt-tempo.
I already tell alt-t.
Oh, Tempo, I'm asking you to need it.
Good, good, good.
We're going to swing right side.
I fast-finger my alt-t anyway.
We're going to swing this right side, okay?
We have to.
We have a choice.
Do you have alt-t though, Doki?
Can you alt-t these guys on the right first?
No, 86, 86.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
We'll see what happens then.
On the left now, too.
I can smoke.
Are we smoking?
Yo, you guys want to stop shooting?
Okay.
Now, it's good smoke.
We're going to get underneath them.
Just get underneath them and look backwards, okay?
Go now, go now, go now, go now, go now.
On the left.
Oh my god, the solo.
Shoot the solo.
Shoot the solo on the left side.
We're dead.
We can't do anything.
There's no way.
There's not enough people alive for us to do anything.
GG's.
Hey, we'll take that.
We literally can't do anything.
We'll take that.
I didn't know...
Yeah.
I mean, we got so many kills though.
We're definitely qualified.
Oh, no.
We definitely did a good job, guys.
That was good.
We played that really good.
That 3v3.
Like, really well.
Nice job.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We got so many kills.
That 4-10.
Yeah, that 4-10.
Helped so much.
Yeah, welcome.
That assault.
Everyone's just smoking.
I'm just like, not today, bitches.
Assaulting on me.
Yeah, I don't think... We had such a poor rotation into the zone.
I mean, that's so difficult for us because there's not enough teams alive.
Yeah, yeah.
To help us for the rotation.
Exactly.
Yeah.
We backed from behind or something?
Do we have a behind to even...
I think we died.
Yeah, I don't think we did.
Yeah.
I think we should have maybe smoked that team off and swung the sun.
I got the KPS.
My bad.
I just didn't think that team was gonna...
That solo was gonna stay there the whole time.
Be able to shoot us.
It was crazy.
I think that solo died.
That solo is dead now.
Yeah, he is.
He died right after us.
Literally right after.
God damn it.
How did they creep us?
I know.
He was...
We're streaming.
That was crazy.
Part 2 is to the top of the rock.
We're on top of the rock.
And I'm like, what are you doing?
You're not gonna make any content.
You're just solo.
Hello?
Yeah, you fucking shitbags.
That's me.
That's me making content.
Let the streamer live.
That is crazy.
We need the content.
We're here to content farm.
Yeah, they fucking farm that endgame.
Holy shit.
What's fourth place for?
That's... what's... 9 points?
9 points.
That's pretty good.
Wait a minute.
Yeah, we'll take that.
That's a great game for us.
Yeah.
If 3, 4, and 5 fucked up, then we might be in third.
Oh, shit.
No way.
No, I don't think they... I don't think they died.
I appreciate that.
That was probably top 3 right there, to be honest.
I've been taking gas by 3, 4, 5.
Good job, though.
Let's go.
We did it!
Good shit, guys.
Next round.
F5.
Okay, okay, okay.
Let's... Are you ready to change your names?
Remember to put TSM in the front.
No, I'll change my name too.
I got you.
Actually, we know.
We can't change our names.
Why?
Because then we have to change it on Battlefy.
And that's fucked up.
Oh, really?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We can't even, like, add stuff in front of our names?
No, wait.
No, no.
There is a way.
Wait.
You have to click your profile.
Yeah.
Nope.
Where's the thingy?
No.
Someone said there's a way you can add a thing to your name.
I want to add stuff to our names, though.
Oh, there we go.
I found it.
No way.
Where'd it go?
Yep.
Go to your friends list.
Yeah.
And then there's a tag on the left side.
A friends list?
And there's a tag?
She wants to do a tag.
She wants to do a tag instead of the actual change in the name itself.
I get it.
Yeah, but would they still see it?
Yeah.
They can see it.
Wait, wait.
How do I do it?
So, friends list?
Yeah.
And then on the left side, there's a thing called tag.
Mmm.
I want to look that up after this.
I'm watching this fucking mod now.
Okay, okay.
I'm going to hide my Apex.
Friends list.
Good job of not dying, by the way.
Oh!
Okay.
Add TSM.
Yeah, I will.
For sure.
I'll do TSM as well.
Yeah, yeah.
There you go.
All I know...
All right.
I'll be right back real quick, guys.
Let me...
You're just griefing people.
DM the code when it's ready.
All right?
Yeah, yeah.
I mean, we have like a 10-minute intervention interview.
Yo!
We're in fourth.
What?
Oh, we improved!
We improved!
We improved.
We went from five to four.
Yeah!
We did!
Oh, dude.
Guys, guys.
Even though there's less teams, we... technically, it's an improvement.
That's what I'm talking about.
Top four, guys.
Good shit.
Top four.
We got better.
Oh, my God.
At this rate, we might have a chance to...
First place has a hundred...
First place has a hundred and two points.
We don't think about the first place team.
We don't think.
Clearly.
They're like actual Pred players.
We have not been Pred for a very...
Teemu, you've never been Pred too.
So like...
Hey.
I got Masters once, okay?
Oh my God.
Holy shit.
Season 17, okay?
Season 17.
You've never been Pred.
That was crazy.
Oh my God!
And it was the season 17 Masters?
Yeah, season 17 Masters, man.
Oh my god, was that the easiest season to get Masters?
We don't talk about that.
Oh, okay, sorry, we don't talk about that part though, obviously.
Yeah, we just talk about season 17 was Masters, okay?
Oh man, alright, wow, good shit guys, let's fucking go.
Let's fucking go.
Let's go.
I am way more locked in this week than last week, I'll tell you that much right now.
My eyes are open now.
Yeah, your eyes are actually seeing normal FPS.
Yeah, I'm seeing normal FPS and like I'm not as tired anymore.
I'm not lying.
Give a round of applause, dude.
I'm doing it, guys.
The queen of sleep right here.
Guys, I did it.
I'm so proud of all of us.
I'm so...
Some of my chats said my wife's laugh is very distinctive like Doki's.
It's really easy to locate her.
Like the last puppy.
If I had you at a convention, I would know exactly where Doki is every time.
100%.
I'd be in the middle of the convention to hear that laugh.
I'd be like, oh my god, southeast.
Doki.
5 meters.
It's the Doki GPS.
Literally, oh my god, that'd be awful.
What do you mean awful?
You telling me how to drive somewhere sounds...
Like the closer you are, the louder the laugh gets.
Oh my god.
You know, there's things you can...
There's like a mod that you can put on your Google Maps that you can replace with other people's voices.
Wait, really?
That's great.
I would love...
Just put Doki's voice on the Google Maps.
Bro, I wanna release that.
Wait, send me.
I wanna release a Doki Bird GPS mod.
Jesus Christ.
This is so funny.
Imagine the content.
You know how the cars beep when you're closer?
Yeah.
When you're like parking and you're closer to a wall, you just hear Doki yelling, beep, beep, beep.
I can't believe you got two kills, bro.
You're the GOAT.
Oh my god.
Here's the school bus.
But remember who helped him get those two kills.
We're all spitting now, spitting.
Let him go.
I love the school bus charge.
This motherfucker said, what's northeast?
Yeah, it's like, look at the compass.
Look up.
No.
Wait, wait.
Northeast?
You gotta say top right.
That's the exact opposite of what you should be saying.
No, no.
Northeast is... yeah, northeast is top right.
Bro, what do you mean?
That's not top east.
That's not my right.
No, what are you saying?
That's not... top east?
That's not... sorry, northeast.
You broke my brain just then with that statement.
You actually...
There's no way you guys... okay, I'm looking at the... I'm looking at that compass thingy.
Yeah.
You guys actually use that?
Yes.
Of course.
Quite frequently, actually.
Yeah.
I have to learn to use it for a competitive.
What are you...
Yeah.
Quite frequently, I use that, actually.
What?
Tempo.
People in competitive use the compass.
All the time.
Yes.
Yeah, I have trouble using the compass when I'm not playing competitive.
Okay.
TSM fucking always uses the... what are you...
I've never met a human that can smell...
I gotta go... you know that never eat...
Oh, and you love this man.
Never eat shredded wheat or never enter stinky...
What is happening?
Never enter stinky washroom.
You know?
That's how you tell which way the compass goes around.
What?
What is going on?
You go N, E, S, and then W.
And then you go over in a circle.
What?
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I gotta do that every time someone tells me directions in that sense.
Okay.
Oh my God.
Bro, you're a real person.
That's not a real human.
He's a real human.
He's a real person.
I'm listening to country songs right now to smooth me out.
Take the stress off.
This is great.
It could have been the drink.
What did we tell Tempo when we said we'll buy him another free meal?
Or you'll buy him...
Oh yeah, I didn't go on a roof.
I was on a second floor.
Yeah, so he didn't go on the roof, but then we did...
And we got top five.
Was it top five?
I don't know.
Top five, right?
Was it top five or was it top three?
I don't remember.
What did we say?
I think it was top five.
Top five?
Top five.
I think it was like this game.
I have no idea, but we're in top five regardless.
Yeah, so... but did we die top five?
Did we die top five?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I don't remember.
We died fourth.
Oh, we died fourth.
Okay.
No, we died third.
Tempo, we need... Okay, my bad.
I didn't mean to cut you off.
But Tempo, when we're late game, bro, let's prioritize your ulti.
Like, you know, like...
Like, if you don't have it, you need to pop ulti-exels like immediately.
My brain...
You and Doki are probably just more important than me.
My brain was trying to figure out how to swap my gun.
Wait, was that why you weren't listening to me when I asked you?
Wait, no way.
Tempo, do you need the ulti-exel?
I was healing.
No, I am literally watching this.
You were like fucking staring at the boxes.
Wait, how do I... How do I turn off my stream?
You were literally staring at the boxes.
Don't look, Doki.
Tempo, I asked you like three times, do you need the ulti-exel?
And I didn't get zero responses.
Okay, okay.
To be fair, Chrono knows this very well.
When I'm playing Apex, my brain is not all there.
Bro, my chat got some points.
Even my chat is 10 minutes late and now she asked like three times.
Merry Christmas.
No one saw anything, okay?
I'm deleting this bot.
No, no, no.
No, we all saw it.
I just opened my chat and the first thing I hear is... first thing I see is he's still looting for some reason.
That is not believable, bro.
Oh, fuck.
The bot is deleted.
I don't know what anyone is talking about.
Oh my god.
Deleting the bot off that is crazy.
That was the moment you had to delete the bot.
Okay, alright.
Oh, it's not out yet, Timber, right?
No.
No, it's not out yet.
I'm playing literally a game right now with octets running around so...
Wait, you're fucking playing a game about us?
Yeah.
What the fuck?
Invite us!
Oh, I'm already in the game.
Leave!
No, I'm gonna get a timer.
And then my warmup session is shocked.
Why are you leaving?
Where are you at?
I'm gonna go on a duo.
Yeah, go do a duo.
I'm gonna do a duo.
Keep that aim warm.
I'm gonna get that aim.
Oh, this kid's a fucking shit head.
Whoa!
Bro, can this fucking movement wannabe just stop?
I'm playing a team deathmatch, bro.
You're playing a deathmatch?
There's a deathmatch?
I also saw it's locked down in the other one.
No, there's a deathmatch.
Maybe I got the last one for the hour or something?
Oh, yeah, it's gone.
It's like control and lockdown.
There's no way I'm playing control.
Yeah, no shot.
No.
I'm done with that shit.
It's okay.
Don't worry.
You're gonna see me so...
Chat, this is gonna be the only time you see me actually getting to kill somebody.
Yeah?
The only time?
The other times I cracked people but my teammates didn't finish the kills for me.
I'm actually lowkey smart.
I don't need a PK for the day.
I'm going crazy right now.
You say that but then it's gonna be like the part where...
Oh my god, the TSM Doughkeeper is so fucking...
In the public lobby.
So cringe.
Oh my god.
I'm lowkey snapping right now.
What is going on?
Who am I?
Who are... Who is this man?
I was not doing this at all.
Alright, chat.
We made it to the next round.
Oh, my bad.
I'm muted.
Wait, I wanna be part of your chat.
Oh, my god.
I'm lowkey smart.
I don't need a PK.
Yeah, chat.
We made it to the next round, dude.
We did it, chat.
Round two, chat.
Round two.
Yeah, I'm chat.
Yeah, you're chat.
I'm that one viewer.
Alright, we're back.
Only dunking.
Yeah.
Shout out to that one viewer.
Shout out to me, the one viewer.
Shout out to you.
That's me.
What the fuck?
I'm jumping right now.
I'm jumping right now in my game.
You understand if you see my...
She drove the car?
If you see my POV, you'd understand.
Yeah, when I got it?
A minute later.
Alright.
Yeah.
Yeah, just wait until ten minutes later and you'll understand why I said that.
Got my triple take.
Wait, we have eight kills.
Wait, how many kills did we have last time?
Definitely not eight.
But we did have like several second places.
And we haven't had a second place yet.
How do I even see what we did last time?
Nope.
Guy is the most wannabe movement player in the world.
What is this guy doing?
What are you fucking doing?
Why doesn't this kid just tap-stripe everything in these games?
It hasn't hit a shot yet.
Look, he's trying his best.
We should laugh.
And there's just me on pretty little roller.
Yeah, like you don't need that.
The fuck?
Who shot me?
Oh my goodness.
I found it.
Found what?
We had ten kills last time.
Oh, so we didn't improve.
No.
We moved from the placements, you know?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Overall, placements had to be better this time.
Yeah, yeah, overall was better.
Yeah, had to be.
Nice.
Oh, it says go to round two.
Go to round what?
I thought it said go to round two.
I was looking at the wrong page.
You're good, you're good.
They got the first place got 102 points?
Yeah, they did.
Yeah.
Oh my god damn.
Yeah, we're definitely not that part of the league, we're not.
No, we're not there yet.
We're trying, we're like in the part where we try to sneak by.
Yeah, we're the low key.
We're just low key existing, you know.
We're just there.
We're just trying to get on by without anyone really recognizing us.
Yeah, we're like just let us pass through, you know.
We are not there yet.
I'm gonna grab that.
Oh wait, you guys aren't even in my game.
Who am I telling this to?
Grabbing that evil cash for my random.
Nice, such a good teammate.
I'm a good teammate.
Is the code out?
Oh no.
Not out yet.
Oh, the lobby.
We got seeded so it's gonna start soon.
Okay.
Alright.
This... this...
Temple, you need to tell me about the GPS mod.
I'm gonna fucking... my next release, I'll release a Dohybird GPS mod.
I got it that way.
You have to tell me how to do it.
I'd buy it.
I'd 100% buy it for you.
I would buy the support.
I would never use it because it would drive me actually insane.
You would gotta use it.
You have to use it for like a vlog.
I would try it.
Just for you.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I would literally spend my entire day voice acting that.
Yeah, that's fire.
That's actually such a good idea.
Yeah, that would be so fun.
Turn left.
And I would release it for free too so no one has to pay for it.
Wow.
Yeah, I'm that nice.
You're such a good person.
I know.
Oh my gosh, somebody stop me in my terrible deeds.
Yeah.
She needs to make money too guys.
We gotta stop her.
Somebody stop me.
I'm just too nice.
No way.
I just no regged you brother.
Yes way.
I believe it.
No way.
I'm getting no regs out here brother.
My team is really bad at this TDM.
Holy shit.
There we go.
I'm carrying TDMs.
You know there's a problem.
You're carrying TDMs?
Yeah, I have no idea.
You know when that's happening we're shocked.
That's crazy.
My stream can finally see me kill people.
I'm so happy.
Kid.
He's the most movement nerd of all time.
And just barely getting any shots.
That's so funny.
I look he respected grind though.
I respect it.
Maybe he's doing a TikTok right now.
It's not about his kills.
It's about those TikTok montages.
True.
Those like heavy basses.
I love those.
Yeah.
That's your entire For You page.
Little sausage out of me.
My chat finally is at the part where we're talking about the compasses.
Are they?
I can't be the only one.
There's no way.
You're the only one.
No way.
You should ask them in the chat.
You might be the only one.
I got someone that said never eat soggy waffles.
There you go.
I'm not the only one.
I know the soggy waffles one.
Yeah, I know that one.
Yeah, but that means they fucking look at the compass.
Pause.
What do you mean pause?
I'm trying to figure out what to say.
What do you mean a pause?
They're like, who are you pausing for?
Oh shit.
Who are you pausing for?
I'm getting bullied.
This is me.
Now you're getting...
Oh wait, code is out?
Oh wait, my game's almost done.
Nice.
Alright, nice.
Me too.
How long till it starts up?
Yeah, how long?
How long?
I'm going to go join now.
Okay, I'm going to call in a little bit because I can't leave or else I get a timer, right?
Oh yeah, you do get... he does get two lunches.
Because we said top five.
Yeah.
I'm sure you're so right.
Oh shit, I'm supposed to figure out...
Oh, where we're dropping?
I'm not getting shot.
I'm almost done with my game too.
Um...
Yeah, my game's almost done.
My teammates are really bad, bro.
I have 23 kills.
I think that's like eight combined.
I hear there's no like, SBMM in like, uh...
Was it Mixed Eight?
Yeah.
I can't lie how bad this is.
I've had moments where I was like, how is that a team?
How is my team real?
I have no idea.
Cascades.
Oh.
There you go.
One down.
No way I lose this game dropping 48 kills.
This is insane.
No way.
I'd be very surprised.
Oh no, my teammate.
Are you okay?
Oh god, team, please.
I'm losing.
I have 20 and 24 out of our 44 kills, guys!
How did you lose?
Someone help me, please!
Use your hands!
How is that possible?
Please use your hands, guys.
Your fingers.
Use anything.
Oh, echo.
Oh, this person typed echo.
I was like, where is that POI?
Great try, guys.
We had a great game.
Oh my god.
I want to let everyone know on my team right now, bro, that you guys did nothing to contribute to this.
I was going to be like, whoa, you positive about your teammates?
Hell no.
Not in this situation.
That's crazy.
Wait, I'm not dead yet.
I need one more kill.
Oh my god, we need two more.
Come on.
I'm so sad.
I think the last kill too.
Oh my god, we lost the game.
It's all your fault.
My teammates bot lobby.
I think I'm in the bot lobby too.
No way.
I wouldn't doubt it.
Sometimes they make the bots fight for XP and then they don't do shit.
They just shoot people who shoot them.
We're waiting for you guys now.
Is it just me?
Oh shit, okay.
Sorry.
I gotta go.
I'm so sad.
Okay, wait, where are we landing, Tubbo?
I'm coming in.
Okay, so right now, no one typed...
I'm here.
Zeus, Elrod, Command, or Stormcatcher.
No, you don't see the TSM in front of me.
You lied.
Wait, do you not see it in front of me?
They see it in the game.
I also lied and I did not do it.
I forgot.
You didn't do it?
No, I totally forgot about it.
Go leave and do it now.
They're gonna wait for you.
No, the fuck they're not.
Please, Wade needs to leave live.
No, no, no.
Stop.
No.
I'm not risking this.
JK.
He's a coward.
He's a coward?
What the fuck, man.
Oh, wait, wait.
We actually have good teams in here.
Oh, shit.
We got Pain.
We got SQ.
We got 00 Negative.
I have no idea who any of these names are.
Yeah, 00...
You're not gonna know anybody ever.
I think that's it, right?
So just those three?
They have three different teams.
They're good.
I would say this round two is easier than last week's round two.
We're taking three different POIs though, okay?
We got Zeus, Command, and Lightning Rod.
We're taking all three.
Yo, wait.
You type Lightning Rod, just so people know.
Alright, I'll type Lightning Rod.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, wait.
How about all three of us type Lightning Rod and they'll think it's all three different teams because they don't pay attention.
Okay, Lightning Rod.
I type Lightning Rod too.
So they'll think three different teams are going to Lightning Rod.
Wait, wait, wait.
Yeah, you're so right.
Watch this, watch this.
But...
See?
You could be like, contesting team 11!
Then it'll be even more confusing!
Okay, it'll be like...
There's like three teams landing...
There's like three teams landing North Pad.
I'll be like, contesting team 1.
Contesting team 1, yes, dude.
So confusing.
People will be so fucking confused.
It's gonna be great.
So we're on Storm Point first, okay.
Cool.
W.
We'll take it.
My team said...
You would be the second person to die in a horror movie with that direction.
What, you?
I think I just caught up.
Yeah, you would be the second.
Wait, who's the first?
I don't know.
He's dead first.
Why would it be me?
I know my cardinal directions!
No, no.
Tempo is 100% first dead in a horror movie.
Yeah, I'd take the second place.
That's messed up.
I would survive in a zombie thingy.
No you won't.
No you would not.
I would be the zombie.
Oh, because...
I think I'd be the...
I think Tempo's gonna die first, then Wig, then me, because I...
The moment Wig gets in trouble, I'm gonna run away.
Oh my god.
You're just leaving?
I'm out!
100% it's all about survival.
Wait, someone said grief team... are we fighting a team off swan?
No, no, I think they just want us to land on team 4.
They want us to land on team 4 or something.
Just type SQ, I'm never gonna watch you again.
Wait, I've got code net.
Oh wait, code net?
Oh, Wig got code net.
Wait, change your name!
Tag!
Do your tag!
I don't know how to do that.
I don't remember what it was.
Change your friends list, and then there's a tag.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, I knew it!
Oh my god!
Wait, it happened for a reason.
It all happened for a reason.
It happened for a reason!
Are you back?
He's back now?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, okay, okay.
Nice.
Look at that.
I knew it.
I didn't remove from the custom match.
They just took me out of the custom match.
They just... what?
You bugged out.
I kicked you out.
They saw your TSM.
Do we need to somehow get a DC restart in case we...
What group are we?
I don't know.
We are...
Group 15.
Alright, no, I'm just getting ready, just in case.
Oh my god, we made it to round 2, guys.
Alright, we're back to where we started last time, guys.
We make it past this round.
We got 12 last...
We got 12 last game.
Last week.
Alright, we're going for 7th.
Yeah.
Look, I'd just be happy with top 10.
I'm gonna be honest, bro.
I'm happy with 9th place.
I'm happy with 10th.
I'm gonna be real.
Like, just please.
That's all we want.
Get me a school bus.
Let's go.
We got this shit.
Easy.
I believe in us guys fully.
I believe.
Chad, thank you all for being here and supporting.
Everybody's chat.
Yeah, thank you everybody.
We love you guys.
You get smaller ping.
What?
What did you just say?
Smaller ping.
Okay, now that's some fucking cope shit right there.
There's no way that's true.
There's no fucking way.
We can do this.
I believe.
There's no way.
There's no way we can't get past, like, top 10 this time around.
I think this lobby's easier for sure.
Yeah.
Okay, but what happens if we...
And we have Zeus.
I mean, we have Lightning Rod.
Okay, we run Storm Queen first.
I'm gonna be honest.
How did we feel without Valk that game?
Okay.
Yeah, we had a million evac hours.
Yeah, okay, yeah.
We'll just make sure we get our evacs.
That's like the biggest thing.
Yeah, so do we do bang then?
Yeah, yeah.
Wait, where does the beacon spawn in Lightning Rod?
Um...
Like, we haven't had a single beacon yet in Lightning Rod.
But...
This is it.
Round 2.
If beacon spawns in Lightning Rod, one of you guys has to swap and go Thunderwatch.
Because I gotta go to wherever the beacon is, right?
Yeah.
Yeah, I can do that.
I'll take over your place if we get the beacon.
Okay.
Alright, let's do this.
Alright, I believe.
Oh, there we go.
I see it.
It says TSM.
Yeah!
Guys, exclusive right now.
We wanted to wait until now to announce it, but we got signed by TSM.
Yep.
Three new content creators.
Signed to TSM, guys.
Yeah, you know how like, how Temple was getting kicked out of his house?
Wait, wait, wait.
It's because...
It's because he's getting signed, so they're getting him a new house.
As a content creator!
You're so smart.
You're so right.
TSM Doki Bird!
Let's go!
TSM Doki sounds fire.
I better see that in the competitive ring.
Yeah, yeah.
We better see this on Reddit.
I swear to God.
I better see that.
Wait, do we not have a beacon again?
No, we don't.
Okay.
We don't, we don't.
This is gonna sound crazy.
Can we pass the Jump Master Tempo?
Haha!
Actually, no.
He was really fucking good.
Evan, get back here!
Alright, wait.
I'm gonna try to go and get the car on the right side.
Okay?
So, Doki, you go to the front of Lightning Rod, and I'll go from here and go to the back.
Okay.
I'll loot here then.
Keep in mind, if someone just did not call...
Lightning Rod?
Yeah.
If someone's going Lightning Rod, we 100% just land Thunder Watch and we try to rotate out.
Alright.
But we have a good jump here.
Should be pretty clean.
I don't think anyone's gonna be too crazy about it.
We should be fine.
Yay!
As of right now, it looks like we are uncontested.
For sure.
Really?
As of right now, yes.
It does.
Oh?
There's like 19...
Lightning Rod?
I think so.
Yes, yes, yes.
Where do I land?
Yeah, land on the watch side.
Go Thunder.
Doki, back up.
I'm gonna loot this building and I'll go to you guys.
Go Thunder.
Okay.
Did they take it?
Yeah, they got it.
They got it.
That's fine.
I'm just gonna run you guys immediately.
I have my Carpide.
I got some good loot.
I stole some of their shit and we're gonna dip out.
Charge Rifle.
Nice.
Okay.
They're gonna maybe try to fight us here too, but let's just...
try to keep on moving.
Did anyone go Storm?
I didn't see at all.
No one's Storm catching me.
I have no idea.
Okay.
My audio's not on.
Okay, that's not good.
Turn it right off.
Also, just be hyper aware.
These kids could 100% push us.
Please.
I have a PK here.
Okay, I'm good.
I'm Lombo Havoc.
I'm okay.
I'm okay too.
Trust me, anyone went Storm, they did.
Okay, there's a team Storm.
These kids are lowkey fucking us here.
But it's okay.
That's what it is.
Okay, I have good guns.
I have Vault and Carpide.
Okay, what we're gonna do, I think then, we're gonna run to the left.
Okay, we're gonna go left side over here.
I'm ready to go whenever.
Yeah, go left side over here.
We're gonna go east side, southeast side.
And we're gonna go get this car.
They shouldn't shoot us, I don't think.
Yeah, hypothetically, right?
Yeah, for sure.
I'm gonna stick to the right side.
If they're here, then fuck them.
We just kill them.
Honestly.
Or do we rat inside the compound and wait for one of their idiots?
And then use the confusion tactic.
No, it's just a car crash.
Yeah.
We need to stop cooking.
Yeah, let's stop cooking.
Let's get in this car and we're gonna go down to spiders.
Okay.
I'm gonna rotate out.
Just get to me immediately.
I'm here.
When you honk, can other people hear the honk?
Yes, of course.
We're gonna leave this compound.
Okay.
Let's just stick together though, because I don't know what this team's gonna do, if I'm being honest.
I'm gonna grab the Evo.
Yeah, go for it.
Just keep your head on a swivel, just in case.
Alright.
Not last!
What?
Oh my god, you scared me.
Not last!
Let's go!
We're good!
Yeah, we're good!
Fucking losers!
Not last!
Okay.
Did y'all loot this in here or no?
I just looted the second floor.
Okay, nice.
I'm gonna go across the street and loot across.
Are we going down this spider's- Yeah, we're gonna take this ride though.
We're gonna navigate with this car for sure.
Well, I'm already gone.
That's fine.
I'm gonna try.
I thought you were gonna loot across.
I'm gonna be honest, we want to go for it.
I'll come with you.
Tell me, don't go too far away from us.
Okay.
There will be teams probably rotating out, and I want you to get shot at or just stormed.
I'm gonna stay in the nuts.
While I wait for your car.
Yeah, yeah.
Hang out with Wig.
We're vibing, we're vibing.
We're looking so good.
So juicy.
My loot's not honestly terrible for what the fuck we got.
Yeah, I honestly feel like I have good loot.
We just need another Evo.
Or like an Assault Bin.
We're gonna go find another Evo right now.
Tempo, come in.
Uber!
Uber's here.
Are we gonna do spiders?
No.
We're gonna grab the Evo.
Yeah, we're gonna go get the Evo on the left side.
Just stay in until I tell you guys to jump out, just in case.
Let's go get this Evo though.
Alright, someone get in there.
Okay.
Weeeeee!
I got us!
Team play!
It's okay.
We're gonna come to the left side.
I might pick the wrong one also.
Wait, wait, wait.
That's a lot of Ulti-Excells and stuff.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Alright.
I got Ulti-Excell and a Med Kit.
We're good.
Yeah, I'm gonna grab some.
So guys, I might also pick the wrong one.
That's okay.
Alright, we're gonna go now to launch.
We're gonna go to Devastated and hit the beacon, okay?
Alright.
And we're gonna get the other Evo on this back left side.
Okay.
Why is there an Evo here?
I'm gonna be honest bro, I have no fucking idea.
I don't think I've ever seen this one.
Yeah, that's so fucking far.
I'll grab it.
Yeah, get it, get it.
Yeah, I'm the Evo girl!
Yeah, you are.
That's me!
Let's go.
I'm just checking the map real quick.
Woah!
It's fine.
I'm healing.
Let's get in here.
And we're gonna try to get... actually, don't get out of here.
We're gonna go in this one, okay?
Alright.
Let's just play from here right now.
I have no idea where this zone is going because we have no beacon here, which sucks.
Let's just navigate our space.
Let me know if we find a...
a sniper scope.
Yeah.
We're gonna take the height of this.
So we're not gonna play inside here.
We're gonna take the height.
Ooh.
Just cause I don't know... I just don't know how many people are here.
Or how many... where the zone is going.
I want anyone to come and just feed on us.
So if it does end here somewhere...
I'm gonna craft real fast.
Yeah, you're good.
I'm gonna go top.
Hopefully no one's up here and I die.
We're good.
There's no way.
You're so healthy.
I'm so healthy.
I also got... I can look over you guys now too.
Alright, I'm heading up.
Woah!
There's a scope here!
There's literally a scope in front of you.
Yeah, I have a...
Yeah.
I'll grab that.
Okay, we're gonna set up here.
Seems like they're rotating in this way.
I think it's going Paiwan to be honest, but I'm not sure.
So we'll just play from here.
We'll open their backs just in case.
Yeah, you can do that.
Alright, you guys play up here.
I'm gonna go get these two bins up here.
Just in case there's any cells coming.
Where were you shooting?
Paiwan side.
Yeah, it was a team.
It was a team in Paiwan.
Looking behind us.
Yeah, they're fighting someone else.
That's good.
Just get shots down and go for it.
Oh, team here!
Team here!
Okay, I'm gonna leave after this.
You can shoot at too.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm gonna leave right now.
I'm gonna go get these bins.
Nice.
He's behind that box.
Yeah, he's not peeking though.
Like I said, there's a lot of people that are coming over here.
I think it might actually ender us.
Should we be here then?
There's an AR team fighting here.
Yeah, we should definitely play hide if it's gonna end here.
For sure.
We can evac hide if we need as well.
It's a really good spot.
I'm just trying to find a spot.
There's an AR team fighting here, Tempo.
You wanna shoot.
I'm gonna look behind us still.
Yeah, there's a team now walking into launch pad back side.
I think we're in a really good spot, guys.
Alright.
This is our new home.
Oh no.
I could 100%, 1 million, 1000% be wrong, but let's just check it out.
We'll vibe out for now.
Wooo.
What happened to that team that was walking behind us?
I don't see them anymore.
Woah!
Oh, I see it.
Wait, landing behind us now too?
I need heal.
I'm gonna go to Phoenix.
I'm gonna be honest.
I'm not gonna peek until the next zone closes.
I think only Tempo should peek.
Yeah.
I stood on top of it.
I almost glided in.
Wait, we're actually in such a good spot.
Look at our zone call.
Oh my god.
Look at this.
Look at that.
R-I-G-O right there.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's our guy.
I'm way more locked in this week.
I'm telling you.
That's our guy.
That's me.
That's him.
C-Pod's affirmation works.
Don't worry.
I'm not gonna peek too much because I don't really have that much good meds.
I have two.
Two bats, nine...
I have two bats, uh, seven.
I'm too seven.
Okay, Tempo.
Can you get like one or two barrels out here?
If a team oobs us, just hit the barrels.
There you go.
Yeah.
Because I don't think we want to peek too much right now, but I want to show a little bit of presence if a team just oobs on us.
Oh, suck.
Alright, so here's the here's the game plan, guys.
If a team oobs, just grenade spam.
I just catch it.
Yes.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Grenade it.
And I have an ulti-excel here.
Anyone needs it later.
Okay.
Alright.
Okay, we need six more teams to die.
Yeah, we're gonna we have one more, one more point.
I don't know where this point.
To any teams that are stream sniping, you want us to make it to the next round so you get content and clout.
Also, also, also we're easier to kill, so it's like better to have us longer.
Yeah, yeah, so you better have us longer in the lobby so you can get higher placement, just so you guys know.
You're so smart.
Yeah, yeah.
So if you're stream sniping us at the moment, remember this.
Yeah, remember everything.
Remember me.
Remember us.
Remember how disappointed I'll be.
Remember, you'll become famous in our, for being in our lobbies.
Yup.
This is gonna be your big break.
Your big break?
Your big break is crazy!
Oh my god.
This is your, this is your chance, guys.
This is your chance!
Let us in!
Stream snip us.
Just let us into round three.
You're gonna be famous.
I'm gonna shoot it with you.
We got any hits that'll be so funny.
I hit one.
I hit, I can't even see where you're hitting at.
They're rotating left, so I think I might pull a little more towards devastated, but we're in a really good spot with an evac tower here.
Alright.
Yeah, they went into here.
Yeah, they went here.
That's fine.
They're gonna hit the people's skin.
I think that's what they want.
And the ring console.
I see them up here, yeah.
Yeah, they're right here now.
Oh, they're finding someone up there.
In 46 seconds, we'll find out.
Good, that's another team gone.
We need that.
Oh my god, someone else has a ca- Someone else has also a caustic with a charge rifle.
I miss it when you can have one person farm evil.
Now I actually have to try.
I think that's my least favorite part about it.
I was so useful back then.
Yeah, because you were the evil farmer.
Yeah, I was the one guy with the rifle.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Give me your shields, guys.
What was it?
What did I say?
Wait for it.
I don't know.
Charge.
What?
Take some, bro.
I think I actually understood what you were saying.
That's insane.
Yeah, I was like, what did he just say?
Exactly.
That was unbelievable.
It's probably because I speak mumbo jumbo, too.
We're in a really good spot.
We just play up here and we evac.
Yeah, we're valid.
How many evacs do we have?
You have one?
Either one?
I have one.
We have two.
We have two evacs.
We're probably going to have to do a double evac.
So ours just gets shot at.
Team just went onto the bridge.
Okay, nice.
We're doing great right now.
I believe in you.
Yeah, we're valid.
Oh, oh, oh.
We're safe.
We're so safe.
It would be funny if Temple got like three meds shot from that fight.
If he just not...
He booped me and then I got just triple swamped.
Yeah.
Keep flying.
My U-Bus.
Hey.
They're above us.
You gotta come here.
I have a nade ready.
Oh, shit.
I think they landed on our right.
I don't think they ubed us.
Okay, okay.
It sounded very scary though.
Yeah, I looked up and I got shot.
Why did I get shot?
What the fuck?
It was my bad.
Where did they land?
I'm not sure.
I think they landed underneath the reds.
I gotta scan right now.
Yeah, scan.
What's red room?
It's like between the toes.
Little red rooms.
I'm sad.
I can't be helpful because I only have a carbine.
It's okay.
I'm not really doing much either.
I don't have enough heals for us to do any shit like that anyway.
We're doing pretty good for not...
For having like a contested drop?
And also just having to farm evos early with a trident.
What the fuck?
There are two solos that just died.
I got shot from the left side.
Three more teams.
Yeah, we're good.
We're good.
Tembo, can you do me a favor?
Can you move this barrel up like right here?
Move it up just a little bit.
Yeah, the middle one.
Yeah, so I can play.
If someone oobs us or comes up here, I can just play it.
What does oob mean?
Out of bounds.
So I can land out of bounds and land on you.
Oh.
Wait, they're fighting on the left.
Shoot this.
I'm gonna get shot.
Oh, motherfucker faded in.
I hit ten.
I got ten damage.
Nice.
Good ten damage.
So huge.
I'm contributing.
Nice.
And then you just took four hundred?
Yeah.
A team landed close.
Yeah, we're good.
We're good.
Dude, why are you shooting us, you fucking bums?
Sorry.
Yeah.
Say it.
Say your feelings.
You're gonna explode if you don't.
Yeah, you don't.
Ducky's trying to give me another clip on Twitter.
Bro, any publicity is all about publicity.
It's good publicity.
Oh, I'm sorry.
Oh, my zone.
Okay, it's really bad.
Oh, that's bad for us.
Yeah.
It's a really bad zone.
Okay, we're gonna evac late.
Okay, that's all we're gonna do.
Okay.
It's fine.
Is it a building?
No, we're gonna evac from the top.
I don't know where we're landing.
I have no idea yet.
We have to check this out.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We can, we can evac and do...
No, what we're probably gonna do is land from the staircase in the back over here.
Alright.
If we can make it that way.
We'll see.
We'll see if we can get the evac off.
We're gonna go very late though.
We want other teams to die first before we start rotating in on this.
And other teams get focused.
Because if we just go early, our evacs can get absolutely rocked.
Yeah.
I feel like everyone's gonna shoot our evacs at that point.
Yeah, 100%.
We need this team on the left to like start moving up and stuff like that before we get rocked.
How much sniper ammo do you have, Temple?
You've been charge rifling forever.
12.
12 more.
Oh, okay.
That's not a lot.
Make sure full HP... Towards the end of like 20 seconds till the zone closes in, make sure you guys have full HP, please.
Okay, okay.
I'll try.
Alright, a couple evacs already coming out.
Alright, so you see my plane over here, guys?
Yeah.
Over on Devastated?
This plane right here.
We're gonna land from those staircases probably, okay?
Okay, okay.
Back side of it.
All the way in the back.
You spam ping us.
Spam ping us when you're ready.
We're gonna go late again.
We're gonna go late.
We need these kids on the left to fuck off, bro.
Like, leave.
What are they looking at?
I don't know why they're staring at us so hard.
Why are they staring at us?
Are we like...
Do they know it's us?
I don't know.
Do they have sniped us correctly?
Maybe, honestly.
Who the fuck knows at this point?
Like, is it 10 minutes past and they know we're here?
I have fallen.
Bro, what the fuck is wrong with...
Alright, you're gonna smoke this height, I think, Doki.
You're gonna smoke these guys.
Okay, okay.
Now?
No, wait like five more seconds.
Okay, let Kyle for it.
I will.
I will let you know.
Oh, they smoked us.
Nice.
Okay.
Alright, ready?
We're gonna go.
Come on, come on, come on.
Come on, come on.
Here's another one.
I can't put the other one.
That's fine.
I'm gonna ult these two and land the other ult.
We're good, we're good.
Just follow my pattern, okay?
Just follow my pattern.
Just follow me.
Stay up height.
Stay on height.
As high as possible.
Oh, there's a team right above us, by the way.
We're fine, we're fine.
Just come here.
Yeah.
We're gonna land right here on silo.
Okay?
We'll land right here.
Come here, come here, come here.
I got it.
Not to me, we're good.
What the fuck?
He's off on someone's head.
Wait, what?
Who the fuck is this guy?
Wait, Tommy!
Don't keep shooting the corners, to the corners, to the corners!
I couldn't, the other team shot me.
I got two kills.
I killed two friends.
What the fuck?
Where did those guys go?
Did you guys see those guys?
No, I saw you got punched.
I was like, who is that?
Wait, what just happened?
Who the fuck was that?
It's okay.
I killed a rank 56 friend.
What the fuck was that?
Oh, wait, no.
What the fuck?
I didn't see anyone there at all.
Was that the team that evac'd with us?
I don't know, but...
I just got punched.
I didn't hear a thing.
I didn't hear a... Oh, JK, I didn't kill a friend.
It was some other fucking...
Some fucking 4k shitter.
I don't know who they are.
Hello?
4k shitter.
Okay, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I like, lost.
I didn't watch that pod back.
Me too.
You said someone landed storm, right?
Yeah.
Okay.
So right now we've got pylon, down beast, and command that we might be able to land at.
Command's not bad, because we can evac out of there if we need to.
Okay, do we want to just aim for command then for this one?
Yeah, I'm down.
I still don't know where they came from.
I'm so lost.
I was so confused when you got punched.
I had no audio.
And I was like, that's not tempo.
I was like, that's a rampart.
That makes no sense.
I'm so confused as to what the fuck just happened to me.
Me too.
B3.
That was so weird.
Because they definitely were not there when we landed.
They were 100% not there.
Yeah, there was nobody there.
They landed the moment we, like, landed, I think.
That's so shit too, because that's so fucking winnable.
We actually, we might have got sent on by this team inside, but we got absolutely sent on because of that team landing on us.
Yeah.
That's so shit.
Shut up.
That was crazy.
There was no way I could live as a rat, too.
You guys got us four points when we would have gotten one.
Yeah, let's go!
I contributed.
No, you did more than contribute.
You carried good shit.
That's just insane.
I cannot believe that just happened to me.
I know.
I was like, what the fuck.
I was like, where did they come from?
Getting punched was like the least expected way to die in that situation.
Yes!
They literally teleported into us.
I think they were just That's the surprise.
He's like...
I think the two.
Yeah, they're like...
Because they started punching.
They didn't even get their guns out.
How did you get two kills?
Wait, if they were punching, yeah.
Then they must have landed right when we landed.
Yeah.
I knew it.
Because like when Wig was getting shot at, I got one down and then the other guy...
I don't know why he didn't...
I mean, he shot at me, but he lost the 1v1.
Yeah, I know.
He got... It's still kind of embarrassing that losing that too.
Yeah, that was...
He definitely lost the 1v1.
They kind of goaded.
Oh my god.
Wow, they got...
The team I'm watching right now is going to win.
They're just farming everyone.
Yeah, GG.
That's the farmers.
Oh my god.
Alright, I need to fucking pee so bad.
I'll be back.
Alright.
GG.
Got 10.
That's better than...
No, I...
Dude, good kills.
Seriously, really good kills.
Those four points are going to be huge for us.
Yeah.
Those two points were going to...
If we get like four or five points every game, then we qualify.
Yeah, we're good.
I'm going to pee.
Alright.
We're going to do this.
Wait, I don't even know where you landed, Teppo.
We just need to pee.
I landed on top of the...
The silo thing.
Yeah, and then you got shot down.
And then I...
I landed on top of it.
Then I got shot as I was jumping down.
And then...
Yeah.
And then I died.
And then you disappeared.
Yeah.
Holy shit.
That was fucking crazy.
Oh, we are in ninth.
We're in ninth?
Let's go.
We're in ninth.
Yeah.
If you didn't get us those two kills and the placement, we would be tied for 13th.
That's good.
We got ninth place.
That was good.
We're gaming.
We're gamers.
Gamers.
Gamers gaming.
Eleven kills.
Okay.
We're doing so well.
I knew it.
I knew we were gaming.
We're on track.
We're on track to qualify for round three.
I've always believed in us.
Look, Tempo.
Tempo, if we make it to round three, I will give you enough money for a third lunch.
Oh my god.
I'm making lunch and we're calling.
We made it out of round one.
Now we make it out of round two.
When we make it out of round two, you'll get lunches for all of LAN.
All right.
Deal.
How many LAN days are there?
Three?
Seven days.
Seven days?
Okay.
Third.
I'll give you third.
It's seven days long.
I'll give you third lunch.
Day three lunch.
And Wake will be in charge of day one and day two.
I'll be in charge of day three.
If we make it to...
All right.
I'm back, guys.
I urinated.
Yeah.
Wait.
We made a deal.
We're in ninth.
If we make it past round two, I'll buy day three of LAN lunch for Tempo.
Wait.
Are you going to LAN?
No.
I'm just going to send him money.
Oh.
It would be a way cooler deal if you were actually there.
If you were there.
Yeah.
Exactly.
If we make it to the finals.
If we make it to the finals, you go to LAN?
Yeah.
We go to LAN.
If we make it to the finals.
Oh, man.
Okay.
Deal.
We'll do it then.
We'll win this one.
Wait.
The code's not up, though.
No.
It's not up.
Yeah.
We're just waiting.
It is.
I just posted.
Oh, it is.
Oh, never mind.
It just got out.
I just put the code in.
It didn't go.
Oh, never mind.
It went there.
Hey, I'm here.
Bro, what team landed on us at Devastated?
No, no, no way.
No way.
Who landed Syphon?
Who landed?
No way.
That was Syphon.
Elrond.
Banned from any events.
That's insane.
You're the GOAT for that, bro.
I'll call a water jug one second.
No.
Actually, speaking of which, you know that, you know how there was a...
I don't know.
I'll wait till Wig gets back too so I don't say twice.
Oh, it was a DG.
DG was the one that landed there.
Wait, really?
Yeah.
All right.
Well, they just outed themselves so they're not playing in any tournaments anymore.
Abuse.
They're not even going to...
Tempo, they're not even going to make it to any event.
Abuse.
No, I mean, there's some open events, you know, and then it'll just be like, oh, it looks like your application just disappeared.
Oh, your name's DG?
Oh, I accidentally deleted this row of applications.
Damn.
Power abuse live on stream.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So, okay.
So, I was saying...
Nice.
If they...
You know that?
You know the 25K sword tournament?
Yeah.
Yeah?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm running through the qual applications for that so...
Oh.
Goodbye, DG.
Looks like you're not making it.
Damn.
Oh.
And you're...
Quit snitching.
He's doing...
Huh -huh-huh-huh-huh...
Uh-huh...
That was me?
Thought I had my gun out is crazy.
Yeah, that's the guy I punched you.
That's the guy that punched you!
Yeah, motherfucker dude.
Yo, fuck that guy!
Ban from watch parties.
Damn!
You're not allowed to watch the watch parties anymore.
Bouyg is not even going to let you watch the party.
Yeah,
I'll copyright strike you.
Imagine?
Yeah.
Oh yeah, if you watch our stuff, we're gonna...
We're gonna...
I'm talking about copyrights, thank you.
No, it's like I showed up on your stream.
You saw me on your stream.
Copyright strike.
That's my identity.
That's my video, yeah.
I break the number one rule of content.
I should do not copyright strike unfairly.
You should start doing it everyone.
Throwing it left and right.
You get one.
This guy gets one.
Yeah, I show up, you saw me in that one game, I'm gonna strike you now.
Say goodbye to your channel.
You know the most evil thing you can do?
They have song requests on and you may play a song.
Now I get that.
Imagine.
You play your own... you make an original song and then you play that original song on their channel.
I actually do have an original Nice Week Strong.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, use it.
Use it as a weapon.
Are you playing that at LAN?
Hell no.
Play it at LAN and copyright strike LAN.
A viewer made it.
It's really good.
Copyright strike everyone that's watching.
Yeah.
The pre-watch party.
On the stream.
Stream.
Didn't the Fine Brothers try to copyright literally React content?
Yeah, they did, they trademarked React.
They're like you can't do React content.
That's gonna be you.
You bring your original song, you play it on your stream channel, and anybody that watchpotties your stream, they have to give...
The revenue they make from that stream, they need to give half to you.
Wow, I'm rich.
Because you had your song played.
It's just like YouTube where they strike you.
You have to give half of your... give content out of you.
Wait, wait, someone said their command.
Oh.
Someone else said their command.
The run- the run-some perk.
We could just go towards Thunderwatch if we wanted.
Okay, depending on where the ship goes...
Yeah.
We can check to see if Pylon is open too.
Because technically...
I'm gonna be honest bro, I definitely think Pylon's taking it.
I think Barometer is technically still open too.
Why?
1, 2, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12, 13, 14...
Yeah, Barometer...
Oh, I should turn my audio back up.
Barometer and Pylon should technically be open.
But...
We'll see.
We'll see how it goes.
Alright, we can't let Doki's 4 points go to waste.
Yeah, I worked so hard for those.
We got these next 3 games.
I worked so hard for those fights.
We got this.
No, really good 2kp.
I just watched it back.
That makes no sense how they did not kill you.
Okay, we'll see if anyone goes into command.
Wait, there's no one running around right now.
Okay, yeah, yeah.
I think when I said I was gonna ban them from all the tournaments, they got scared and left.
Nice.
That's low-key horrible, but I love it.
Whoa!
Power!
This is the reason why Tempo's in my game.
Abusive power, man.
You guys land here, Tempo go Thunder, and then I'll go get the car.
I'll get the car over there.
This is the reason why.
I'm gonna make sure that you're not getting landed on though.
You're good, you're good.
Okay, I'm landing here and then I'm gonna go up.
Alright, yeah, we're good.
I'm actually surprised they left.
Oh my god.
I think they actually thought you were serious.
That's fucked up.
Someone's gonna make a Reddit post about you.
I think what actually happened is I think they had a worse game than us, to be honest.
Oh.
Which is pretty tough.
Well, we stole their car too, so they're not really getting anything out of it by the time I get here.
Yeah, they're just gonna keep stealing our car.
We just might as well dip.
Yeah, I'm literally taking the most important aspect of their gameplay and just giving up.
I gotta redeploy.
So almost like a capital K.
Definitely she called them a 4K shitter.
Yeah.
Yeah, 4K shitter's crazy awesome.
I love that out of you, to be honest.
You can't... if you have your 4K badge and you lose to my badge right here with the fucking double bronze.
What are you doing?
I don't even have a 4K badge on this account with my Bangalore.
That is so ridiculous.
Alright, wait, is there a beacon for us in?
No, there's not.
That sucks.
We haven't had a single beacon here.
Yeah, we have really bad luck when it comes to the really important rounds to not get the really important stuff.
To be honest.
That's pretty sad.
Not gonna lie.
There's a...
We're really good at that.
Just not getting the things we need.
The evac here.
I already have an evac.
I'm good.
There's no evo cash for me to take either.
Like, this is fucking torch.
Yeah.
I'll just go below and see what happens.
If I die, I'll scream, okay?
Alright, don't worry.
I hear ya.
There's a... Are you gonna shoot that flier?
Cause I am for you.
Zeus just scanned us.
Keep that in mind.
They're gonna tell we're really separate then.
That's not good.
There's no way they're gonna rush us, right?
Well, they're gonna go for... they're gonna go for that... uh...
What?
They're gonna go for this thing.
Evo cash?
They are, yeah.
I'm gonna come back up to you guys right now anyway.
Uh huh.
We should wait for Stormcatcher to leave then go back to Storm and get the beacons.
I don't see anything good yet.
I haven't found the syringe.
We should also get that Evo when they're gone.
For sure.
I'm gonna kill this dragon.
Okay.
Just for like a little bit of... just a little bit of flier stuff.
Oh, nice.
A bat.
Alrighty.
Does someone want that 3x?
Yeah.
That's a few.
Yeah, he was good.
Oh, he's so high!
He's so high!
Alright, come here, come here, come here, come here, come here, come here, come here, jump off, come here.
Oh, they're shooting from behind us.
Oh, they took that Zeus zip in the back.
The pad?
Uh oh.
No, no, I can't take the pad.
Just come on.
Just get in my car.
Literally, keyboard.
Can you guys get to me?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I got it.
I don't think tempo is... I don't know.
I guess tempo's okay.
Tempo's okay.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Do not finish.
Get in.
Get in, get in, get in, get in, get in, get in.
Where the fuck... they were right behind... how did they get there?
I didn't even see them.
They took that zip in the very far back.
Oh!
Swig, are you okay to drive here?
This driving is scaring me.
This driving is murdering me.
Give me comms real quick.
I'll take the EVO.
Yeah, yeah, I got it.
I got it.
Okay, okay.
Got it?
We got blue now?
And I go on the... we go up on Storm and scan anything?
We're going right now.
I'll scan up and we go up.
Okay.
We're good.
Alright, nice.
We survived.
I did not have a chance to get a lot of meds though.
It's okay.
We don't really have much.
Yeah.
Good job.
We'll hit these Spikens too.
For sure.
I'm gonna see if there's extra meds anywhere.
I need like... I'm gonna try to find...
Not last.
Not last!
Let's go!
Not us.
We'll take it.
We got CA.
Shield side let me know.
Hopefully grab a bat.
Yeah, we should all craft the bat up for sure.
Alright, I'm gonna craft a bat then.
Okay, they're on Thunder.
They're on Thunder.
That's fine.
I'm looking for them right now.
Kids are fucking idiots.
Alright.
Alright, we probably can't hit the people scan but craft the bat...
I can like... smoke it maybe?
Um...
Do it.
Maybe.
Yeah.
Yeah, they're running far right.
We're good.
I'm gonna finish this.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We should be able to now.
There's gonna be an echo HQ zone.
Yeah, they're running back there.
Yeah.
Oh, look at all these.
How many evac do we have?
Do we know?
I have one.
We have three.
We all have...
Alright, come with me.
Do we wanna grab any... like we wanna grab what?
That one?
Yeah, probably.
Let's probably grab that.
Let's grab that last EVA.
Just land on it.
Alright.
And we have another...
One bat, 16 cells.
Um... I have... Oh, I have six bats.
Oh, I have...
Yeah, seven bats.
Does anyone need extra bats?
What the fuck?
I'll take one.
I have one.
Yeah, yeah.
What the fuck?
How do I get seven?
I'm gonna land over here.
Yeah?
Yeah, you can.
Go for it buddy.
You're chillin'.
Yeah, yeah.
You're good.
You should not be over there.
We wanna walk in and just get to Echo somewhere, but Echo's pretty taken right now.
Actually, only two spots taken.
We can probably find somewhere to go.
Getting in the middle of Echo wouldn't be bad either.
Okay, who wants bats?
Who needs bats?
Uh, I'll take some in this house.
I'll drop it here.
I dropped two bats.
You wanna take one?
Do you wanna grab one?
I'll take one.
Yeah, I have one right now.
Yeah, you... No, you grab the one that's there.
I left one there.
Thanks buddy.
Appreciate it.
Okay.
Now the next two cells.
Alright, we're gonna try to keep rotating.
We're gonna get to Pi-1 here.
There was no one really in Pi-1, so we're gonna keep walking on in.
Alright.
If you see any extra syringes, let me know.
I only have two.
There's two in here.
Okay, nice.
I got it.
Alright, now four.
Yeah.
They were in front of us here earlier, but I don't see them now, so...
Keep on following me.
We are blue though.
We're good.
Okay, I feel like Tempo has played a lot better since getting off of the roofs.
I agree.
Yeah, I feel like we've done a lot better now that he's not there.
I think the roofs were definitely the problem.
It's Tempo.
Without a doubt.
Yeah.
I don't know what you're talking about.
Alright, I see another evac tower here.
Oh, no.
It's a Mech.
Never mind.
I'm gonna scan this.
We can loot this up a little bit more.
We're gonna keep walking on this left side tree line.
We're gonna evac from here, okay?
We wanna grab that thing, right?
On the left?
Which one?
Yeah, you go first.
Yeah, correct.
We definitely do.
I'm trying to see if there's anything I should take.
Yeah, so right now I'm pretty good.
There's another 3x.
I took it three times, yeah.
I'm gonna get this Evo cache.
We are inside the next room.
Alright, I think I'm good.
I need like a stock if you guys buy an extra stock.
I'm looking top pylon.
I don't see anyone.
What do you wanna rotate to?
We should go top pylon right now and actually hit that fucking ring console if there's no one up there.
Alright.
Scatted then, just in case.
I am.
Yeah, I could be like, you know, you wanna stop in here.
I'm scanning.
No one's here.
I'm gonna take the head of it right now.
Hey, I'm...
There's a digi here.
Close range.
I'm downstairs.
I'm about to scan the thing.
What floor is it on?
I'm gonna craft another badge.
It's down here with me.
Okay, cool.
Wait, wait.
What?
You're good.
On the left, on the left, on the left.
We're good.
It should be close to us.
I heard something for sure.
I'm coming to you, Wade.
I hear them.
I hear them underneath it.
They're running away.
Okay.
They are?
They're running to you.
Yeah, they're running away.
Yeah, you're good.
You're good.
I'm gonna scan.
Yeah, yeah.
Definitely scan it for sure.
Now we might use your E-back tower.
Yeah, there... I see them.
Little armor.
Yeah, there's armor.
Crack one.
I see some here too.
Hmm.
What is free?
Is there a player scan we can hit?
No.
We should just go over here and take a risk.
We're gonna make a risk, okay?
Alright.
I mean, we do have redeploy.
Yeah, we're gonna take a risk here.
I have no idea what's free, but we're gonna find out.
19 squads up there was a little bit scary.
I can't lie.
Alright.
You good?
It's fine.
I can smoke us too.
Yeah, we should be good.
I don't think these guys will shoot us off.
Pretty stupid waste of time doing this to us.
Alright.
I'm ready.
Yeah, we're gonna redeploy here.
I don't have one, so whenever you guys put it up.
Okay.
Ready?
Wait, wait, wait.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
We're gonna try it.
We're gonna try to land something over here, okay?
Alright.
Just follow my lead.
I have no idea what's free and we're gonna find out.
We're gonna find out now.
Wait, we can't go over this.
The way it doesn't reach.
We're idiots.
Go this way.
Go back down.
Wait.
Go straight back down?
Yeah, straight back down.
That's correct.
Okay.
It does not make it.
Wait, we could've went the sideways.
It's fine.
Just come here.
Go back.
Just go back to buy one.
It doesn't reach over.
Alright.
I'd rather just play top tower right now.
I'd rather wait for the zone close and then we just play fucking...
Hit it one more time?
Yes.
Okay.
Goodbye, redeploy.
For some reason, I thought you could redeploy over there.
I swear to God, I've watched people redeploy.
I'm just gonna play the hide for now.
I remember when some... I had a tournament and then somebody... we were doing hide and seek and then they tried to redeploy from there and it didn't reach.
So one of the seekers died in zone.
Oh, really?
Yeah.
That's fucking hilarious.
It's the same thing too.
It was right here.
Yeah.
I was like, you probably know we can't get back over there.
On me.
On me, I guess.
I probably should know those things.
You probably should have actually.
Yeah, Mr. Watch.
Oh, I almost fell.
That's good.
Wait, I can't climb up this.
What?
Are you doing a zone read?
Yeah, we're gonna rush this closest.
Yeah.
I look north... east side.
I look east side.
There's no one next to this pack.
We wanna get this pack too.
You guys stay up here.
I'm gonna go with this pack.
Okay?
Okay.
I'm looking at east side.
I'm gonna watch over you or try to from here.
Okay.
We should be good.
There's no one over here, I don't think.
Yeah.
I'm watching top hill, so...
I don't see anybody on east side.
Yeah, we should be fine.
For some reason, we're the only team coming from highland right now, which I don't understand why.
You're clear so far.
I'm looking up the hill for you.
You're good, buddy.
I got a wingman.
I'm definitely taking it.
Okay.
Anyone need it two times or anything or no?
I do.
If you can bring it over.
I'll take it, yeah.
Gotcha.
We're still clear.
Yep, yep.
I got evo off that too.
Nice.
Huge.
Are you almost red, though?
Big.
No, no, no.
Definitely not even close to red.
Still 1900 off.
Okay.
That side's still clear.
There's nobody on east side.
I hear people fighting in the prowler section.
Yeah.
That's actually good, though.
Yeah, because they're almost going to have to come to us.
Yeah, that's fine.
I'm going to go down and get ready to scan.
Yeah, go for it, McDucky.
Yeah.
Here's your two times one.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'll grab it.
Hey.
Light ammo, two of you.
How's it going?
I'm looking at our east side still.
And also the north side a little.
Okay.
The Wrangler ulted the north.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I see them over there.
I see them coming over.
They're starting to come over.
Yeah.
They're definitely going to fight over there and just come this way.
It's fine.
I think we just let them.
We can't get there quick enough.
All right.
We see that sound, but I'll straight echo 100%.
We going now?
I need to go now for sure.
All right.
I'm heading over.
We're going to evac this way then.
Okay.
We're going to evac around the mountain.
Evac around three.
Yeah.
That's what I was thinking.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
We're going to have to.
We're going to have to this time.
I don't see anyone below this.
This is our last evac.
Well, I didn't see anyone here when you were looting the pack.
Okay.
So...
I think so.
There's like this little corridor over here.
I want to try to get to.
You know what I'm talking about?
The little tunnel in there?
Yeah.
I want to try to land in that tunnel and just put traps down and smoke immediately.
Okay.
So put an evac right here.
Like smoke ourselves or smoke the enemy?
We're going to smoke ourselves right when we land in there.
I'll go first so you guys know where to land.
We'll see though.
There might be a team there.
So I'm going to find out when we land in there.
Oh, they're shooting at you back now, bro.
Oh, no.
We're not.
We can't.
That's so fucking cringe.
Man.
I don't think we can.
Yeah.
What do we want to do?
We don't have an evac now, right?
No.
We don't have an evac.
That was our last one.
That's so bad for us actually.
I mean we're technically... is there anyone over here?
I'm not sure.
Our team just landed far right side.
Dude, this kid shooting at you back is so cringe.
I'm going to go look in this bench for an evac once I can get us to stay here.
Okay.
I'm looking behind us just in case.
Yeah, just get us out if we don't have an evac.
This is so fucked.
I really fucked us over that first one.
That's so cringe.
I want your back from Pylon.
I'm watching.
There's a guy running.
Where?
On Pylon?
No, no, no, no, no.
No, it's in front of Tempo in front of us.
I'm looking behind us now.
There's a team in Pylon though.
They're going to come over to the side.
We're going to have to try to kill these guys when they rotate in.
Wait, really?
Where?
I don't see them.
Over here.
They're going to be on the middle side.
Okay.
I don't see him still.
They're going to come this way though for sure.
I'm going to play down a little bit more and walk up to you guys.
Okay.
I don't want these kids to get like...
I'm going to get in cover here.
Yeah, you're good.
You're good.
They're going to rotate over here.
They're going to play just in Pylon.
Check.
I saw one guy at least.
It might be more than one.
But they're shooting their traps out right now.
They're top Pylon.
I just hope I don't get shot from behind.
I see them.
They're running down.
They're running down to the right.
Yeah, they're dropping.
I'm going to go to this tree.
Yeah, yeah.
Try to get in close on this.
Yes, yes, yes.
We want to fight this.
We do not want these kids to live.
I'm looking now.
They just scanned Beacon.
That's fine.
So...
They're going to rotate in on this right side.
Tempo, you're going out of zone by the way.
So...
Yep.
We need to try to get a knock when they cross over the wall.
They're here.
Yeah, we're good.
Yeah, I see them.
I see them.
I see us too.
It's actually so bad for us.
Just because this team on the top can't 100% rotate and kill us here.
Yeah.
They're on this box behind this car.
What color armor do you know?
Purple.
Purple?
Yeah.
Okay.
We're going to have to just 3v3 these guys.
I want to have an ulti.
So are now.
Nope.
Okay.
This is so bad for us.
Fuck me.
I have ult here though.
Yeah, you're good.
Wait.
Did they...
I think we just have to late rotate in the zone, boys.
I'm going to be honest.
I think we're just tired.
But they're getting shot.
We're trying to find another team.
Yeah.
No team's holding them.
Another team shot them.
There's one guy behind that tree though.
He's by himself.
Yeah.
Where's this other squad at?
Can we make it around the zone if we need to?
Yeah.
We can.
I think we're going to have to like get late and just walk in.
Hopefully all these guys just forgot about us to be honest.
I don't know.
I think they finished the fight already.
I don't know what happened over there.
They're not shooting anymore.
They're not shooting each other.
I'm not sure.
Ult to us.
Ult to the left.
Come to me guys.
Come to me.
Come to me now.
We're going to cross over to the zone.
We're going to cross over.
I have an arch.
I'm going to get hit by like three bang ults.
Me too.
I might be hit by this too.
I'm dead.
I'm dead to the zone.
I'm on it.
I'm skipping the bot.
I got five.
I'm on it.
I'm like, wait.
I'm stuck.
I ulted them too.
Yeah.
You're vibing.
So, but they all...
We're dead.
They scared us.
No way!
These kids are still sitting here, man.
No way.
I'm getting ran up.
I'll just...
Oh my god.
If we have an evac...
No!
This is not like playing Valk, man.
We had three.
We had three evacs too.
That's the worst we are.
We only used two.
What was the third one?
Oh, I'm top of the swarm.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They have an evac.
We should... I think we had the evac here.
That was the corner.
Well, no.
They could have got that.
They could have shot that out too.
They just were too distracted on my loot box.
I just didn't expect the team to be playing on the fucking cannon right there, man.
They looted the team.
They're dead.
No, no.
Oh, no.
No way.
Unless...
Oh, they're dead.
Yes.
Thank fucking god.
I hope you die.
Honestly, this is the team I don't mind.
I wish we kind of lived.
The other fucking squad is a bunch of fucking idiots.
So, we got one point from that though.
I'm so assed though, man.
Oh my god.
Look at all these nades.
Jesus Christ.
No way.
We're definitely going to play Valk though on World's Edge for sure.
Okay.
We need some backdoob.
I'll be right back.
They do.
We need our chat's wig.
I'm back.
Did you entertain our chat?
No.
What?
Why not?
I was commuting the whole time.
Told you.
What?
No.
I'm so sad that team just played cannon and shot an E back to our house.
Yeah.
Instead of power toys and rotate.
That's mind blowing.
Yeah.
And then they let the other team behind us rotate.
Why can they rotate and not us?
They had zero benefit of shooting our E back out.
They literally had nothing.
That was so dumb.
They're like, fuck these people.
I think we had more than one team shoot us because the E back tower died so fast.
No.
It was all three of them just shooting it.
Oh.
Which makes no sense because us E backing is better for them.
Like, I don't understand why the fuck they're shooting our E back out.
Because they're like, fuck that team and they knew it was us.
They had the...
No.
What they actually said was, what shoot E back?
I have no idea how to do that.
I don't know how to play the game correctly.
I can only say that.
Oh shit.
That's the specific words out of their mouth.
This is round two challengers.
I don't think anybody knows how to play in round two.
Yeah, I agree.
Bro, that's your wingman.
Yeah, it is.
That's your gun.
And he's whipping every shot.
And he's missing every shot with it.
Oh my god.
Bro.
Holy fuck.
Bro, I don't... bro, that's sad.
Are you still in Challenger circuit?
Damn!
So are we though.
So are we though, guys.
So are we.
I mean, we did die before them.
We did.
We did die before them.
First part is, we would have been so safe in the spot I wanted to go to.
I'm so sad.
Every time.
Every fucking time.
That's just one point.
Why shoot us then?
Why?
We're literally leaving your back.
Why do you not want us to rotate?
What are you doing?
Because they're like, what if we get that three extra KP though?
We got literally none of it.
Like, when it's all about the possibilities.
True.
My chat got to the part where we fucked up our redeploy.
Oh yeah.
I can't believe we can't get it.
I actually love you for a long time.
I guess I'm just so used to like fucking Valkoving over the house.
I thought we were gonna... I thought we were wrapping around the mountain.
Well, to be fair, we wouldn't have reached the spot I wanted to if we had to wrap around the mountainside.
Yeah, but then we could have extra redeploy.
Nah, we would have fucking landed on somebody for sure.
I mean, we could have maybe made it work, but...
Yeah, I thought we were going around and I was like, alright, I'm ready to go like halfway around and then I had to turn back.
To be fair though, there's just no world where that team would sure you back out and not let us go past them.
We should have let Tempo be free and just see what happens.
I could have, I could have ratted to zone, I could have ratted to zone six.
Yeah, yeah.
We should have let him be free and just see what happens.
I would be in a tree right now.
Spit it.
Alright, so, thank you.
We would have climbed up a tree and then we would have been top five.
That could have been us.
Like all these teams were fighting and then we were in that top five.
Oh, these are an all bowler team.
This spot, this spot we're in right now is actually exactly right next to where I want to go.
I'm so sad, man.
I could have been Ash.
I'm so... I could have been Ash.
That's good.
I'm so sad.
Yeah.
It's a horrible cat wall too.
What the fuck are we doing?
What if, why is he playing cat?
Is cat meta?
Cats aren't bad right now.
It's alright.
I don't know what's meta.
Oof, they're so dead.
Yeah.
I don't think they're gonna live this.
Yeah, they're definitely not.
Yeah, they're definitely, that team definitely is not first.
GG's.
Yeah!
We're not second though.
Oh man.
Love that for us.
We're doing it!
The one point.
We can pretend to be that team.
True.
Spent.
Spent, spent, spent.
We are gonna be...
We're gonna be like 15th probably.
Probably in...
Yeah.
15th, 16th.
Yeah, somewhere around there.
Yeah, without a doubt.
Yeah, 100%.
We should really only be like five points ahead, so...
Yeah.
We just need a good last two games.
We just need to get to zone, bro.
Yeah, we need to be at zone.
Hardest thing about Challenge Circuit is all the dumbasses that play.
They don't play edge.
That's the hardest thing.
Yeah.
There's a lot of teams that play edge in this one, I think.
I left my team.
Alright, I am waiting for...
Who's this person?
I don't know who this person is.
I'm always worried I accidentally rejected somebody that I actually know, because so many people just randomly add me.
That's so true.
Actually.
And like, I don't reject, I just straight up block.
I don't...
I think that happened.
I block so much.
I blocked 100% of my friends.
Without a doubt, I definitely blocked friends.
I think like somebody who was in my team for one of the tournaments added me, but I was like, who is this fucker?
And then I actually blocked.
And after I blocked them, I was like, wait, they were on my team.
That's so funny.
That is so ridiculous.
Alright.
We are...
Yup.
Exactly.
14.
And 10th is four points away from us.
Oh, it's not that long.
We just need a good last two games.
Exactly.
Exactly what we thought would happen.
I'm playing World Chess.
I'm playing Valkyrie's Game.
Okay.
Not Bloodhound.
I blood.
Yeah.
Okay.
Let me make sure my banner represents correctly what I am as a player.
So I'll be honest.
Where are we going on this map?
We don't even know, right?
Yeah.
We'll figure it out.
We don't even know.
Oh, the badges aren't fixed yet.
We'll just type siphon to start with.
The badges aren't fixed yet.
I will guarantee those.
Siphon is probably just fucked up.
No, we can just...
I can just type the thing again.
You'll...
We will play...
You won't get invited to any tournament.
I'm not sure.
Fair.
That's cool.
That's good.
Fence always work.
Everyone likes to play.
That's good.
Threatening other people.
That's a good thing to do.
Yeah.
Are we good people, guys?
We can start threatening more.
Yes.
Are we?
Are you?
Yes.
Okay.
Maybe not you, but yes.
Wait.
What about me?
Why?
Yeah, maybe.
Maybe not you, but yes.
What?
What did I do?
Just got to be nicer, man.
I'm not the one that's threatening people!
Also, lobby code's out.
Yeah, oh we're in, don't worry.
Oh wait, hey guys, did you guys know that the lobby code is out?
Every fucking time.
Did you guys know that the lobby code is out?
Someone's signing fissure.
Tissue.
Yay!
So far so good!
I believe in us.
I always do.
Alrighty.
What's the worst that could happen?
I mean, we should- I think we might be free here, I'm not sure.
We'll see.
If we're not free though, there's no way we can really swerve.
That's the only problem.
We can swerve, Tree is still open.
Tree and Harvester are still open.
I'm crossing off as I see people post stuff.
Okay.
Is it still open?
Yup.
Yay!
Okay.
We got this.
Yeah, we can still- just in case, we can still swerve, Harvester and Tree.
That's fair.
I'm down for that actually, that's pretty good.
We got this, I believe.
I totally believe in us.
This is the game where we're in the top five.
This is where we got all of our points, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, exactly.
World's Edge is where we got a lot of our points.
This is it.
Which?
Hmmmm.
Okay, so Lava Siphon and we swerved to Tree, it wouldn't be that bad.
We can make that work.
We just really need to focus on getting this fucking end zone, bro.
If we just get a good spot in zone, we're literally just guaranteed to fucking qual.
We just need a beacon.
It's just avoiding the bullshit, man.
It's so hard for us to do that sometimes.
In that situation, we 100% could have if we had a Valk and we get into zone and probably get top five, but it's really fucking hard when the evac's just getting shot out for no reason at all.
Yeah.
We're in that situation.
At the lows.
We're better at World's Edge than we are on Stormpoint.
Yeah, we're a World's Edge team.
That's us.
We'll never figure out Stormpoint, but that's okay.
Agreed.
Alright, one more.
We're a World's Edge squad.
That's us.
I love these guys are talking about fucking Rainbow Six, dude.
Bro, I don't think they're locked in, man.
I swear.
Which team is it?
I don't know.
Okay, they are... which team?
Which team?
I swear, they're talking about Rainbow Six Siege and they're higher ranked than us.
I don't know.
I don't...
Guys, I don't know.
I think we have a problem.
No, we're good.
We're good.
I'm listening to fucking no hands right now.
We're so locked in.
I thought that we're supposed to be better this time.
Girl, drop it to the floor.
The amount of charge rifle shots.
Are we supposed to be better gamers?
This time around?
We have the speed to throw this cash.
No, we're doing good.
We're doing good.
We're actually in a pretty good... we just got top 15 both games in a row.
That's pretty good, actually.
Last week, we got like 19th in the second game.
And then like 19th again, I think.
And then the last game, we also got 19th last game.
Last week.
No, okay.
No, last week, we got two games where we didn't place very well, but we still got top 12.
Yeah.
We still got top 12.
We're in the last game too.
We're good.
We're in a better streak already.
I thought we were 14th right now.
Yeah.
Which is better, but through two games last week, we were not at 14th.
We were at 14th only because of one game though.
Oh.
We got one game.
We got the RV.
And it was just like two games.
Yeah.
And then we got second place.
And then we got like 19th, 19th, 19th.
Okay.
We just need to repeat that.
We need to repeat that exact scenario.
Yeah.
We need to go find an RV.
We need to find an RV, guys.
Guys, yes.
You're understanding a little bit.
This is good.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We figured it out.
We need spots where no one can shoot us because we don't have the firepower for this.
Exactly.
We're a strategic team.
We're not a shooting team.
Wait.
Let me go plug in Evan's controller.
Hello.
Wait.
What are you trying to say about his controller, bro?
What?
He's cheating?
Huh?
You need so bad, huh?
No.
You plug in Hal's controller so you can get to the story.
There's a special thing on there, you know?
Yeah.
On the back of it?
I thought it was a rumble pack, but it wasn't.
He downloaded a program for it?
No.
Don't worry.
I'm ready for Bloodhound.
All right.
So, siphon into tree or harvester if we need to survive.
Bro, I can't believe my ring badge is still not back yet.
Or do we just contest siphon?
You know?
TSM?
We have the TSM buff.
We contest siphon, we win.
No.
That's just not...
I don't think I wanna do that.
Guys, I don't know if I want to contest any fucking...
Why do we not have beacon again?
I don't know.
Dude, fuck them.
They don't get the damage.
Yeah, nobody gets Siphon.
We're looting two POIs.
Wait, there's no point in scanning this yet.
Stream rate advantage.
Don't scan until it's done, yeah.
It's fine.
I'd actually rather just land Tree anyway because the fucking beacons, dude.
I'm not going to go Lava Siphon with no beacon.
It's useless to us.
What is our luck though?
Landing Lava Siphon and not getting a beacon is crazy.
Why is our round two worse than...
Our luck should be better in round two than round one.
Never.
We actually have the worst round fucking...
The worst round two.
Ever.
And my loot is fucking awful.
Me too.
Oh my god.
There's a Devo and a Mastiff.
I don't like this.
Does that at least... Does the bot that you shot down at least have a key?
No.
I don't think so.
Oh my god.
This is a...
I'm ready to...
No, it's going to end no name I think.
I think it's going to end no name or blue bin.
It's one of the two.
It's okay.
I'm ready to rotate.
Yeah, we should rotate.
I'm going to loot this backside house and we just go.
Okay.
Do we go back to Siphon?
We are going to go to Siphon.
Okay.
I'm going to go to the bridge.
Okay, go for it.
Yeah.
I'm going to go.
It's okay.
If I die, then my teammates are dog shit.
I don't know if that's how that works out actually.
That's not how that works.
Wait.
Doki looted this whole place and didn't grab the harvester.
Doki.
Oh, I didn't see it.
The evil thing didn't show up.
The evil thing popped up when I looted it.
Oh my god.
She's not locked in.
Okay.
You can't say that because the thing did not pop up when I was looting that.
You cannot blame me on that.
It literally did not open.
That was not my fault.
I'm going to go up this zip thingy.
It literally didn't pop up.
We're separating pretty far, guys.
You said there's no one there.
So I'm fully trusting my idea.
I said there's probably no one in Lava Siphon.
I have no idea.
If I die, Doki will kill me.
We'll rotate through Siphon.
Meet my call.
It's not my fault if I die.
This is South Siphon.
South Siphon is not looted.
We're going to rotate through this.
Oh, wait.
They're far.
They're over on your launch.
I have a gold mag for you, Wig.
Okay, great.
Thank you so much.
Do you want to scan the people beacon?
We should scan stuff.
I'm going to go to people beacon.
Wait, I saw a trail this way.
You see that?
No, I did not look at it.
There's a red trail over there.
I'm going to go inside with you.
I dropped a gold.
I'll take that.
Thank you.
Why not?
Wait a minute.
Where did you see that thing?
Was it in the red?
I saw a red trail taking me from the red up point.
And then they flew this direction.
But I don't know if they flew inside the building or what.
Or they flew this way.
I couldn't tell.
I'm going to move up and check.
I couldn't tell the direction.
I'm heading over.
I'm going to take lava damage just for you guys.
Thank you.
I tried to get on the car.
It didn't work.
It's okay, buddy.
Let me know when I can do the people scan.
We're going to figure that out right when you get over here.
Does someone need a 2x?
I do if you don't need it.
Yeah.
We're good.
I don't see anyone here.
Okay.
I'm going to risk my life.
Do it.
Because my teammate told me to.
I got you.
Trust me.
Pew pew pew.
Let's see.
Nobody.
Oh yeah.
We need to get going.
What the fuck is going on at Monument?
Come through over here.
We're going to get up through choke right now.
We're going to get topside guys with choke.
Lava 7 choke.
We're good.
I have four cells.
I have cells too.
I have four bats though.
Blue bag.
We're going to hit this tower in front of us.
And we're going to get top of the guys with choke.
Lava 7 choke.
I'm ready.
Go for it.
Right here.
I just wanted to look at that bird.
And I was waiting for you anyway.
Okay.
I had to go grab a bat.
They're trying to take it from us.
Where are they?
They're down below.
We can't.
God damn it.
Where did they come from?
We need to move in a little bit more.
I want to get to zone.
We're not going to be able to get to zone from here.
That's so fucked.
We can go around from the geyser side.
Let's see what they do.
There's a team in there right now.
That sucks.
Let's see if this team in lava 7 choke moves.
I don't know if they're going to hold it or not.
Damn.
We were like half a second earlier.
Where's the geyser team?
They're next to geyser.
The actual geyser itself.
They were in there.
I think this team would have moved up a little bit.
We're going to go up here and scan.
I think this team is not here anymore.
They moved up.
They left the choke completely.
We're going to walk up and scan.
Get to right here and scan.
If they're up there, stay on your mountainside and you're good to go.
Scanning?
Nope.
Take, take, take.
I'm going up.
We'll let my IGL go up further.
Yeah, let me go first.
I see a rez.
We're fine right now.
53 seconds ago.
There's a gas canister here.
There's going to be a team on the right side.
There's definitely a team over here.
I got scanned.
I'm just going to full heal this.
Go for it.
We have a redeploy.
We want to use it.
I don't know where this is going to pull.
This might pull back.
We'll stay here for now.
We'll watch front then.
Yeah, you watch front.
Just make sure you don't get ratted on.
They can 100% creep up.
We just play from here and we can evade.
We can valkyrie delay if we need to.
It's not a bad spot because this could be a wonky pull.
I don't really trust this pull at all.
Okay.
I was waiting until they scan.
Should be fine.
Also, if the zone does pull down, I'm pretty sure big house is not taking it.
Just to point out.
Temba, you keep looking behind us down below.
Yeah, I'm looking siphon.
Yeah, I'm going to scope this scene out.
Yeah, just keep on scanning.
There is a team siphon.
I'm looking at monument side too.
They slid down.
We hold these kids down no matter what.
That's for sure.
Wait, someone just hit a beacon.
What the hell was that noise?
Someone just hit a ring console.
Right here, what the fuck?
Is he just in the open?
I don't know.
He just hit a ring console.
Careful, Temba.
We backed up.
Who are we by the way?
Yeah, I don't know what the fuck that was.
I just heard a ring console and that guy was in front of me.
What?
What a bug.
Yeah, you're good.
They are going to blue bin.
We are fine.
They are leaving us.
Are you still looking?
Okay, you are still looking behind.
Yeah.
I see them.
What the fuck is this spot you are trying to play, buddy?
Just leave.
Leave us.
We are content.
Leave.
I don't know why they are trying to hold you.
This spot is so bad.
Unless they think there is someone behind.
Remember, this is round two.
Oh my god.
Okay, one sec.
I heal.
Watch out for them.
Temba, focus your attention on the front side.
I'll look back.
They are waiting still.
Yeah.
You have to step a little bit more and keep scanning and show presence.
No, no, no.
How are they fucking pushing this?
I'm batting this.
What am I watching right now?
There is someone behind us.
What the fuck?
Bro, we are getting griefed, man.
Come to my corner.
What am I fucking watching right now?
We just got Caustic ulted.
Am I saving Slyre?
Get the ADR.
We are fucked.
We are so dead.
No.
Just hide.
There is another team pushing forward.
You don't exist.
I'm getting griefed.
No, genuinely, what the fuck am I playing, bro?
Oh my god.
I don't know.
It's another time for it.
These kids are so fucking bad, man.
Bro, just save the house.
That's your home now, Temba.
Oh my god, bro.
This is the shit that tells me.
Just don't pick time to chill.
Oh my god.
Bro, what the fuck?
Don't worry, guys.
I can get your banner.
I can get your banner and then evac tower.
No, no.
This is...
Banner, evac, and I'm good.
And I have a mobi right here.
Just get us one point.
I actually cannot believe what I'm talking about.
How is that team able to push from blue bins?
Why are they pushing from blue bins?
What are you doing?
These are why these kids stay hard to challenge a circuit for 98 years.
Holy fuck, dude.
Oh my god.
How is this possible?
How in the world are they able to push up like that?
That is crazy.
Temba, is that P20 I see in your hand?
Yeah, I was looking for a re.
Yo, I have hammer points.
It's okay.
I believe.
No one's gonna go in your house.
There's no way.
Just stay there.
Don't even fucking get out of...
Don't even leave.
Just stay there.
There's no way.
Oh my god, it pulls right on top.
Does it pull on the choke?
Oh my god, it does, bro.
It pulls out here.
And we just got grief so hard.
You know the old zone with the pills and shit?
Yeah.
It's gonna be the blue pens one.
We literally called it perfectly.
And we just got grief from two fucking...
Oh my god.
We got grief so hard.
I think it was the nade.
They saw you got naded and they're like, this is it.
This is it.
In any good lobby, that team just cannot move.
They just cannot push from blue pens.
Like, it doesn't make...
Yeah, they got grief for that.
Let's just hope that team doesn't...
How many gas cans can you have out?
Six.
Wait, really?
I'm maxed out.
Okay, wouldn't it be funny to just throw a nade and activate all six of these?
That's why... yup.
That's why I have a nade for counter-activate.
That time when we had...
We had Wigg as the rat and now it's Tempu's time to shine.
All you need to do is get to 15th.
Plus one.
No, I have a nade.
I'm gonna win.
I believe in you.
I'm gonna get to third and then I'm gonna nade them as they 3P each other.
Oh no.
Guys, where did that scan come from?
I have no idea, guys.
I have no fucking clue.
Are they behind you?
While we were fucking...
strategizing the one Bloodhound scan to end it all.
To find out you're a rat.
You're so fucked.
No, you're a rat, bro.
Wait, I can... I can evac out of here.
You got this, man.
Another pause for the rest of the year.
Guys, we need one more team to die.
One more team to die.
One more.
That's all we need.
I'm doing the top 10 out of you, guys.
That's gotta be from up there, right?
It came from behind, didn't it?
I swear it came from behind.
I wish we could ping when we're dead.
I wish that was a feature.
Maybe they'll miss the scan if I'm wrong and just died.
It's easy, dogs, bro.
I feel it.
I can feel it.
I can feel that top 15.
I do too.
Yeah, yeah.
We just need... we literally need one team.
One more team to die while this recloses.
I'm not gonna push you in here, bro.
I would not push you.
Like, I'll be real.
Seven barrels deep.
A fucking fart bomb.
Like, I need... I think you get this top 15.
Oh, yes!
Let's go!
I feel like that team might push you.
Oh, that's two different bloodhounds.
Okay.
Oh my god.
It pulls there.
As soon as these guys pass me, I can... as soon as these guys walk out past me, I can late evac from out here.
And then just go in a circle.
Holy shit.
This is a terrible zone.
This is literally open.
Well, to be fair, the team Bluebeard should have been dead.
The fucking Geyser team should have shot them the whole fucking time they're walking up on us.
Like, what are they doing?
Are they touching themselves?
Like, I don't understand.
Bro, the homies gotta, you know, relieve the other homies' stress.
Yeah, they're just jerking each other off.
These guys are running past.
You need ultis.
You need ultis, Tebow.
You need to stay alive for top 12.
No, no, no.
I think they're running past.
They are not running past.
Oh, good, bitch.
Yeah, fuck them up, Tebow.
Top 10, baby.
Come on.
Yeah, yeah.
Fuck you.
I have 18 million barrels.
You can't get in here.
Oh.
I don't know, man.
Top 10.
You're so close.
Keep barreling.
Just do like a non-stop barrel act.
Yes, 100%.
There's no way.
That's your new door.
This is the barrel act of 2024.
Oh, my God.
Are you gonna keep doing that?
Nice.
Top 10.
Yes.
I fucking hate challenger circuit.
Good shit, bro.
Good job.
Well played, man.
I wouldn't know if this team is gonna...
Oh, they stole your evac.
They're stealing my plan.
They stole your plan.
I hope they die off this evac.
Yeah.
I hope you fucking fly into a mountain and die.
Oh, my God.
You could've died there.
If that was you, you would've died.
You would've died.
There's no way.
Bro, if you lived, we would've been top 6.
We got full sent on from fucking...
We were playing this choke here.
We got one team came up here.
Two teams came up here.
And then we just got fucking full sent.
That could've been you.
They stole your evac.
That's actually a really good spot where they landed, bro.
I'm not gonna lie.
That was a good job.
That could've been us, man.
That could've been fucking tempo.
We got top 10.
Was that two points for top 10?
I think so.
Nice.
We got plus 2.
Okay, last game, guys.
We need to have a really good game.
Yeah, that's for damn sure.
Or I don't think we're making it.
Are we ever not gonna get griefed in round 2?
Or what the fuck going on?
Our round 2 is never lucky.
We're lucky in round 1.
The fucking round that never matters.
Like...
This is bullshit.
This is bullshit, dude.
I call for a recount.
I demand a revote.
Yeah, I demand this particular game to be reset.
I agree.
I think they bring us back to the exact same circle.
Restart the game.
We go from there.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Guys, do you not want more content?
We're literally boosting the Challenger Circuit views right now.
Are you fucking kidding me?
You guys, like...
I bet you...
Why do you keep doing this?
Don't you want the content to be good?
I bet you I have the most viewers on YouTube right now for Challenger Circuit.
You need me for the YouTube representation.
Actually, though...
We need you for the viewership.
Come on!
Come on, Tease!
You gotta let us...
We're here to save Apex!
So we can go Syphon, by the way.
Yeah, we can.
But if there's no beacon, I don't even know what to do.
I just wanna go there.
That's true.
Alright.
So we've got two POIs.
Yeah, we have two POIs.
Realistically, this last game should be good for us.
All I'm saying...
Let us through to round three and we'll give you more content.
Best case scenario, we're in 12th.
Okay.
That's definitely not gonna happen, for sure.
That's not gonna happen.
We'll probably stay in 14th, which means we need a 10-point game.
Okay.
Alright, that's doable.
That's second place and one kill.
Oh, he still had a conduit?
Oh, and then he still hit himself.
Oh my god.
Oh, and then he...
Oh no!
Bro, this guy has a 4k badge.
What the fuck?
Bro, what the fuck am I watching?
Oh, yo.
You know what I should've done?
What?
When that team was coming in, I should've given them the evac.
Yeah, they would've left.
And then they would've left.
And then I would've been like, alright, see you guys.
Yeah, but then you would've just died on the walk up.
Yeah, you would've died on the walk up, not gonna lie.
You needed that evac.
Oh no, no, I'd take it after them.
I'd pretend like we're four people on a team.
I should've colluded.
I feel like you'd be the one who...
Yeah, all four of us should've taken the balloon.
I should've just thrown it out for them and then been like...
Truce.
Yeah, but I think if you just threw it out for them, the other team would've shot the evac.
Because there was no way they would've fucking not shot it.
It would've been a truce, what do you mean?
No, I meant the other team.
The other, other team.
Yeah, but then they would see four of us and get scared.
No, they'll see the fucking evac tower and shoot it down.
Like, what?
I'm confused.
Okay, jeez.
This is it.
Oh my god.
I'm still watching that conduit do some amazing things.
Oh, conduit 838326?
Guys, I thought that we were a world's edge team.
What happened to us?
We used to be...
We just got griefed, guys.
Teams around us have no brain cells.
I called the zone perfectly.
I like, literally knew exactly where it was going.
And we had Geyser choke doing a fucking team jerk off into the fucking shooting squad.
We should've been in a house.
We should've probably threw the roof for them though, bro.
I'm gonna be honest.
If that team that was on those boxes, the blue bins, lived, I swear to god, I'd be so sad.
I'm pretty sure they did.
They did?
No one pushed them?
No.
Geyser choke did nothing.
Those guys were awful.
Geyser didn't do anything.
Yeah, but I'm thinking like the other team behind them.
That's what you would think.
For sure.
No, for sure.
They just don't.
They don't know what they're doing.
Yeah, that's right.
That's what he meant.
I have no idea who the...
Okay.
Oh wait, no, that is them.
Wait, no, it's a Wraith team.
Wraith Caustic Blood Hound team.
I haven't seen a Wraith Caustic Blood Hound team at all.
Someone was like in my chat, what if it's the TSM tag that's giving you the scarce?
Okay, let's remove our TSM tag.
Let's remove it and see if we get better.
You're still right.
It's the tag.
It's the tag curse.
It'd be funny when we get tagged.
I'm about to just literally say to fucking that chat, guys are choked.
We jerking each other off or what?
Do it!
Do it.
Uh...
Okay, I'm taking off the TSM tag.
Guys, we got fired from TSM.
We are.
Oh, we only dropped one rank.
We're in 15.
Oh, it's still about how far we all came.
Seven points.
Oh.
Okay.
Alright, so yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
It's not bad at all.
Seven points?
If you get a ten point game, we're definitely back in it.
Yeah.
I got rid of TSM.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Ten point game.
Alright, let's go.
Ten point game, guys.
We need this one.
Guys, okay.
Wait, wait, wait.
Twelve, nine, seven.
We need third and three kills, okay?
Easy.
Nice, yeah.
It's so easy, guys.
We have two POIs.
We can't fuck this up.
Yeah, exactly.
There's no way.
I'll just type code in chat.
Oh, that would be so funny.
Oh, G-Table, your loadout was crazy, bro.
P20 charge rifle is nuts.
Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
I was like, is that P20?
I couldn't find the read.
Alright?
I had hammer points, okay?
The thing is, I don't think that makes it better.
No, no.
There were so many big guns on the ground when I passed, it was crazy.
Wait, Hammer doesn't make it better?
No.
Well, I was also looking for a read.
That's why.
Fair.
Fair, fair.
How do you not find a read?
That's so weird.
That's like one of the...
Whoever geyser choked...
choking each other.
Guys, I'm in the lobby now.
We're good.
I'm here.
You guys know the lobby codes out, guys?
Oh yeah, we're in here.
We're in here.
By the way, we're in.
Alright, guys.
10-point game.
Let's do this.
Alright, 10-point game.
Easy.
Never lost a 10-point game.
This is it.
We got this.
I believe in this.
I'm in that situation, bro.
You're go for that.
We can do this.
We're like 40 barrels down in the hole.
I feel like...
If that team just left me alone, I feel like I could have flew and then landed somewhere and just rap jammed all the way to third.
Yes, but Warren, challenge your circuit.
No team actually thinks for themselves.
Yeah.
They rely on feelings.
Yo, you know what?
They should make it and then we can play Pathfinder.
They should make it so Pathfinder can't be scanned.
Because he's a robot.
What the fuck?
Because then we could just play Pathfinder and no one would scan us.
Yeah, but then the rest of us can get scanned.
Oh no, when we're ratting.
Oh, when the rat has to rat.
Yeah, when the Pathfinder has to rat, basically.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, I see.
Great job fighting to that team who tried to fight us leaving Geyser.
Yeah.
I think that's us.
Whoever Geyser...
Wait, what were you saying?
They were beating each other off in the Geyser room?
The Geyser choke?
Yeah.
Were we in the Geyser choke?
We were not in the Geyser choke.
No, but the team Geyser choke didn't shoot the Blue Bin team at all.
I don't know what the fuck they were doing.
Like in that situation, we were like, definitely maybe need to show more presence in the front, but that team on Geyser choke should be shooting that Blue Bin the whole time.
That was like the freest kills for both of us.
Alright, 100P.
I believe in us, guys.
We can do this.
There's no way.
We just need a really, really, really good last game.
No, just a semi.
3 and 3 isn't that much of a stretch.
This is literally our last game tempo.
We really need a good game.
Yeah, 3 and 3.
12, 9, 7, 8.
That's 10 points.
Yo, teammate is duo.
Do we just land on them?
No.
Yeah, we get 2 free kills.
What if another team thirds as well?
There's no way.
I bet you this team is a controller team.
We play 3 shooting people.
Or 3 ability damage people.
There's no way.
We're not griefing our last game.
Maggie, Fuse, and...
Oh shoot, Stuck.
And Valk.
Maggie, Fuse, and Valk.
And then we land on the duo.
He wants us to land on the duo.
Maggie, Fuse, and Valk.
And we just ability spam team 8 and land on them.
Late land on them.
And then get 2 free points.
Where do we...
Where...
God, my head hurts so hard.
Oh, fuck.
Um...
I mean...
Let's just go Lava Siphon.
Let's go Lava Siphon, guys.
Let's get a rotation.
We just need a good endgame, bro.
I don't think we can go...
We broke Wig.
We got top 3.
We can qualify.
Bro, you actually broke Wig.
He's just like, did you just say that?
I'm not kidding.
I actually ignored the whole thing.
I heard that and I was like, dude, I can't.
I'm so low on the game.
I'm so locked in to get this top 10 right now that I just can't think about what we just said.
I can't.
I'm locked.
We got this.
We're doing this.
I believe.
Let's do it.
We are a World's Edge team.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Guys, don't fucking take my 2 points that I got in the first game.
Guys, it has to matter.
It was 2 points.
We don't do anything.
Those 2 points you did didn't mean fuck all.
Yeah, like what the fuck?
I tried so hard.
I'm bang, right?
I'm bleeding.
I'm actually... I wanna point out how good that would have been for us if we stayed alive.
That sucks.
Yeah.
We got this.
Alrighty.
Locked.
I have to go to the bathroom pretty bad though.
Alright, let's do it.
Wait, did you not go to the bathroom just then?
I did.
Okay, I was gonna say.
Yo, we got beacon.
We got beacon.
Wait, my game crashed.
My game crashed.
What?
No!
Alt F4 your game because you are still in here.
So Alt F4 your game and then reconnect.
Your water orn look we know what is going on.
No way!
Can you not F4 reset?
If you Alt F4 you can get in.
No, no, my game like full crashed.
Yeah, just close your entire game and then restart.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I just closed the entire game.
You should really get back in.
Okay, that was so scary.
Please, please, please.
Wait, there is still going on with typing now.
Please, please, please, please, please, please, please.
You think so?
It looks like it, right?
Please, please, please, please, please.
No, they are going left.
I thought you could reset.
Please, please, please.
No, what is her luck?
We are good, we are good.
I am in, I am in.
No one is lining with us.
I am going to land here in the middle.
And punch her in.
I am in, I am in, I am in, I am in, I am in, I am in.
I am going to land in middle because of Beacon.
Just hit the Beacon.
Let me get this to you.
Is there a team on us?
No, no, no, no.
Okay, I am going to loot the inside of this then.
Okay, nice.
Oh my god.
That would have been a shitty way to go out.
Oh my God.
Jesus Christ.
Alright, so I'm close too.
We got a good rotation here.
Probably gonna be staging side.
Holy fuck me, man.
That was scary.
Not gonna lie.
Pressing me the fuck out.
That was so scary.
Thank God.
I got gold helmet though.
Let's go.
Wait, we have two gold helmets?
It's huge.
We'll give it to you when we get into town.
It's great.
Yeah, I'm gonna look the far left.
The far left.
There's something over there.
Purple stuff.
I don't know what it is.
I'll look.
Guys, I found my re.
Nice.
One game too late.
Watch this.
Nah.
There's also a bunch of evac towers over here if you guys wanna have them.
You ping it?
Yeah, I got you.
Nice.
Got it.
Damage.
Do you see a repeater?
Let me know.
We have the geocache over here too.
What do we want?
Top thermal or...
Yeah, it's gonna be thermal chokes.
Thermal chokes.
Yeah, there's an energy mag here.
I'm gonna grab this.
Actually, no.
I don't need a repeater anymore.
I have a carbine.
There's a purple heavy mag here.
Someone with thermal will be really good.
I think the two story buildings will be really good for us.
So we should probably rush immediately if we can.
Okay, I'm coming over then.
Yeah, come over me now guys.
Both of you.
I wanna get here fast.
I don't really wanna deal with the bullshitting and try to get a good spot in zone.
Alright.
I'm running.
Yeah, yeah.
Come my way.
I'm running.
No tempo so far.
It should be fine now.
There's a charge rifle here too.
That's too late.
I have a sense.
I don't know.
I also have a vault key if we need something in the end here.
Maybe, maybe.
Let's just go quick.
Yeah, we just move first.
If we get those two stories, we can actually win this game I think.
I think it's gonna pull that way.
Could even go island, but regardless, we still can play.
Come on, get that.
Evac and then I'm running straight.
I mean, it's in my pathway anyway.
Yeah, it's fine.
No, don't worry.
You should probably get it.
You're chilling.
Alright, I'm good.
Okay.
Wait, do you need a heavy mag?
No, I'm actually good bro.
I got a purple one.
I'm chilling.
I have no backpack.
This is bad.
It's fine.
It should be fine.
Yeah, I didn't get a chance to do the people scan.
Don't forget.
No, it's all good.
We're gonna go towards tree and then ult the end.
Actually, can I evac?
If I... Okay, we're gonna try something here.
We're gonna try something.
We're gonna come to me.
Yeah.
Not here.
Can I grab that canister?
Yeah, go get that cash.
Go get the cash.
Yeah, we gotta wait for Doki anyway.
Yeah, you're chilling.
You should be fine.
Yep, I'm good.
I'm here.
So, when we slam inside one of these buildings, guys, it's a really good chance we're gonna be there.
So, just like stay together.
We're gonna literally just try to slam inside one of the buildings.
I'm here.
Okay, you're good.
You're good.
Don't worry.
I'm chilling.
Alright, come over to me.
Ready?
Can I go up here and hit this?
I can.
How do I touch this?
What?
You're good.
You got this.
Alright.
Up here.
Okay?
It's hard ping.
I'll get it.
I'll ping.
We're gonna see which one's free though.
One of those buildings, yeah.
We're gonna try to slam the second floor of this left one, okay?
This one?
This one.
Left one.
Right here.
Okay.
Then right here.
Then we're gonna scan across and we're gonna try to get to the next one if there's no one in that one, okay?
One sec.
On us!
Here.
Come upstairs.
That trap downstairs is not mine.
You're good.
Okay.
Can you scan across?
No more scans.
Okay.
We're gonna wait for the scan.
Are they okay?
Three seconds.
Scanning.
Yep.
If there's no one in the next building, we should go.
Take this building then.
Come here.
What happened to them?
I don't know.
They backed up.
There was one guy.
He shot himself.
It's fine.
Alright.
Let's take this one.
We're good.
We're gonna hold this one and we're chilling.
There's a Loba near us.
That's fine.
Great.
Okay.
Nice.
We're good.
Set up our floors.
Lock doors down below.
We're good to go.
Nice job.
We have no backpack you said?
No.
Oh no.
I have a lot.
I have eight cells, one bat.
Okay.
So not great.
Like my ammo situation is not good.
I'm gonna throw... I mean...
I feel like I need more ammo then.
Does anyone want my Phoenix kit?
Oh nevermind.
I'm coming back out.
Wait.
You're gone.
We're still here.
Whoa.
Okay.
There's two up here.
Trying to get the loot.
Oh I just realized I have no fucking sight on my...
sniper gun.
There's a...
I'll give you my 2x because I don't think I can shoot really.
Here.
That's fair.
Because I literally don't have the ammo to shoot.
To poke at all.
Here.
Take it before it gets taken.
What do you need?
I'll give you my ammo.
Well I have light and energy and 120 each.
There's a lot of energy.
There's some more energy down here too.
Yeah.
I don't have the backpack space.
I only have two stacks of each.
Oh here.
I can get it for you.
I want to get a few here.
It's like... Yeah.
You can grab the energy and light here.
Yeah I got you.
I'll get the light and energy first.
I literally don't have the ammo for poking.
Here.
We're gonna keep this door closed guys.
Just keep this door closed.
We're not gonna take too much damage if we don't.
I have two bad stick cells.
I have one phoenix kit, one bat, and seven cells.
I literally cannot poke because of the lack of...
stuff.
Here's your ammo though.
Just in case.
Alright.
We're a little poor.
Well we're a little poor now but I'm not gonna lie.
Our spot's good.
I just...
Can't you like climb up on this thing or something?
No.
I think they patched it in.
Yeah they used to be able to.
Because people would...
rat here and then like wait until somebody comes in and then shoot them.
Oh tempo here as well.
Come here.
Come upstairs.
Take this.
I have more ammo.
I have my... Oh yeah barrels.
Yeah.
Yeah you're good.
Just in case.
I definitely don't need my ulti or my fucking Q.
Yeah you don't need those.
Yeah there's no... You can't climb that.
I'm gonna stay in the bathroom.
I don't think I can contribute to the team unless somebody pushes us.
I can't really do anything either.
I'm just kidding.
I hope the zone comes to your game.
That's what this is.
Well we have evacs right?
Yeah we have two evacs and knuckles.
Evac-ing from here.
I feel like we're shot down.
Good job though.
Like...
Like honestly we just got grief last game.
We're actually calling zones like pretty good.
We're not doing anything wrong.
Yeah yeah.
It's just other people ruining our game.
It seems like that's a very common trend for us.
We never do anything wrong.
We just need this to pull.
We just need this to pull literally right here.
And then we can get top three.
And we can get kill somewhere.
Yeah.
I have three nades though.
That's all we need bro.
We literally just need an end game.
We need nades and ghasts.
I have no nades but...
With the 10 minute delay.
Now everybody knows I'm gay.
Now everybody knows.
So my chat said that.
Didn't chat not have delay?
Go ahead.
I don't think he understood the assignment.
I'm confused.
I don't think he realized what delay means.
Nothing wrong with it anyway.
Fuck it.
Do your thing.
Good job coming out in my chat.
Team playing fence over there.
I'm just using the bathroom.
Can you take one of these barrels...
two of these barrels out and put them in the doors in the other building?
Two of these barrels out and put them in the doors in the other building?
Block the doors.
Wait.
Let's see where this team goes first.
They're going to land on it I think.
They are.
They are?
No they're not.
They're not.
I don't think so.
I think you can do it buddy.
Block their doors.
Alright.
100 ammo.
Let's go.
Block it from the inside?
Inside.
Yeah.
And then come out the top side.
So when they land inside they can get stuck outside.
We can kill them.
Good idea.
Yay.
Seven more squads please die.
I got more light ammo for you.
A lot more squads.
Give me.
I can only eat like 30 of that though.
Or not even 30.
I'm stressed out dude.
I'm stressed out.
It's okay.
As long as we stay in this house they're not going to do anything.
We have like caustic olives.
We live on the second floor.
I live in this.
They're not going to see me.
If I live in this bathroom.
Wait.
Do you guys have any nades?
I know Wig has none.
Zero.
Okay wait.
You guys each take a thermite so we can just throw nades at everyone.
I'll stay up here.
They'll never expect it.
Oh my.
Wait.
What the fuck?
Oh yeah.
So we can get up there.
There's two spots right here.
There's another one right here.
Hi.
Well I mean.
Wig's gigantic head is.
I feel like if I go here they will never look up.
They always look at the stairs.
And I can easily grab a kill there.
Yeah yeah yeah.
You do that.
Yeah I'll be here.
I'll be here to contribute to my team.
That's a free nade bro.
Should I scan?
I should scan.
Nobody on the house beside us.
Yeah we should be good.
We have the doors blocked off.
I'm just going to be praying the sound comes to us.
We're so fucked.
It might pull like back here.
It could.
The hell Mary in five seconds.
If it pulls down there I really don't know what to say guys.
We had a good run.
We were just never meant to get past round two.
Maybe next year.
Do you know how to move to DC?
Oh.
It's fine we stay here.
It's going to end show.
Oh wait.
No.
No no no.
It's pulling back to us.
It's one of those surprise motherfuckers zones.
Alright how much do you want bet?
I'll bet a lot of money it does not.
I'll bet zero dollars because it is baby.
Let's go.
Oh shit.
What is this guy doing?
He's up here just chilling huh?
Wig I swear please don't get shot by like three different people.
Someone might try to find this building right now.
I got shot by one.
Yeah like I called that and you in the middle of the building.
Someone had an instant tragedy.
In this building.
Where am I?
Next floor is okay.
They can't go first floor because of my traps.
It's fine they are going to be fucked.
My traps is hurting them.
That's fine.
Just keep this house safe.
Now block our doors.
Yeah.
I'm going to scan.
I'm going to scan the house behind us.
I'm going to live here now.
Yo the fact that these guys are all coming up.
Makes it seem like.
No there is no choice.
They just have no choice.
They have to.
They have no choice.
There is no way they would know either.
There is no way this challenge is over.
They scanned this beacon over here.
Oh.
They are over here on the fence line right now.
They know I'm up here.
If these two teams fight we 100% just kill these guys.
Oh my god look at this.
They are calling this thing hardcore.
Should we have a barrel on the door or no?
Yeah we should for sure.
On the outside maybe.
They are probably going to break it.
Yeah they are going to break it.
I'll throw one there anyway since I have some cooldowns.
They are going to forget I'm up on this.
They are going to forget I'm up here.
I bet you.
There is no way they will remember.
You are so right.
You are so smart.
There is no way.
There is no way right guys?
Yeah right guys.
There is no way we get a three man shot from here.
Team full running on the left over here.
I don't know if you guys can see out the window.
I can.
I'm scanning.
Do you want me to help shoot?
Yeah sure.
I'm coming down.
Cracked one.
They died to kills.
Got one.
Nice.
I think they are full dead.
We got 2kp.
Nice job.
Pull back on us.
We hold our top floor.
We hold our top floor no matter what though.
Call the bottom floor if we need to or anything.
But you are good right now.
Just don't die for it.
I'm trying to.
I can't do the climb anymore.
I'm so close to purple armor.
I really want to try to get this.
I'm going to try to do the climb.
No I can't do the climb anymore.
It was so cool when I was able to do it.
What are you shooting me for you fucking idiot.
You guys are so bad.
I got it.
Okay.
Stand.
How many cells and bats do you have?
I have one bat and 6 cells.
Three cells.
Two bats.
Okay.
They are smoking us.
Just watch our first floor.
I'm looking first.
We are good.
They will never remember I'm up here.
Never.
We will never.
There is no way they will remember.
Okay.
I got purple armor.
I'm going to pop a phoenix for this.
I have two bats and three cells.
Okay.
Nice.
Alright.
I'm going to be honest.
I saw Doki up top.
I thought it was Tempo on the roof.
I was about to scream.
How the fuck would he get to the roof?
There is no way he would have lived.
I was like Tempo.
What the fuck?
That's the team on the roof though.
It's okay.
They will never remember me.
Is there a bolt up here that I can take?
Dude's mom is going to fight.
We will see what happens.
They are coming on the outside of us right now.
We are good.
They are over there.
One team is behind and one team is up there.
It's safe but not really.
Is there anyone still in that other house?
Yeah.
We need these two teams to fight.
They are using us as a buffer.
Yeah.
That's fine.
Follow me.
You want me to scan or you want me to see?
Tempo come first.
They needed that door.
Yeah.
We are good.
Do you want me to scan west or east?
I'm going to be honest.
Scan west side every time.
Scan this way.
That team is gone.
Oh wait.
Never mind.
They are going to probably finish her off.
They are on our first floor.
Come on.
We are good.
I'm watching first floor from up here.
They are going to fight soon.
I have a scan at five.
We are good.
We just hold our second floor with everything we have.
I should have met 50 gifted.
What the fuck?
Don't say that.
You are trolling.
Lock in.
Tempo.
Get another barrel on the balcony.
They can't really shoot out that easily.
I'm watching the window down here.
Okay.
We are staying up here.
Are they on the roof right now or no?
No.
That's great for us.
Someone needs it.
I'm good.
I'm going to try.
Someone has a Kraber.
We just stay inside.
We don't really stay inside.
Tempo.
Can you move this barrel?
This one.
And put it right next to the door right here.
I hear a lot of blood.
Let them do it.
We are good guys.
Don't go out.
Let them die.
There is literally no reason to kill.
We have two KPs.
Let them fight everything.
We are good.
We are doing great.
Phenomenal guys.
They put a barrel on the roof.
I'm still staring first floor.
I broke it.
I'm about to surrender here I think.
Do you need surrender?
No.
I'm good.
I have two ulti cells for you.
Okay.
I do not.
I have full ult.
I have not used my ult once.
There is just a random...
I'm just chilling.
We are fine.
They must be so confused with me staying up here.
We are all good.
Just keep scanning.
Wait.
Doki, grab the helm.
You are over there.
I have it already.
Scan the roof a little bit.
There is one up there.
I see them.
Top five.
Do we need three?
Probably.
I'm just going to look for more KP.
There are two guys on the outside.
There is someone going to end right in front of us.
We are good right now.
Full team on the roof.
There is a team on that door.
Okay.
Do we try to grab the roof and then...
No.
They are on the roof.
There is a full three men in this costume.
How do we get out of here?
We are going to jump down and go left.
Okay.
I'm going to break barrels.
Stay there.
This is nerve wracking.
We are going to jump down and go left on the staircase.
There is that one rat.
There is a rat right here.
Okay.
We can just rush that rat and then we could...
Yeah.
I don't know.
We are going to have to jump out and play this fence line on the left side.
Okay.
We are going to have to smoke.
I don't know.
He sees me.
We need this team to die on the right.
The one that is going to kill us is really fucking us to be honest.
Right here?
Yeah.
That team is fucking us but it's going to be really hard to do anything.
That's a good one I think.
They are putting barrels on us.
They are trying to trap us inside.
They are going to probably call us to go to the L.A.
game.
They will be smart if they did.
You need to start bringing these barrels outside.
They are putting barrels on our balcony.
You need to do it.
I can't.
It's on the outside.
I'm left.
Far left.
Just walk out and peek on the outside.
Yeah.
Right in the barrels.
Nice.
That's your job.
We just jump out of your left side late.
Let's see what these guys do.
They have to leave before us.
I'm playing my life no matter what.
Me too.
We stay alive here.
Can you scan underneath us and see where they are?
On the left side.
They are still there.
Stay inside late.
We are going to swing out left.
We are going to cost these kids too late.
Right side.
Play here slow.
I need them on the right side.
I'll just kill them on the right side.
I'm here.
Kill them.
Nice.
Top three.
Stay behind.
Do we make it?
11 points.
That was our only play.
I have no idea if it's enough or not.
11 points is a lot.
Oh my god.
I have no idea.
It's going to be so close.
That was our only play.
That was...
Okay.
That was so stressful.
That was a miracle play.
No.
One point.
Are you kidding me?
Wait.
Oh my god.
Are we actually one...
Oh.
We got four kids.
You said top three with three kids.
No.
Really?
If we got one more point, we would have tied 10th place.
But we win the tie breaker.
Oh my god.
That's so heartbreaking.
GG's man.
We did a good job.
That was the one, man.
That was the fucking one, bro.
We even tempoed your calculations.
No.
Tempo was low key almost right though.
Yeah.
We really only just needed to get a fucking snag of KP somewhere else.
We needed one more cape.
There was no way.
We're so broke.
The 10th place team will randomly...
What did 10th place get last game?
Oh, no.
They got three points last game.
If we got reaped last game, we fucking qual, bro.
Oh my god.
We reaped so hard.
I can't believe they got rid of the content team.
Wait, wait.
Better though.
We did better this week.
We always got one.
Yeah, I'll see you guys next year.
When is the next one?
Is it after Split 1 playoffs?
Actually...
When's the next one?
Yeah, it would be after...
It would be like whenever...
So LAN is May.
And then Split 1...
Split 1 would start somewhere around the end of May or early June.
So I guess that would be when it is.
End of May or early June is when CC1 should be.
Okay.
Because they have Pro League qualifiers next week.
Oh my god, chat.
I can't believe it.
We were so close.
We literally won one point.
And we won the tiebreaker off of that too.
Oh my god.
We did one more KP, bro.
We did so good.
You guys did so good dropping down.
We got the fucking...
We got both KP too.
We got both those kills.
There was no way we could get third kill.
And then that fifth kill.
There's no way we could even get third place there.
We're just dead.
We were third place.
That's the thing.
I mean second.
We were on second.
There's no way we could have gotten second place.
I can't believe it.
If we didn't get grief last game.
Remember those names.
Remember those names last game.
That's on you.
I will write those names in my death note.
Hello?
End game.
Not doing that.
We're not writing any names or anything like that.
Bro, you're so good!
It sucks for you because we missed like maybe one or two KP on that team fighting in that show.
We got two of them but there was like one more we could have got.
Yeah.
The stars were aligning too.
Oh my god.
What a heartbreaker.
Bro, shit!
We're improving.
I'll see you guys next challenge.
I had a lot of fun this week.
That was good.
Yeah, that was fun.
One month break and then we run it back.
Yeah.
Oh, I'm so down.
You know the vibes.
If we make it past day one, you're all proud of us.
That was actually a way big improvement though.
Yeah, we improved so much.
I feel like we should have been able to get that type of game every game.
Okay, so here's the thing though.
We're going to run Valk 99% of the time.
Okay.
So on Storm Point 2 then.
Yes.
Because if we avoid all the bullshit, bro, we just get top threes.
Like we just literally... because I can call zones.
Teams won't feed you inside...
feed face inside of a house because it's hard to push the caustic.
We just need to avoid the really sketchy spots, I guess, at all costs.
Like if you think there's a slight chance a dumb team will push you, guess what?
That team is dumb and they are there.
Yeah.
Exactly.
So like now we know though, like we just need to play inside spots where there's just no way they push us.
Yeah, we need to play the caustic and just get inside.
We can't be pinched anywhere.
No, nothing.
Yeah, there's like no spot where you can hold space.
Most likely they'll fucking run at us.
Yeah, that's pretty fucking evident, I guess.
Alright, we're getting better.
Next challenger circuit, you're going to see us in round three.
I actually thought we were going to make it.
What did they get this game?
They died in tenth with zero.
Oh my god.
If they died in eleventh, one more place earlier.
Oh my god, that actually is unbelievable.
Alright, well fucking GG, Ty.
I'm happy we improved though.
We got better.
I'm so proud of us.
Good fucking shit.
We got so much better and we didn't have like some team that's purposely griefing us.
No, we landed.
We landed.
We landed lightning rod and siphon too.
Yeah, we got fucked over a bit.
We're improving on our PLR.
We're improving.
Also, we looked like... to be honest, we looked way more locked in this week.
Like breaking barrel, putting barrels down.
We just looked like way better.
Yeah, getting kills.
Yeah.
Exactly.
I think we did good.
I'm proud of us regardless.
We're running back though.
Next one, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
100%.
I'm so down.
I'm so fucking down.
You have no idea.
Make my Wikipedia, guys.
Make my...
Yeah.
Where's my Wikipedia?
Actually, yeah.
We need a... we all need... we need a Wikipedia too.
Yeah, we're official.
We're official.
We're an official team signed by TSM.
Yeah, lowkey sexist.
She doesn't have one yet.
I don't want to say it.
Wait a minute.
We took off... wait.
We took off the tag.
Yeah, no, no, no.
And then we got let go by TSM because we failed the... we've got it.
True.
We only get signed while we're playing and then we got let go in between.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, we got let go because we didn't make it.
So...
We're free agents now.
We're free agents.
We did so good.
It's okay.
Next challenge is Circuit.
We're going to run it back.
Yes.
100%.
I wonder what the meta will be then.
Who knows?
Let's see.
Yeah.
Okay, we'll stick with this.
No, no, we are not sticking with this.
I don't know.
We might need this Caustic Bound Blood.
Caustic Bound Blood.
Caustic Bound Blood all the time.
Okay.
It's okay.
That's why we're like... we're not going to do the NA strat where after one bad tournament, we break up.
No, never.
We should never.
That means we're staying together forever.
We're rivals too, right?
Yeah.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I mean, if I need to win money one month to pay a mortgage, I'm sorry.
Hey, hey, hey.
I mean, look.
I mean, it's...
All right, all right.
...extract rivals might be random.
We don't know that.
This Twitch Rivals was an anomaly.
Every other Twitch Rivals we've played, we've been like middle of the pack.
What do you mean every... we've done one.
We've done one together.
What do you mean every other... this is our... that last one was our second.
What is this data pool?
We have two Twitch Rivals together.
I remember playing like four Twitch Rivals and I kept getting in the middle.
No, we played... I played one... two Twitch Rivals with you.
You guys.
Not four.
Oh, I might have played two.
I might have played two without you then.
Yeah, I probably done better than the two with us.
Yeah, you...
Oh, damn.
So, Doki was the one that was like, oh, no.
What do you mean?
Money is on the line.
We play someone else.
But I plays better.
Oh.
Whoa.
Yeah, we talking shit.
Wow.
I've placed higher definitely before.
Oh, I understand.
That's a better doubt.
I think Doki has more earnings than Teppo.
We can earn each other that.
I'm pretty sure.
My Liquipedia is out there.
I definitely have more earnings.
Alright, that's it.
Liquipedia.
I don't have a Liquipedia.
That's the thing.
Wait, you don't what?
I don't have one because they removed it.
Not even under... Oh.
Wait, they removed it?
They got removed.
They removed it because they were like...
Wait, so you had one but then they removed it.
Yeah, because they were like, it's not... the tournaments aren't official enough.
So, they removed my Liquipedia.
This one's official, right?
Yeah, but they still don't make it for me.
The moderators hate me because I'm an anime girl.
I think we have to win this.
You win money from an official tournament.
That means we have to get into Pro League and then get...
I literally win more money in unofficial tournaments.
For sure.
You definitely do.
Without a fucking...
Unofficial Apex tournaments pay more than official.
Without a doubt.
100%.
That's sad.
You're so right.
I deserve it.
GG's guys though.
GG's.
Alright, GG's though.
I love you all, man.
I love you guys so much.
Thanks for playing.
I appreciate... I know I'm not the best, but I appreciate y'all for hanging out.
No, you were great IGLs.
You did great.
You got us into the zone every single time.
Thank you.
We tried.
By the way, I bet 50 lunches on that zone poll last time.
I just... you guys... my mic just cut out and you guys just didn't hear it.
I'm just gonna say, the fact that we did better than nine other teams who scrim a lot together and who like do this for a living.
Like, I feel like, you know...
Doki plays the game once a week.
Yeah.
That's weird.
That's what... that's when we play this.
I think I play less than anybody else.
Yeah, I literally... we literally don't even scrim and we did better than like nine other teams?
That's on them.
No, we did so good.
That was fucking fantastic.
That was pretty good.
Worst part about that, if that's a trio down below and we kill them, we win.
Yeah.
We kill a duo, which sucks.
Yeah, we... it was a duo.
It's coming up.
It's coming up where we jumped off.
No, oh no.
They're gonna be like, no!
Alright, GG's though, guys.
GG's.
Alright, GG's.
I love y'all, man.
Bye-bye.
I'm gonna go talk to my chat and cry.
Love you guys so much.
Yeah, I'll talk to my chat.
It'll be a 10-minute delay.
I'll see you guys later.
Bye.
Oh yeah, 10-minute delay.
Love y'all.
Oh my god.
We were so close.
But we already played Apex for like four hours now.
So I'm just happy we did really well.
I feel like we're improving more and more as a team.
And it's like our character arc.
Each challenger circuit you go.
You see us get better and better.
So you're here for the journey.
You're gonna see us in round three.
Next challenger circuit.
Which is like what?
In like two to three months or something.
Don't worry, guys.
Don't worry.
Next challenger circuit.
It is a character arc.
You're here for the besties journey.
We're gonna have the revenge revenge arc.
I believe in us.
Anyway, thank you guys as always for supporting us and for watching me.
I always, always do appreciate it.
I have so much fun just hanging out with the besties.
I love just, you know, even though like, you know, it's a competitive thing.
I just do have fun.
Do have fun just hanging out and like talking shit with the besties.
Because it's like our hangout session.
It's not just like a competitive tournament.
It's literally a hangout session too.
But yes, thank you, Dragoons.
As always, everybody stay hydrated, posture check, get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.